on a vu une interruption avant
le dîner et des sénateurs sceptiques
autour du pass voire même c'est vrai
même des sénateurs qui sont sceptiques
autour de la vaccination ça a valu et
bien une petite
phrase de bernard jomier le sénateur
apparenté ps et qui s'en est directement
pris à didier raoul tu disons que le
professeur de médecine avait pu
alimenter certaines thèses anti vaccins
je vous écoute et bernard je mets un peu
plus tôt dans l'après midi le directeur
de l'institut hospitalo universitaires
méditerranée le professeur out tient des
propos qui discrédite le vaccin cet
institut est financé largement sur fonds
publics ça devrait être le vaisseau
amiral des maladies infectieuses en
france c'est la boussole qui indique le
sud et le maintien de libéra août à la
direction de cette ia chu est un
scandale national il décrédibilise notre
politique sanitaire il désorienté
français il alimente le discours ans
steve at il faut prendre vos
responsabilités monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre pardon
encore une fois le même labsus
décidément il faut prendre vos
responsabilités lui répondre
publiquement
écoutons la réponse d'olivier verront
effectivement la mise la santé qui était
sur le banc des ministres acp sont là il
a voulu répondre aussi aux sénateurs les
plus sceptiques sur la vaccination qui a
vu l vous perdez des effets indésirables
de cette vaccination écouté lui et
veyran pour rebondir se fatiguent
sénateurs jonnier je le rejoins monsieur
juillet sur sur ce point là je
j'aimerais qu'il y ait un peu plus de
voix qu'ils se fassent entendre pour
promouvoir le vaccin vous avez été un
certain nombre à le faire mais toutes
les petites attaques toutes les petites
piques qui sont portés les effets
indésirables
intel a dit qu' on pense que est ce
qu'on est sûr que tout cela mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs participe je le
pense en sincérité je le pense en
sincérité a créé de la confusion chez
nos concitoyens qui vous regardent qui
vous écoute et cela ne nous aide pas à
atteindre la couverture vaccinale que
nous espérons voir et que vous m'invitez
en règle générale à atteindre
voilà vous êtes bien en direct sur
public sénat dans un instant nous allons
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle
poursuivre l'examen du projet de loi 2
passes vaccinale mon l'a compris il ya
eu un peu plus tôt dans l'après midi des
échanges un peu houleux autour de la
vaccination avec dessinateur très
sceptique sur cette vaccination qui se
sont comptées ils étaient douze au total
on les a comptés lors d'un vote en
scrutin public ça va lui aussi cette
petite mise au point d'une sénatrice
salaires marie mercier ecoutez-la sur
l'intérêt de la vaccination par rapport
au simple fait de se tester
les services sont saturés lire et à son
thrombose et c'est même pour ça qu'on
vaccine et surtout les soignants sont
épuisés et ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux ces soignants dont font partie
les jeunes internes qui ont été
contaminés lors des premières vagues ces
jeunes internes qui ne comptent pas
leurs heures il y a dans le journal de
saône et loire ce matin à grand titre
nos héros sont fatigués les héros sont
épuisés et ce sont nos soignants j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure pourquoi il
valait mieux quelqu'un de vacciner kovy
plus plutôt qu'à non vaccinés avec un
test négatif aux tentes et je ne
recommencerai pas cette explication mais
pour nos héros pour nos choix niant
maintenons la vaccination il faut être
20 traîné et pas testé voilà la séance 1
qui va bien reprendre d'un instant à
l'autre et que vous pourrez suivre en
direct toute la soirée sur l'antenne de
public sénat remet retour sur un autre
moment fort dans l'après midi avec une
question d'actualité autour de la
vaccination des sportifs de haut niveau
on peut le dire un amendement djokovic
qui a été examiné en quelque sorte tout
à l'heure avec cette question faut-il
exempté de passes vaccinale les sportifs
professionnels ou les sportifs de haut
niveau écouté les arguments de michel
savin qui proposait cette exemption
ainsi que et bien la réponse du
rapporteur et l'ère philippe bas
regard de leurs spécificités de leur
activité il me semble opportun de
permettre à ces sportives exercer leur
activité principale
sur présentation d'un poste sanitaire
comme c'est le cas actuellement il est
important d'étendre cette possibilité
aux sportifs étrangers
vous l'avez on vient le signaler qu'ils
vont venir participer à des compétitions
en france en effet tous les pays
n'impose pas les mêmes obligations
vaccinales et il est important de
sécuriser la participation du de
sportifs étrangers une compétition se
déroulant sur le territoire français les
grands sportifs
les étrangers qui viendraient dans des
compétitions en france
aussi bien que nos grands sportifs
français
sont des personnes dont la notoriété
et l'admiration qu'il suscite sont elles
qui laisse assez difficile d'en faire
une catégorie à part pour laquelle
l'exigence du pass vaccinale serait un
peu à géométrie variable comme si
l'intérêt de la compétition
l'emporté sur l'intérêt de l'exemplarité
auprès des jeunes gens d'ailleurs
voilà un la séance qui va reprendre d'un
instant à l'autre puisque la sonnerie
vient de retentir ici au palais du juste
hambourg et que vous le voyez sur ces
images qui vont s'afficher sur votre
écran géant larcher est en train de
rejoindre l'hémicycle pour cette séance
qui va reprendre d'un instant à l'autre
c'est lui qui préside ce soir la séance
qui va continuer autour de l'article 1
car il reste encore des amendements à
examiner avant même l'adoption de cet
article un parmi les pronostics un qu'on
a pu avoir ici dans les couloirs
consternant et bien la durée de l'examen
de ce texte et ce soir on nous parle
d'un vague qui pourrait intervenir vers
une heure du matin fut propositions
l'examen de ce texte jusqu'au bout
direction l'hémicycle adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée
renforçant les outils de gestion de la
crise sanitaire et modifiant le code
la santé publique ça me parvenu
amendement 44 identifié quater au sein
de l'article 1er avec trois amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune
d'amendements
44 rectifié grether que présente le
viano vous avez la parole merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre le
hasard fait décidément bien les choses
puisque le ministre de l'intérieur a été
reçue hier pour parler de l'organisation
des futures échéances électorales auprès
du conseil constitutionnel mon
amendement a pour objet
de ne pas permettre la mise en oeuvre
des passes sanitaires ou vaccinaux à
l'entrée des bureaux de vote c'est un
amendement que j'ai déjà présenté à de
nombreuses reprises lors des précédents
textes d'urgence sanitaire à chaque fois
ils ont été refusées rejetée par le
gouvernement donc je pense que
d'inscrire cela dans la loi permettrait
de rassurer tout le monde sur la
nécessité absolue de préserver nos
bureaux de vote de la mise en oeuvre de
ses passes naxi no mercy à l'avant dont
191 rectifier et présentée par monsieur
ravier avait la pop merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues en cette
période de campagne électorale
l'inquiétude est grande pour nos
compatriotes de voir le pass sanitaire
de venir parce vaccinale et bientôt on
passe électorale ce mardi 11 janvier le
conseil constitutionnel évoque en ces
termes je le cite la possibilité que le
gouvernement élabore de nouvelles
mesures d'organisation qui apparaîtrait
rendu nécessaire par la crise sanitaire
afin de garantir le bon déroulement de
l'élection présidentielle et je ne cache
pas que les engagements de monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur ne me satisfont
pas parce que nous sommes habitués à ces
environnements donc je vous demande
d'inscrire trois points dans ce texte
l'interdiction de soumettre l'accès aux
bureaux de vote un quelconque passe
l'interdiction du recours au vote
électronique et par correspondance et le
rappel du droit de chacun de voter à
l'urne en personne ou de faire une
procuration pour rappel le vote par
correspondance est interdite depuis 1975
en france car ils présentaient de trop
nombreux risques de fraude le vote grâce
à des machines électroniques est permis
dans certaines communes depuis 1969 mais
il n'a pas ramené les électeurs aux
urnes il a même engendré de la méfiance
la séquence politique majeur qui s'ouvre
devant nous ne doit pas devenir un
simulacre de démocratie dans la ministre
ne fait pas monter la peur dans ce pays
pour balancer par la fenêtre nos
bulletins de vote il ne s'agirait pas
d'encourager les électeurs qui sont de
décourager pendant les électeurs qui
sont de moins en moins nombreux à chaque
élection au point que certains se sont
crus autorisés dans fabriqués dans les
ehpad marseillais le suffrage vaccinale
deviendrait le nouveau suffrage
censitaire de ce régime dans l'universel
restreint et contrôlé trois adjectifs
qui conviennent à merveille à la
politique gouvernementale actuelle pour
balayer mon amendement vous allez me
rétorquer que cela est déjà satisfait
par la crise la constitution or je ne le
crois pas pour rappel le 5 août 2021 le
conseil constitutionnel a donné son
accord pour l'instauration du pass
sanitaire sous trois conditions
le pass and i ter devait être limité
dans le ter ne pouvaient être restreints
à la seule vaccination et enfin ne
devait pas permettre le contrôle des
citoyens par d'autres citoyens on sait
aujourd'hui ce que sont devenus ces
trois conditions très assez verticale
poubelle alors mes chers collègues merci
donc par prudence peut faire bon accueil
à cet amendement merci monsieur le
président le monde ment 12 rectifié bis
et madame noël qu'il préside il défendu
non monsieur duclos
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre
moi je suis favorable à cet amendement
alors peut-être qu'on explique un tueur
de vote oui bah oui je pensais que cette
heure d'explications d'autres puisque on
a fini de l'avis de la commission et du
gouvernement
je veuille
l'avis de la commission sur ses abords
de mort
c'est le président mes chers collègues
mais vraiment si j'avais pensé qu'il y
avait le moindre risque j'aurais été le
premier à proposer à la commission des
lois un amendement de ce type et vous
expliquer pourquoi cette inutile tout
simplement parce que de la même façon
que pour le pass sanitaires
le pass vaccinale ne peut être exigé que
dans des lieux limitativement énumérés
par la loi elle-même et mieux encore
quand il est exigé dans un des lieux qui
n'est pas énumérés par la loi
il ya des sanctions pénales
il y à des sanctions pénales mais
mon cher collègue et vous pourrez vous
exprimer je le suppose tout à l'heure si
vous le souhaitez en ce qui me concerne
je vous confirme qu'il y à des sanctions
pénales lorsqu'on demande de passes
sanitaire dans des lieux où il n'est pas
prévu
ça fait quand même des protections
naturellement extrêmement forte les
dénégations de notre collègue laurent
duplomb que j'observe avec attention
ne sont pas des arguments
la vérité c'est celle que je vous dis
tout simplement et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
si ils nous venait à l'esprit l'idée
saugrenue de devoir énoncé tous les
lieux où on ne peut pas exiger le pass
sanitaires la liste serait très longue
car nulle part on a le droit d'exiger le
pass sanitaires et le pass vaccinale
sauf dans les lieux qui sont prévues par
la loi les bureaux de vote c'est
absolument est radicalement exclu vous
pouvez le répéter dans le texte sur tous
les tons vous n'ajouterai rien à la loi
peut-être vous serez vous fait plaisir
et moi j'aimerais aussi vous faire
plaisir mais peut-être aurez-vous
suffisamment de plaisir en sachant que
votre intention est entièrement pourvu
par le texte moi aussi je suis démocrate
exactement comme vous mais je ne
supporterais pas de telles restrictions
j'ajoute mes chers collègues que si vous
vous savez ce que c'est qu'un lieu
d'exercice de la démocratie
moi je l'ignorent totalement la
démocratie à la fois partout et nulle
part on exerce la démocratie et la
citoyenneté dans tous les endroits où se
trouve en exerce au parlement exerce
dans les communes on exerce dans les
entreprises c'est la vertu de la
démocratie que son lieu d'exercice n'est
pas
limité et par conséquent si vous écrivez
ça dans la loi et qu'un jour un juge a
statué ne sera pas ce que vous voulez
dire parce que vous ne dites rien quand
vous dites cela dont je me permets de
vous dire mais avec beaucoup de fougue
parce que je suis comme vous attaché à
la démocratie que on n'a pas besoin de
cet amendement il même qu'il est
contre-productif parce que il faudra à
ce moment-là énumérer tous les autres
lieux où le pass vaccinale sera interdit
et vous n'avez pas fini d'en discuter si
vous rentrez dans ce genre de
gymnastique alors l'avis est défavorable
monsieur le président
très bien à vis du gouvernement madame
d'amis mais ma vie va se presser
alors je suis saisi de demain deux
demandes d'explications de vote monsieur
du plomb tout d'abord
servez
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président excusez moi
d'avoir pris la parole à un moment qui
n'émettait pas autorisés ce que je
voudrais dire aux rapporteurs la
première chose c'est que ma grand mère
disait il vaut mieux un soutien que deux
tu l'auras et qu'à un moment donné quand
on a écrit quelque chose on est au
dessus on n'est plus sûr de ne pas y
revenir alors je veux bien qu'on nous
dise qu on est rassuré par la
constitution qu on est rassuré par nos
institutions mais je rappelle quand même
que le conseil d'état en juillet disait
du pass sanitaire qu'il était obligé de
laisser la possibilité de présenter un
test négatif pour pouvoir rentrer
simplement dans un restaurant ce même
conseil d'état aujourd'hui ce rognés à
travers le pass vaccinale puisqu'il dit
exactement inverse en dix ans pour
entrer dans un restaurant demain le test
ne suffira plus il suffira d'avoir il
faudra avoir un pass vaccinale
hier comme par hasard comme par
enchantement peut-être un faisceau
d'indicés ou peut-être pas le ministre
de l'intérieur chargé de l'organisation
des élections et en particulier des
élections présidentielles rencontre le
président du conseil constitutionnel
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
communiqué du conseil constitutionnel
pour parler pour pourra discuter et
mettre en avant des évolutions possibles
sur la tenue des élections
présidentielles alors je suis pas
complotistes je ne suis pas quelqu'un de
pessimiste
je ne suis pas quelqu'un d'anxieux mais
je me dis qu'à un moment donné quand il
ya un faisceau d'indicés aussi important
est ce que le principe le principal et
j'entends l'argument de philippe bas
nous dire il faudrait nommer
explicitement la totalité des sites mais
la plupart des sites dont on pourrait
nommer on peut s'en [__] pour la
démocratie le seul site qui compte pour
tenir la démocratie c'est le lieu de
vote et que dans ce parlement c'est en
particulier au sénat on a besoin de
pouvoir démontrer que ce lieu-là et de
le lieu le prix beaucoup plus précis et
le plus important de la démocratie c'est
bien le lieu de vote alors votre couple
votons cet amendement et on rassure à
nos électeurs
monsieur hervé merci monsieur le
président madame unis je vais cher
collègue moi je vais voter l'amendement
tidiane noël et des collègues qu'ils ont
co signé et je vais vous dire monsieur
rapporteur peau pourquoi et et de
manière très précise la première des
choses c'est que en matière de vie
démocratique on nous avait promis que
jamais au monde ne demanderait le pass
sanitaires pour accéder à des meetings
politiques à des réunions publiques de
la campagne présidentielle
il se trouve qu'à l'assemblée nationale
madame la ministre 1 dans le texte a été
ajoutée cette faculté pour les
organisateurs de demander la
présentation d'un pass sanitaires ou
d'un test pardon c'est leur droit mais
en fait on attendait l'arbitraire il
arbitraire n'est pas l'arbitraire en
france il n'est pas entre les mains de
l'organisateur du meeting le droit
d'aller dans un meeting politique pour
un citoyen quel qu'il soit c'est pas
épauler mi-temps les meetings politiques
de la présence hier la ministre c'est
fait aussi pour les points pour le porno
pour nos concitoyens
et donc moi je crois vraiment que cet
amendement il est il est nécessaire pour
préserver et garantir le set ce droit
d'accès aux
lieux qui sont les lieux de l'exercice
du vote était rappelé pas par laurent
duplomb de manière très claire et donc
moi je pense qu'ils vont vraiment que
monsieur opère
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues je n'ai pas la même
grand mère que monsieur du plomb mais ma
grand mère bourguignonne disait la même
chose je ne fais pas confiance à ce
gouvernement il ya ce vraiment la
république qui a quelques heures
quelques jours à piétiner l'article 5 de
la constitution
ce président disant j'emmerde les non
vaccinés et
imaginons que la situation française se
dégrade et qu'il applique l'article 16
de la constitution
il aura tout l'est du lait tous les
pouvoirs il aura le pouvoir justement je
pense que je ne suis pas un constituent
ni alice miller a le pouvoir de obligé
le le pass vaccinale dans les lieux de
vote madame noël vous vouliez expliquer
votre vote
oui merci monsieur présent moi je
m'étonne monsieur le rapporteur de
l'avis que vous émettez sur mon
amendement puisque au mois de novembre
dernier vous aviez émis un avis de
sagesse ce qui avait d'ailleurs permis
au sénat de l'adopter à 6,6 là je
pourrai pour sortir les les les débats
c'était très clair d'autre part qu'est
ce qui nous empêche au vu des dernières
déclarations
qu'est-ce qui nous prémunit de ne pas
voir un jour une déclaration disant que
pour nous prémunir du risque
que les non vaccinés pourrait
éventuellement faire courir sur les
vaccinés et bien qu'on ne prévoira pas
un vote électronique ou encore impasse
vaccinale à l'entrée du bureau de vote
on peut s'attendre à tout on est on va
de reniement reniement depuis un an
rappelez vous les premiers prémices du
pass vaccinale du pass sanitaire ce
qu'il était et ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
neuf mois après donc pardonnez moi mais
moi je préfère l'inscrire dans la loi et
bien pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je vais soumettre
maintenant au vote ces trois amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune
evènement 44 rectifié doit taire ceux
qui sont favorables à son adoption de
manifestants devant la barre
avis contraire
n'est pas adoptée il en est de même pour
les deux autres amendements
nous allons va t'en passer à au vote sur
l'ensemble de l'article 1er
il est il des demandes d'explications de
vote l'ensemble
madame la présidente
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre sans surprise et même si nous
sommes très favorables à la vaccination
nous voterons contre cet article premier
qui instaure donc le pass vaccinale bien
qu'il faut le reconnaître commission des
lois se soit évertué à en revoir les
contours et les modalités le caractère
temporaire cas du ray les critères
d'occupation de nos hôpitaux et de
couverture vaccinale à 80% est pour nous
plus qu'hypothétique
en effet à l'heure où la quatrième dose
de vaccin est déjà évoqué comment ne pas
douter d'une stabilisation de la
définition du schéma vaccinal complet et
ainsi un recul assez sont dans le temps
de ce taux d'atteinte de couverture
vaccinale à 80% en outre invoqué comme
critère l'accueil de moins de dix mille
patients dans les hôpitaux revient à
conforter le gouvernement qui légifère
pour pallier les carences de deux
hôpitaux publics dont il est lui-même en
grande partie à l'origine aussi tous ces
efforts sont à saluer mais accompagne
pour ainsi dire les cheminements du
gouvernement et ne remettent absolument
pas en cause la logique sécuritaire
autoritaire en cours qui devrait être
renversé selon nous au profit d'une
logique de gestion purement sanitaire et
sociale de la crise nous nous nous
félicitons au tout de même à l'issue de
la discussion de cet article de
l'adoption de notre amendement disant à
exonérer du passage aux finales les
déplacements de longue distance par
transports publics à terre régionaux en
cas de motif impérieux pour se rendre à
la convocation d'une juridiction ou
d'une autorité administrative ou chez un
professionnel du droit
deux autres de nos amendements itw à
adopter avec l'ensemble un ensemble
d'amendements identiques en discussion
commune et nous saluons en ce sens leur
ville le revirement salutaire de la
commission des lois et de nos droits de
notre rapporteur sur l'importante
question des contrôles d'identité qui
reste heureusement une prérogative des
forces de l'ordre espérons mes chers
collègues que cela passe la rampe de la
commission mixte paritaire
jimena roche
sans surprise j'avais entendu nos
troupes ne votera pas cet article de ce
projet de loi bien entendu nous pouvons
nous féliciter et
des avancées qui ont été faites grâce au
travail la commission de l'eau et de son
président et des quelques votes que nous
avons obtenus ici ou de quelques heures
de discussions sur certains points comme
par exemple le contrôle des papiers
d'identité
les exceptions pour les déplacements
lointains dont a parlé
notre collègue a les stars mais
néanmoins oserais je veux dire nous
avons une discussion décousu dans
laquelle très manifestement nous voyons
bien que la loi ne correspond pas aux
objectifs que le gouvernement annonce
mais correspond bien par contre à une
politique qui n'est pas une politique de
diminution de la propagation du virus ni
même une réelle politique sanitaire de
lutte contre la pandémie mais qui es tu
un nouveau projet de loi qui n'est pas
un projet de loi d'urgence sanitaire
mais qui est un projet de loi d'urgence
politique disons le clairement et nous
avons marqué effectivement que comme je
le dis dans la déclaration générale la
droite républicaine
roumègue grommelle mon gré modifié à la
marge le périmètre où certains éléments
de cette loi mais par contre va
accompagner une nouvelle fois le
gouvernement dans une nouvelle loi
d'urgence
avec vraisemblablement un certain nombre
d'arbitrages qui seront faits qui seront
discutés non plus par le parlement tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui dans toute sa
diversité mais par la commission mixte
paritaire en fonction d'accords qu'ils
iront en fait la droite républicaine
majoritaire au sénat
et la république en marche majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale sur fonctionnement
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter sur un
projet de loi aussi important pour nos
concitoyens que celui ci après
la révolte et la résignation c'est une
lassitude qui va peser sur la sur la vie
sociale de notre société pendant des
années et des mois donc pour toutes ces
raisons là nous nous opposons à ce
projet loi et nous nous opposons bien
entendu à cet article y compris avec les
modifications qui a été apportée ici par
notre parlement
même si on à richard
le président en peu de mots nous avons
notre groupe a les réserves sur deux ou
trois des adjonctions qui ont été
apportés par la majorité du sénat et qui
nous semble affaiblir certains des
certains éléments d'efficacité du pasj
vaccinale mais comme
l'article premier entraîne la création
et la mise en en e2 se passe vaccinale
avec l'essentiel même de ses effets
positifs nous soutiendrons à l'exception
d'une collègue nous soutiendrons
l'article 1er je recherche
merci monsieur le président on en a mis
ce mais chaque collègue en peu de mots
également je voudrais simplement vous
redire
mon regret ne pas pouvoir voter cet
article 1er malgré ce que j'ai déjà dit
d'ailleurs lors de la discussion
générale sur cet article à hyères malgré
les efforts
très importants
subsistent en sus substantielle de
monsieur rapporteur respectivement
madame la rapporteure des deux
commissions des efforts des deux
commissions mais pour les raisons déjà
indiqué je ne pourrai véritablement pas
voter cet article je le regrette
j'insiste vraiment sur les l'encadrement
important qui a été apporté à ce projet
de loi à travers cet article va en
parler de commissions et pourtant malgré
tout je ne pourrais pas le voter pour
les raisons indiquées jouer un jeu sans
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le président je reste
profondément guadeloupéen je représente
ici les élus de la guadeloupe et les
guadeloupéens compte tenu de la
situation particulière dans laquelle se
trouve la population guadeloupéenne
compte tenu du taux de vaccination
insuffisamment c'est vrai pris en compte
par la population et même si il y à une
augmentation tous les gestes rognant que
chez la population je ne peux pas me
permettre de voter c'est un type d'une
part je ne suis pas anti pacs je n'ai
jamais été j'ai eu un premier schéma
vaccinal incomplet plus un deuxième
d'après les dispositions qui ont été
prises et pour éviter qu'on ne pense
qu'à j info parce ça a été fait ici au
sénat donc les preuves sont ici même au
syndic médicale première chose deuxième
chose monsieur monsieur président
excusez moi mais je ne peux accepter que
le travail des élus ajoutez 1 qui a été
proposé à l'assemblée nationale adopté à
l'assemblée nationale soit récusé ici
donc je ne peux accepter de représenter
une population qui en difficulté
aujourd'hui parce qu'une minorité c'est
vrai mais en difficulté l'ensemble de la
population alors moi je ne peux pas
accepter et j'avoue très content alors
je n'ai pas de problème par rapport à
mon groupe mais à titre personnel je
voterai contre l'autisme à ce qu'ils
feront ils feront le chat qui est le
leur mais je veux qu'ils respectent le
mien je vous remercie madame la ministre
pour les deux amendements de monsieur
théophile et de monsieur lurel pour
lesquelles vous avez donné un avis
favorable et j'espère que vous ferez au
mieux pour que la situation de la
guadeloupe soit différente de celle que
je connais aujourd'hui je vous remercie
madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre elle collègues je
reste sceptique face à la logique de ce
texte est particulièrement de cet
article 1er et ce malgré les
améliorations apportées par la
commission et par le rapporteur
monsieur bah et aussi bien sûr par notre
assemblée obliger toute la population à
se vacciner et enchaîner les dose de
rappel sous la menace d'une fiction des
libertés et permettrait selon le
gouvernement de stopper l'épidémie est
de diminuer la pression sur le système
hospitalier
déjà bien malade ce n'est pas l'avis de
l'om est ce qu'ils affirment que des
programmes de rappel sans discernement
ont toutes les chances de prolonger la
pandémie plutôt que d'y mettre fin une
nouvelle fois l'exécutif semble céder à
la panique
marginalisée tue toute une partie de la
population par l'instauration d'un pack
vaccinale n'est pas une solution viable
le ciblage la protection des publics à
risque devraient + horizons la pédagogie
auprès des plus réfractaires devrait
continuer l'utilisation des marques
offertes et de renforcer l'alternative
d'un traitement médical développé le
gouvernement oublie la prise en compte
du caractère international de la lutte
contre l'épidémie le variante delta
venaient d'inde au micro-ondes afrique
du sud des pays où le taux de
vaccination restent faibles faible une
levée des brêles des brevets est
indispensable pour limiter la
circulation des marion bien sûr nous la
france nous ne pouvons pas nous se lever
les brevets vu que nous ne fabriquons
pas de vaccin en revanche bien sûr là il
faut qu'il y ait des accords européens
et avec les états unis qui sont les
principaux fabricants de
deux vaccins je les ai reçus avaient de
l'importance et de l'efficacité du
vaccin je suis va signer trois font
conclure oui mais il n'est cependant
jamais bond a su mentaliser le médical
pour faire de la procure motors fini de
manipuler les français pourrait qu au
culte et les amandinois la macro je
voterai contre je ne prends pas la
parole souvent mais bon je m'excuse
dépassés montant du bail je suis heureux
et je demande à chacun de respecter le
temps s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
président ma vie c'est sûr collègues
d'abord avant de donner mon explication
de vote sur cet article 1er je voudrais
saluer l'évolution qui a été fait en
séance hier soir sur la question des
contrôles d'identité monsieur le
président dans la question préalable que
j'avais déposé ça faisait partie des
deux problèmes principaux à mes yeux de
ce texte d'avoir 7 qui est cette faculté
donnée à des dires récents au sein de
l'établissement de contrôler l'identité
de nos compatriotes en parallèle du pass
vaccinale le sénat dans sa sagesse est
revenu là dessus merci monsieur le
rapporteur et je compte sur les
sénatrices et sénateurs qui
représenteront la haute assemblée à la
commission mixte paritaire pour que cet
élément là soit absolument conserver
dans le texte final mais il reste je
passerai le pass vaccinale et n'ai
jamais voté depuis le début neil pas
sanitaire sous aucune forme de ce qu'une
forme parce que je pense que
philosophiquement et politiquement il
pose des problèmes considérables mais
ils posent au delà de ces problèmes
politiques et philosophiques sur
lesquels je suis revenu hier un problème
concret c'est son utilité sanitaires le
pass sanitaire demain le pass vaccinale
ne limiteront en rien la contamination
d'un virus qui se propage entre vacciner
et je le redis je suis bien placé pour
vous en parler puisque d'en vacciner moi
même j'ai contracté ce
cette maladie là il ya quelques comment
non je n'en suis pas mort il m'en
félicite d'ailleurs maintenant sinon je
ne serais pas là enfin je profite
d'avoir la parole monsieur le président
pour alerter le rapporteur sur le fait
sur les sanctions pénales en cas de
mauvais usage de mauvais contrôles du
pass sanitaire demain vaccinale il nie
il n'y a pas ou très peu de sanctions
pénales quand le pass sanitaire est
utilisé à mauvais escient et au mauvais
endroit
on combat et c'est normal les faux-pas
sanitaires on devrait combattre la
mauvaise utilisation du pass sanitaire
de manu plaza finale dans notre pays les
gens pénales prévues dans la loi y
entrer lourdes bagatelle
président madame la ministre avec
gravité parce que je crois que le sujet
est extrêmement grave en conscience et
en responsabilité beaucoup de sénateurs
centristes votent orange cet article 1
avec une profonde gratitude aussi pour
le travail remarquable et raisonnable
qui a été accompli par la commission des
lois et des affaires sociales aucun
d'entre nous n'a voulu n'a choisi et n'a
provoqué une telle situation mais je
pense que il nous appartient tout en
respectant les convictions des uns et
des autres d'abord de saluer la qualité
du débat dans cet hémicycle est de
reconnaître que face à cette difficulté
il convient d'accepter
adopter des mesures qui sont sans doute
parfois
discutable mais qui permet trop en tout
cas sinon d'enrayer du moins de vivre
cette situation de la manière la moins
difficile et que je voudrais en plus
nous rappeler mais si je suis
extrêmement honoré que cette assemblée
et cette dignité que nous avons une
responsabilité par rapport un certain
nombre de rumeurs ou d'emballement qui
nous font parfois perdre le sens commun
puis monsieur sueur
monsieur le président notre groupe
d'abord mes chers collègues se réjouit
du fait que sur cet article 1 nous ayons
eu un débat peu vrai
dans une certaine sérénité
je pense que c'est très important que le
sénat donne cette image
vous le savez nous allons ont pris
position dans la solitude mais dans la
clarté pour l'obligation vaccinale
notre groupe considère
que le pass vaccinale se rapproche de
notre position même si d'une certaine
façon c'est une obligation vaccinale
déguisé toutefois nous serons logique et
la grande majorité de notre jeu gros il
y aura quelques exceptions votre à cet
article 1er
et nous le voterons d'autant plus
qu'il y a eu des apports du sénat que je
tiens à souligner pour ce qui est du
réalisme par rapport aux jauges
pour ce qui est de la prise en compte de
la situation des mineurs pour ce qui est
des décisions prises par les différents
par an et par un parent par rapport aux
jeunes de 5 à 11 ans mais surtout
surtout
cette position très importante
sur le respect de l'état de droit
les restaurateurs vont exiger le pass
vaccinale mais c'est la police la
gendarmerie qui est fondé à demander les
contrôles d'identité
monsieur le rapporteur vous le savez ce
sera très important et vous le savez que
ces positions fortes du sénat soit prise
en compte dans la commission mixte
paritaire je vous remercie merci
madame et le rhône
monsieur le président chers collègues
en premier j'aimerais remercier à mon
tour notre rapporteur philippe bas pour
tout le travail et madame des roches
pour le travail réalisé pour
encadrer et améliorer ce texte
j'aimerais remercier aussi notre
président de groupe bruno retailleau qui
a permis qu'une autre voix s'élèvent au
sein de notre groupe l'est républicain
le gouvernement nous impose des débats
des débats très sérieux qui touche à la
profonde conscience de chacun d'entre
nous dans un temps
imparti beaucoup trop court beaucoup
trop court pour aller au fond de nos
consciences et pour prendre en compte
tout ce que peuvent vivre aujourd'hui
les français nous travaillons dans
l'urgence nous sommes agacé parce que
nous passons des jours et des nuits à
chaque fois 31 juil et 12 juillet
annonce fin juillet on se décide le 11
novembre hélas le 27 décembre entre les
fêtes de noël et de nouvel an je
j'accuse le gouvernement d'être
responsable de la tension que vivent
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens nous leur
faisons vivre des quelque chose
d'insupportable
les jours de repos n'ont pas été
respectées les jours familiaux les jours
de croyance n'ont pas été respectés et
ils ont vécu ces quelques jours encore
dans la panique encore dans l'urgence
encore dans la quiétude la censure le
manque de transparence les interdictions
les manipulations m'oriente vers a
d'autant plus grands principes de
précaution je ne suis pas anti vax
pas du tout mais
il est là je ne suis pas anti vaccins je
suis comme beaucoup d'autres citoyens
inquiète et je réfléchis quand on est
dans les justes dans la juste décision
on est dans la transparence
et sam et vous l'avez vu encore ce soir
menton de transparence je me désole de
ce que nous faisons subir aux français
aux familles aux enfants ces derniers
sont longs et donc j'ai voterait contre
cet article 1er merci de presse du
président alors monsieur je venais je
rappelle à tout le monde de respecter
son temps
merci monsieur le président
moi je voulais saluer également le
travail extrêmement pédagogique
extrêmement précis de nos rapporteur et
les remercier pour cela dans ce débat et
au moment où le mot liberté a été
prononcée tellement de fois depuis le
début de nos travaux juste peut-être une
lecture salutaire dont vous m'excuserez
c'est l'article 4 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen du 26
août 1789 qui dispose que la liberté
consiste à pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne
nuit pas à autrui
ainsi l'exercice des droits naturels de
chaque homme n'a de bornes que celles
qui assurent aux autres membres de la
société la jouissance de ces mêmes
droits
ces bornes ne peuvent être déterminées
que par la loi c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voterai favorablement cet
article 1er
madame sous le groupe
merci monsieur le président monsieur sur
le rappelait il ya peu nous avons
débattu sur l'obligation vaccinale est à
cette époque je m'étais opposé parce que
je trouvais que c'était finalement un
aveu d'échec eu de contrainte plutôt que
d'arriver à convaincre mais depuis j'ai
travaillé sur un texte qui sera présenté
demain sur le coup vide l'ont alors
autant je comprends parfaitement les
inquiétudes des gens qui nous ont
contactés se sont exprimés qui craignent
le vaccin et ses conséquences autant je
dois dire que il y a il pourrait y avoir
un million de personnes qui décrivent
plusieurs mois après des conséquences
absolument insupportable
dans la plupart des cas des gens qui ont
fait une forme légère du coc vide donc
je voudrais qu'on mettre ces chiffres en
perspective des chiffres qui sont
annoncés comme des conséquences
vaccinale est donc suite à ces travaux
et après avoir entendu des personnes qui
souffrent de kovy de long et bien je
voterai pour cet article parce que je
vais voter maintenant pour toutes les
mesures même si elles sont imparfaites
et même si elles sont des lignes du ciel
ont des limites qui pourrait tendre à
prévenir les les infections de parce par
ce virus voilà je vous remercie monsieur
théophile
président d'aig
la collègue jasmin vient de s'exprimer
mais je pense qu'elles s'expriment en
sonore
nous avons discuté de l'article nous
avons eu des apports nous avons eu aussi
des modifications dans cet article ça
c'est le débat le chemin n'est pas
terminé nous aurons la cempi nous aurons
encore des discussions il va y avoir un
compromis certainement mais la matrice
restera ce que je dis personnellement et
avec beaucoup d'avis de avec ce que j'ai
travaillé avec ceux pour lequel nous
avons travaillé ensemble sur le sujet
des élus
compte tenu du fait que je sais que la
particularité sera retenu c'est à dire
une forme d'exception pour mon
département pour les départements
d'outre-mer j'ai entendu le rapporteur
bas qui a exprimé
une petite divergence légistique je
dirais bay les choses sont rentrées dans
l'ordre puisque l'idée est là et la
conscience et l'art compte tenu du fait
que nous ne pouvons pas appliquée en
l'état dans les départements d'outre-mer
en tout cas en guadeloupe compte tenu de
ce que nous savons aussi ça m'empêche
pas de voter la loi sachant que le
chemin n'est pas terminée je voterai cet
article là pour permettre justement de
mettre de l'eau au moulin est pourquoi
nous y arrivons à trouver une bonne
solution pour nos compatriotes
mais sur le nom ville merci monsieur le
président tout simplement pour vous dire
que l'on que notre groupe les
indépendants votera en gravité en
responsabilité donc cet article un jeu
serait il vraiment le le travail de ce
débat au sein du sénat et notamment
l'apport de la commission des lois de la
commission des affaires sociales et deux
de leurs rapporteurs
respectifs qui équilibre ce texte salue
aussi
les avancées de ce texte au niveau du
sénat et notamment en matière de jauge
en matière de
dada proches et d'appréhension au niveau
des pour appréhender les mineurs et un
titre personnel
le dispositif et notamment
limitant le contrôle d'identité
à la merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues oui la
liberté est rogné par le pass vaccinale
se passe vaccinale qui va impliquer la
vaccination d'enfants parce que 5
millions d'adultes n'ont pas été
vaccinés et parce que notre hôpital est
en a élevé mais la liberté c'est avant
tout une question de
proportionnalité voilà ce que c'est que
la liberté elle est où la liberté quand
on est dans un lit draps ou quand on
subit des les effets effroyable des
colis de long la liberté ce n'est pas
les responsabilités
[Applaudissements]
madame guyon puy m'adapte et oignies je
crois le président ohio
merci monsieur le président je vais je
n'avais pas imaginé m'exprimer puisque
notre collègue fluence pardon trans
foisy chatel s'était exprimé juste avant
en partie au nom du groupe mais je vais
juste vous dire que moi aussi je vais
voter cet article 1er en toute
responsabilité et aussi en pensant aux
soignants aux soignants qui qui
attendent qu'ils soignent de nombreuses
de nombreux malades qui ne sont pas
vaccinés aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
et qui n'en peuvent plus donc je
souhaite évidemment actes et bien
entendu le travail de la commission qui
a réussi à nous faire des propositions
pour circonscrire et est proposé
finalement une mise en oeuvre de ce pass
vaccinale tout à fait en cohérence avec
les libertés publiques
le contrôle d'identité j'avais cosigné
les amendements donc je me réjouis qu'il
soit supprimé les jauges également c'est
une avancée donc le pass vaccinale oui
c'est une contrainte supplémentaire mais
c'est une contrainte supplémentaire avec
une situation particulière et une
pandémie galopante donc oui je voterai
en toute responsabilité merci aux
lecteurs
oui merci monsieur le président chers
collègues le débat est passionnant à
cette heure si
j'étais parti pour voter pour l'article
1er mai depuis que le rapporteur a pris
la parole alors l'élu l'élu polynésien
je parviens l'élu polynésien outre mais
faut pas aussi tout mélanger il ya les
territoires parce que tout le monde a
tendance ici à parler des territoires
d'outre-mer on parle des départements
mais moi je suis issue d'une
collectivité dotée d'un statut
d'autonomie
ces noms qui légiférons l'antre nos
propres lois la loi sur l'obligation
vaccinale en polynésie c'est la
collectivité qui a voté la loi sur ne
pas s'inviter c'est la polynésie alors
je suis un peu perturbé depuis tout à
l'heure à entendre que cette rare à cela
applicable avec les sanctions dans nos
territoires
je fais pas
la santé c'est la compétence de la
polynésie française les amis vous êtes
en train d'empiéter
à travers l'obligation par la loi
nationale de faire appliquer en
polynésie française vous êtes en train
d'empiéter sur nos compétences les
embouts je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
dans l'état comme c'est écrit et dit
voté pour dont vous aurez compris je ne
participerai pas aux de cet article 1er
tu me rends
merci monsieur président la ministre mes
chers collègues cette gestion de crise
et à ses légions de ce qu'il fallait pas
faire
pourtant gouverner c'est prévoir et
c'est pas la première épidémie que notre
pays traverse ni l'humanité
et lorsque certains tout à l'heure je
miserais santé nous a accusés
d'entretenir la confusion chez les
français
j'ai bien dit de retourner la question
mais qui est-ce qui a changé de pied xx
x qui est ce que qui est responsable de
tout ça
on doit se souvenir que ça fait deux ans
que ça dure a quand même évident et vous
rappeler tout ce qui a été dit autour
des masques que nous avions suffisamment
qu'il fallait réserver au choix niant
qu'il fallait pas besoin de les mettre à
les relire etc etc
donc or quand on pratique l'art du
mensonge la dissimulation et les
contradictions il faut pas s'étonner que
la crédibilité de la parole publique
évident est atteinte le pire c'est qu'on
avait tout pour réussir je rappelle que
c'est suite à une initiative
sénatoriales que l'eprus a été créé
l'eprus établissement de préparation et
de réponse sanitaire
créée en 2007 et là j'ai une pensée pour
mon ami et collègue francis delattre qui
avait en 2015 alerté sur la diminution
des mâles qui a alerté sera la mise en
danger cet établissement donc ça a été
déconstruit alors on avait les houthis a
été déconstruit et là aujourd'hui on
arrive trop tard le pass sanitaire le
pass dax inhalent si ça fonctionnait
cette volonté du tout vaccinal pour tout
le monde si c'était la volonté c'était
des radicaux rapport aux navires aux
paras vaccin va ça marche pas la preuve
et ont proposé de continuer quand
j'apprends aujourd'hui que le ms
considère que la stratégie de
vaccination basé sur des rappels répéter
a peu de chances d'être approprié ou
viable
l'ol mais ce qu on continue et on
dépense un milliard tous les mois pour
des tests moi dans mon département trois
hôpitaux sont transformées trois
hôpitaux on à 56
56 1 million 250 mille habitants il ya
peut-être des questions est-ce que c'est
raisonnable est-ce qu'on peut pas
utiliser ses moyens a conclu colossaux
je conclus que le président et les
hôpitaux nos hôpitaux a donc organisé
russe il était en cette période d'hiver
déjà submergées super
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues
ce cet article premier a été riche riche
en amendement riche en débats et comme
tout le monde je salue le travail de la
commission qu à
capuche etc a amendé mais je ne je ne me
reconnais pas dans
dans cet article 1er et
tu senti peu des coudes de la part du
ministre
est
ce parce vaccinale c'est une obligation
vaccinale déguisés comme l'a dit jean
pierre sueur
les soignants sont obligés ce soit de se
vacciner et les soignants ou
en cas d'effets secondaires droit à une
indemnisation par l'oniam
en cas de vaccination
la population n'aura pas droit à cette
indemnisation par l'oniam donc il ya
nous sommes vraiment dans une rupture
d'égalité on a parlé beaucoup de liberté
parlons d'égalité
nous sommes dans une rupture d'égalité
entre les soignants entre les citoyens
les soignants qui auront droit à une
indemnisation est le peuple qui n'aura
pas droit à cette intimidation et je me
poserai à cet article 1er merci ouais
non
alors dont vous aviez demandé et oui
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président j'ai
n'étonnerait personne en vous disant que
je voterai évidemment contre cet article
1er je reviendrai pas sur les raisons je
me suis suffisamment exprimé tout au
long de ce sujet j'entends la plupart
d'entre vous nous dire que grâce à ce
passe vaccinale on va permettre de
diminuer le nombre de personnes non
vaccinées en réanimation
très bien madame la ministre votre
gouvernement nous le dit à longueur de
pages publicitaires on peut débattre de
tout sauf des chiffres alors moi
j'aurais juste une question à vous poser
pourriez vous nous définir précisément
précisément ce que vous mettez dans la
catégorie des non vaccinés parce que
vous savez il ya beaucoup de citoyens
aujourd'hui qui suivent nos débats on
reçoit beaucoup de messages pour nous
demander des précisions qu'est ce qu'on
met dans la catégorie des non vaccinés
est ce qu'il s'agit de gens qui n'ont
encore reçu aucune dose est ce qu'il
s'agit de gens qui ont un schéma
vaccinal incomplet ce n'est pas la même
chose ce n'est pas la même chose donc
j'aimerais juste avoir un
éclaircissement merci beaucoup trop de
vent nous prédit lors auteuil où
monsieur le président madame la ministre
la grande majorité de mon groupe votre à
l'article 1er qui institue le pass
vaccinale mais je voudrais dire le sens
de notre vote nous avons une arme c'est
le vaccin ce n'est pas la seule arme
elle n'est pas totalement parfaite elle
ne bloque pas les contaminations mais
elle a un immense avantage les rappeler
et répété hier soir c'est que elle
prémunit contre les formes graves
nous avons plusieurs enquêtes désormais
qu'ils nous montrent que ya une
fourchette entre 70% et de 90 % des lits
en soins critiques et en réanimation qui
sont occupés par des personnes dans le
schéma vaccinal
et ce quoi nul ou soit incomplet et
encore pour ceux qui sont vaccinés et
qui sont dans ces services là beaucoup
beaucoup une forte proportion sont des
personnes qui sont immunodéprimés et moi
je ne veux pas je les dis reçoit aussi
du tri je ne veux pas de la
déprogrammation qui enlève autant de
chances de survie à tant de nos
compatriotes c'est un principe de
responsabilité et notre position c'est
le principe de responsabilité depuis le
départ nous voulons la responsabilité b
madame la ministre nous voulons aussi la
proportionnalité la commission a bien
travaillé et tous les groupes ici jean
pierre sueur le rappelait tout à l'heure
nous avons contribué je crois la plupart
des groupes à renforcer cette
proportionnalité je ne citerai pas les
amendements qui ont été adoptées en
revanche madame ça n'est pas pour nous
en le votant cet article 1 le patac
sinal une façon de donner quitus au
gouvernement sur sa politique accident
il ya un manque d'anticipation l'avait
spectaculairement sur notamment
l'éducation nationale pourquoi ne pas
avoir équipé toutes les classes de
france ça revient parce que c'est une la
politique publique bien sûr à l'état il
y a aussi un problème de lits de nombre
de lits de réanimation la cour des
comptes a fait un rapport et elle a dit
que ces services là on était l'angle
mort du ségur de la santé et nous sommes
encore le pays où le taux de vaccination
des plus fragiles et sans doute le plus
faible voilà madame nous appliquons à
nous-mêmes ce principe de responsabilité
nous ne donnons pas quitus au
gouvernement mais nous voterons
majoritairement lepage accident mais
refuse
chers collègues j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par la commission et par le groupe air
des pays
il va donc les procédés au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 de notre règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
ouais
voilà vous le vivez en direct sur
l'antenne de public sénat il ya en ce
moment même un scrutin public sur
l'ensemble de l'article 1 de ce projet
de loi dit de passes vaccinale c'est cet
article 1 qui transforme le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale on l'a vu
aussi avec des des modifications en
séance ici au sénat depuis hier puisque
on a vu par exemple que les sénateurs
ont supprimé le renforcement des
contrôles d'identité pour les cafetiers
pour les restaurateurs de votre pass
vaccinale on a vu aussi une modification
des jauges dans les stades et dans les
salles de spectacle avec des
pourcentages d'occupation dans l ces
établissements donc la version
effectivement de du sénat est différente
de celle des députés et on a entendu
qu'une majorité des principaux groupes
politiques du sénat vont voter cette
version de l'article eu un tel qu'il a
été écrit par hé hé bien les sénateurs
on a entendu qu'une grande majorité des
ailes à une majorité du groupe ps
majorité du groupe centriste vont voter
ce texte les groupes écologistes les
groupes communistes vont s'y opposer
même s'ils sont favorables à la
vaccination ils ne veulent pas du
principe du pass vaccinale et on a
entendu d'autres sénateurs et qui
appartiennent à des groupes quelques
sénateurs aient l'air ils sont environ
une douzaine aussi loïc hervé pour le
groupe centriste eux sont opposés au
principe du pass vaccinale opposés et
également pour certains à la vaccination
en tout cas à l'utilisation de la
vaccination comme une réponse à la crise
sanitaire il ya donc en ce moment dans
l'hémicycle un scrutin public ça
signifie qu'on va voir une photo de tout
l'hémicycle et du vote dans tous les
groupes politiques c'est donc la
différence avec un un scrutin à main
levée on va pouvoir avoir comme ça et
bien une photo complète de qui vote quoi
dans l'hémicycle puisque c'est un vote
avec des cartes électroniques qu'on va
pouvoir comme ça elle savoir si dans
chaque groupe kel sénateurs votent
pourquoi les huissiers sont en train de
et bien opérer ce vote vous les voyez
ils sont juste en bas du plateau il
vérifie et que tout le monde à
l'opportunité de voter avec la carte
électronique ils vont pouvoir comme ça
rassembler tous les votes et puis ils
ont faire signe ensuite à gérard larcher
comme plus personne ne demandera à voter
alors ça prend un peu de temps parce que
il ya des groupes avec à une liberté de
vote on l'a entendu par exemple la
victoire jasmin qui est élu dans les
antilles en guadeloupe qui ne veut pas
voter comme son groupe le groupe
socialiste donc qui va devoir et bien
donné sa carte de vote et donc là le
scrutin est clos va y avoir quelques
secondes au plateau pour l'ordinateur et
puissent récolter toutes les données de
vote et on va voir s'afficher dans
l'hémicycle le résultat du scrutin
direction mystique poursuivre ce
résultat en direct sur public sénat
résultat du scrutin 73
portant sur l'article 1er en devenant
342 donc je suffrages exprimés 311 pour
l'adoption 242 contre 69 sénat a donc
adopté
[Applaudissements]
nous allons examiner maintenant
après l'article premier d'un moment
portera tic additionnel qui porte le
numéro 81 capes
monsieur le comte eux présentent
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
avant de présenter l'amendement madame
l'ami je ne je n'oublie pas que nous
aimerions avoir une réponse sur la
question des certificats de
rétablissement et de la reconnaissance
des certificats de rétablissement
établies dans l'union européenne et à
l'étranger car c'est un peu lié à la
nature de cet amendement par cet
amendement nous souhaitons demander par
la loi une modification du décret du 1er
juin 2021 qui définit les parcours
vaccinaux
toutes les solutions et toutes les
situations ne sont pas prises en compte
en particulier lorsque vous avez une
partie de votre vie ou votre vie à
l'étranger et que vous devez venir en
france et que en france vous devez avoir
une vie sociale je signale cela parce
qu'il est aussi des français qui vivent
hors de france et qui doivent avoir une
vie sociale dans le pays dans lequel ils
vivent et doivent et vacciner parce que
au 6 impasse vaccinale mais avec
d'autres vaccins je pense en particulier
aux français qui vivent en russie et qui
doivent être vaccinés spoutnik pour
pouvoir vivre en russie et donc par cet
amendement nous posons le principe que
quel que soit quels que soient les
vaccins que vous avez pu obtenir par le
passé il y a toujours une voix
éventuellement avec des vaccins pour
obtenir un pass vaccinale en france et
qu'il doit y avoir
cette voie inscrite dans le décret et
que le décret doit être pris après avis
de la haute autorité de santé ce n'est
donc pas une question de reconnaissance
de vaccins c'est juste une question
d'affirmer le droit de chacun de pouvoir
avoir le droit à un pass vaccinale quel
que soit ce qu'il a pu vivre auparavant
c'est un peu plus compliqué que la seule
reconnaissance des vaccins parce que
depuis il ya la question de la troisième
dose je prends un exemple
d'une personne qui a eu deux sinovac au
brésil qui a obtenu une dose de rappel
ce qui s'appelait dose de rappel au mois
de septembre pour pouvoir avoir un
impact sanitaire
et qui aujourd'hui voix sont pas
sanitaire affiché comme devant
s'éteindre à partir du 15 janvier
donc il faudra qu'il fasse une quatrième
dose peut-être pourquoi pas mais à ce
moment là que ce soit clairement indiqué
dans le décret après avis de la haute
autorité de santé nous voulons affirmer
ce droit chacun a droit un passant qui
se soumet à ses obligations et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous proposons ce
nous nous proposons cet amendement
l'avis de la commission monsieur le rat
pour que
défavorable monsieur le président malgré
la réalité du problème soulevé par notre
collègue parce que
l'admission d'un vaccin sur le marché
est une décision de l'agencé européenne
du médicament
et on ne peut pas la transférer au
gouvernement par une disposition
législative
même si on faisait précéder le décret
prévu d'un avis de la haute autorité de
santé dont la spécialité n'est pas
d'évaluer la qualité des médicaments la
qualité des vaccins leur innocuité et
leur efficacité
et je crois qu'on ne peut pas prendre de
mesures générales qui consisterait à
prévoir par avance qu'un vaccin devrait
nécessairement être validée je comprends
que nos compatriotes de l'étranger
prennent les vaccins qui sont
disponibles dans le pays où ils se
trouvent j'espère d'ailleurs que ces
vaccins pour 10 des effets bénéfiques
mais je ne crois pas que le parlement
puisse être juge de la validité d'un
vaccin est d'une certaine façon ce cet
amendement postule qu'il faudrait à
toute force admettre ces vaccins je
crois pas qu'on puisse le faire donc
l'avis est défavorable monsieur le
président au
même avis pour répondre à monsieur le
sénateur qui me repose la question qui
m'a posé tout à l'heure on sera clair
pour ce qui est des pays de l'union
européenne
juridiquement la situation et traitées
sauf pour un pays en l'occurrence
l'espagne et nous traitons situation par
situation pour cette législation hors
situation européenne
celle oms qui détermine les vaccins et
leur fiabilité est donc on ne pourrait
pas accorder des vaccins qui dans notre
législation n'est pas autorisée et donc
on ça reviendrait à faire un peu
n'importe quoi alors que nous sommes en
train de légiférer de manière
responsable donc ya pas de français que
de seconde zone pour nous on a très bien
compris le problème pour les certificats
de rétablissement ces mêmes conditions
que pour le pass sanitaires et donc rien
qui change sur 7 sur ces conditions donc
voilà il n'y a pas de sujet là dessus et
puis c'est pas le gouvernement français
qui décide
explications de vote
tu es revêche fleurs
merci madame monsieur le président
madame la ministre chat échaudé craint
l'eau froide et madame la ministre je me
permets d'attirer votre attention sur le
fait que en adoptant le pass vaccinale
dans quelques jours maintenant la france
s'éloigne du cadre européen du pass du
green pass de l'union va maintenant mais
ne dit pas d'où je n'ai pas fini ma
phrase pardon mais j'aimerais aller au
bout de la démonstration
les règles posées en france
seront des règles qui seront pas
forcément les mêmes que celles qui sont
en vigueur dans d'autres états l'union
européenne ça c'est purement factuel
quand le gouvernement a décidé avant
noël d'interdire aux citoyens
britanniques de venir en france pour les
vacances de le faire juste avant les
vacances de noël
nous avons interdit et des britanniques
vacciner doublement de venir dans notre
pays une giboulée des prises par le
gouvernement dans le premier semestre
2022 laura les vacances de février les
vacances de pâques le premier mois de
juillet puisque c'est une loi qui est
valable jusqu'au au mois de juillet est
ce que vous pouvez pour les citoyens
européens les citoyens britanniques et
les autres citoyens du monde regardez
comment nous pourrons garantir que les
étrangers qui viennent en france pour
des vacances pour les activités
d'affaires ou pour tout autre réseau y
compris les raisons familiales au delà
même de ce que jean yves lecompte a
évoqué quelle situation des français
établis hors de france mais ceux qui ont
l'habitude de 90 pays on est le premier
pays touristique du monde donc il faut
quand même qu'on a qu'on anticipe pour
une fois est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire comment le gouvernement envisage
d'adapter le dispositif pour que
l'économie touristique française ne
pâtissent pas trop de l'éloignement des
normes du pass vaccinale français par
rapport aux green pass européen merci
monsieur feurs
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues notre groupe
tient particulièrement à cet amendement
présenté par jean yves le conte pourquoi
parce que monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez bien vu que ce qui est demandé
c'est un décret la loi dispose qu il y
aura un décret donc il ne s'agit pas de
légiférer directement sur ces questions
parce que c'est impossible mais il
s'agit
de la situation de plusieurs millions de
nos compatriotes dans le monde il ya
ceux qui sont en europe mais ceux qui
sont sur tous les continents et
lorsqu'ils reviennent en france la
question se pose et elle ne peut être
résolu naturellement que par une analyse
très approprié à titre réglementaire de
la situation de chaque pays et ce n'est
pas du tout laxiste de notre part
puisque nous prévoyons qu'un décret pris
a pris après avis la haute autorité de
santé détermine les exigences de
vaccination qui seront requises en
fonction des vaccins qu'auront reçues
nos compatriotes dans les pays où ils
résident je vous remercie
[Musique]
le président monsieur le rapporteur vous
êtes trop intelligent et trop vivre
pourquoi ce que vous nous indiquez
je ne parle pas de reconnaissance de
vaccins
je demande simplement qu'on nous dise
comment
même après d'autres vaccins reconnu on
peut obtenir un pass vaccinale parce que
vous voyez le 23 septembre dernier le
gouvernement a publié une infographie
qui précise qu'un vacciner spoutnik pour
avoir un schéma vaccinal complet en
france doit faire deux fois le vaccin
français très bien pourquoi pas c'est
logique effectivement c'est comme s'ils
n'avaient pas puisque on reconnaît pas
toutefois
toutefois j'ai demande j'ai fait un
courrier au ministre de la santé pour
lui demander si ça avait été validés
parce que bien entendu quatre fois
vacciner sur vacciner ça mérite quand
même peut-être un avis de la haute
autorité de santé je n'ai pas eu de
réponse et la situation va devenir
encore plus compliqué maintenant parce
qu'il ya des pays qui vaccinent avec une
troisième dose qui n'est pas et rennes
donc c'est compte tenu de la
multiplicité de ces cas que nous avons
besoin d'un chemin pour chacun pour que
personne ne soit condamné pour ce qu'il
est et que pour chacun est un droit à
pouvoir continuer à exercer ses libertés
en france ce n'est pas à laxistes ce
n'est pas une question de reconnaissance
de vaccin contrairement à ce que vous
semblez croire c'est juste une question
de demander comment etc et débit le
gouvernement publie des infographies
sans validation de la haute autorité de
santé sur des recommandations vaccinales
et ça c'est important et d'ailleurs le
sénat l'avait votée au mois d'octobre
sous une forme un peu différente cette
fois-ci je précise les choses en disant
qu on peut rajouter des vaccins cissé
estimé nécessaire ce n'est pas une
reconnaissance de vaccins qui ne sont
pas reconnus par le ms ou par la nôtre
la msp c'est simplement la possibilité
de reconnaître à chaque français la
possibilité d'avoir la liberté en france
il se soumet aux exigences vaccinale
quel que soit ce qu'il a pu vivre
auparavant monsieur violent
oui merci monsieur le président et cher
collègue je voudrais juste sur cet
amendement m'inscrire dans les propos
qui viennent des tenues et notamment
aussi par mon collègue loïc hervé faut
dire que je voterai cet amendement à
défaut qu'on ait une autre solution mais
on a besoin d'une solution
l'ensemble des parlementaires de savoie
et de haute-savoie avons écrit il ya
déjà quelques semaines
c'était au mois de décembre au ministre
à mi temps due au tourisme et à mi-temps
des pme pour lui demander quelles
solutions ils entendaient prendre pour
les clientèles étrangères notamment à
partir du 15 janvier qui venaient de
pays où la réglementation n'était pas la
même que la nôtre je vous rapelle que au
delà des français établis à l'étranger
on nous avons une clientèle touristique
importante nous sommes en pleine saison
d'hiver dans des situations où après
deux années de fermeture des stations de
ski les situations sont très difficiles
l'interdiction faite par le gouvernement
aux clientèle anglaise ont créé des
conditions très difficiles aussi dans
certaines stations où jusqu'à 50 60 %
dans certaines stations de clientèle
venait de d'angleterre est donc
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de solution
donc nous souhaitons tout simplement que
le gouvernement puisse déjà nous dire
quelle est sa pratique puisque la
méthode qui consiste à dire on
n'interdit pas aux étrangers de venir
mon les empêche de le faire ça commence
à bien faire et on a besoin de trouver
de trouver des solutions donc on vous
demande quelles sont ces solutions ou
alors de prendre 7 7
mesure qui permettra plus tard au
gouvernement d'en trouver mais on est à
côté de la suisse la suisse à une
réglementation qui est différente de la
nôtre certains pays y compris comme les
anglais les enfants de moins de deux
moins de 18 ans ne font qu'une seule
dose alors que nous on en demande 3 il
ya des réglementations qui sont qui sont
différentes pour les ressortissants
européens ou étranger et donc c'est un
enjeu économique fort et c'est pas 15
sujet pour les stations de ski puisque
loïc hervé il a dit tout à l'heure
jusqu'à fin juillet c'est toute
l'économie de notre pays et notamment de
bus littoral qui sera aussi touchée dès
cet été donc madame la ministre nous
souhaiterions avoir des éclaircissements
sur ce que vous comptez faire auquel cas
la solution qu'il est proposé par nos
collègues compte me semblerait une juste
solution je crois comme
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président je
soutiendrai évidemment cet amendement de
notre collègue content parce que comme
je lé d'hier en
discussion sur l'article 1er au ministre
vers ans nous avons besoin d'un texte
réglementaire et il avait lourdement
défaut dans tous les textes législatifs
précédent et il a fallu batailler parce
que madame la ministre sur les trois
millions quatre cent mille français que
nous avons dans le monde la moitié
d'entre eux vivent hors de l'union
européenne était ce là qu'ils
rencontrent les pires difficultés
c'est cela qui sont dans des processus
vaccinaux qui ne sont pas sous le
contrôle de l'agencé européenne pour le
médicament de
des régulations européennes et c'est
cela qui rend compte quand ils viennent
en france les pires difficultés pour
obtenir un pass sanitaire parce que pour
vous faire l'histoire de manière de
manière brève lorsque la pandémie
s'est fait
de plus en plus violentes et qu' il y a
eu la campagne de vaccination nous avons
demandé qu'il y ait comme en 2009 avec
la grippe h1n1 une campagne de
vaccination de la france à travers le
tous les consulats et ambassades
le gouvernement n'a pas voulu le faire
et a préféré s'en remettre aux autorités
locales disant que cela serait plus
pratique après il a eu le pass annie
terre hélas nous avons eu le problème
puisque les différents vaccins n'étaient
pas tous ceux reconnus par l' oms et par
les autorités européennes et maintenant
avec le pass vaccinale nous avons un
nouveau problème par dessus le précédent
problème donc madame la ministre nous
avons besoin de règles claires
intelligible pour les français dans les
205 pays de la planète donc oui un texte
réglementaire est nécessaire bien je
vais soumettre
la ministre juste pour préciser que
tout à l'heure je vous ai parlé du
décret de 2 de la loi qui a été votée
ici même au mois de mai 2021 et je vais
vous dire que la seule la haute autorité
de santé et le conseil scientifique se
sont bien prononcer sur les vaccins
étrangers et donc sur la reconnaissance
de ces vaccins et la liste et précise
donc il y aura des situations qu'on peut
évoquer pour d'autres situations dans
d'autres pays que vous évoquez mais en
tout cas vous parler d'eux depuis tout à
l'heure du réglementaire et bien c'est
déjà fait donc voilà je peux pas être
plus prolixe que cela parce que c'est la
loi vous l'avez voter ici même et les
décrit ont été pris
dans columbo
intervenir
c'est tout con second vote oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur je voudrais
simplement dire que nous nous proposons
en fait une solution puisque le pass
vaccinale aujourd'hui supprime la
reconnaissance du test pcr qui était
jusqu alors la possibilité pour ceux qui
n'ont pas un parcours vaccinale reconnu
en france de pouvoir vivre normalement
cette suppression exacerbe encore les
difficultés que rencontreront en effet
ceux qui viennent de l'étranger et qui
ne présentent pas un pass vaccinale
reconnue
bien je vais soumettre au vote
ceux qui sont favorables à l'abonnement
qui porte le numéro 84 présentée par
monsieur le comte qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement de manifestants devant
l'amas
avis contraire
abstention
n'est pas adopté
un amendement qui porte le numéro 10
rectifié bâle à mulhouse brawn
monsieur le président madame la ministre
alors que la france préside l'union
européenne il convient de rappeler la
jurisprudence de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme de strasbourg 8 avril
2021 en effet en l'état la france
pourrait être mac fois condamné et
contrainte de changer sa loi il s'avère
que la cour a rendu une décision le 8
avril 2021 appelé wawrinka posant des
conditions pour la mise en place d'une
vaccination obligatoire par un état
membre soit légale dans une société
démocratique
selon cette jurisprudence pour qu'une
obligation vaccinale fois conforme à
l'intérêt de sa population il faudra
respecter quatre raisons que les
maladies soit extrêmement graves et
mortels que les vaccins soient efficaces
et les effets secondaires connus que les
sanctions de la non vaccination soit
mesuré que le statut d'objecteur de
conscience soit prêt si demain la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme devait
se pencher sur la vaccination
obligatoire de lakovic 19 en france elle
observera qu'à ce jour la colite 10,9 et
grave pour une partie de la population
pour la grande majorité notamment les
enfants la malle d'une maladie ne
conduira pas à la mort
concernant les effets secondaires il
n'existe pas de recul suffisant les
conséquences graves sont une exclusion
totale de plusieurs millions de
personnes dont les enfants concernant
les sanctions elles sont
disproportionnées puisque des millions
de français sont mis au ban de la
société est soumis à fortes amendes
c'est pourquoi il convient de prendre en
considération des objections qu'en
conscience nos concitoyens peuvent
soulever à l'encontre de la vaccination
de leurs enfants de leur propre
vaccination ou encore de la répétition
sans fin de celle ci pour ceux qui s'y
sont déjà pliés compte tenu des
incertitudes et des risques de l'avenir
il est de notre devoir d'admettre que la
conscience de nos concitoyens peut être
heurtée et mettre en oeuvre une
protection des celle ci en créant pour
tous et particulièrement pour nos
enfants le statut d'objecteur de
conscience qui mettra assauts l'avocat
d'être protégé contre toutes les
discriminations
l'avis de la commission je leur apporte
ce président il faut pas tourner autour
du pot la vérité c'est que cet
amendement
supprime l'obligation de présenter le
pass vaccinale telle qu'elle est définie
par l'article 1er que nous venons
d'adopter parce que s'il suffit à toute
personne d'invoquer sa clause de
conscience quels que soient les formes
pour échapper à l'obligation de
présenter le pass vaccinale pour aller
par exemple au restaurant ça veut dire
que cette obligation n'existe plus nous
avons voté sa création ne pouvons pas
maintenant voter sa disparition avis
défavorable
gouvernement
un avis
défavorable sur le vote je loue père
merci monsieur le président
monsieur madame et messieurs chers
collègues souvenez-vous du service
militaire il y avait une clause qui
scelle cette l'objection de conscience
et l'objection de conscience n'a jamais
empêché 99 99 francs pour cent des
français de faire leur service militaire
dont j'ai fait partie merci par d'autres
de world
we explications de vote nommés le rhône
temps de donner la possibilité à nos
concitoyens de pouvoir s'exprimer et
agir dans la profonde conscience c'est
aussi une possibilité pour les
gouvernements de sortir de cette impasse
du tout vaccinal
jeux soumis au vote ce qui sont
favorable à l'amendement 10 rectifiée
présentée par vingt mille arbres de
manifestants devant l'amas
avis contraire
abstention n'est pas adoptées ou passion
l'amendement numéro 141 il est présenté
par monsieur le président laurent
sur le président nous allons retirer
l'amendement 141 et si vous êtes
d'accord je vais donc descendre le 142
très bien il est donc retiré le 142e
bien fou
donc cet amendement vise excusez ma voix
mais cet amendement vise à mettre sur
on déballe le sort du conseil de défense
nous proposons par cet amendement
d'exclure à l'avenir le conseil de
défense comme lieu de gestion des crises
sanitaires telles que celles que nous
devons connaître la seule trace du
conseil de défense sur le plan
constitutionnel
elle se trouve dans l'article 15 du
texte qui est notre ordre juridique elle
dit le président de la république et
chef des armées il préside les conseils
de défense et comité supérieur de la
défense nationale comment avons pu enfin
nous nous trouver dans une situation où
le conseil de défense est devenue le
lieu suprême de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
en vérité l'objectif de cette manoeuvre
a été tout simplement d'installer une
gestion solitaire et autoritaire autour
du président de la république qui a
marginalisé le gouvernement marginaliser
les corps intermédiaires
marginaliser le parlement
marginaliser les collectivités
territoriales dans la gestion de la
crise et cette situation qui est un
grave dérive démocratique nous la
pensions de surcroît totalement
inefficace du point de vue de la gestion
sanitaire nous savons que les
discussions des conseils de défense sont
protégés par le secret défense ça
conduit d'ailleurs à ce que des
délibérations qui devrait qui pourraient
être mises dans le débat public du
conseil scientifique qui très
naturellement discutent de plusieurs
hypothèses ont été mises à l'abri du
débat public et du débat des
parlementaires
par ce biais là donc ça nous paraît être
totalement
incongrue inefficace et donc nous
demandons par cette afrique qu'à
l'avenir le conseil de défense ne puisse
plus être le vieux le lieu de gestion de
la crise sanitaire nous avons fait des
propositions
différentes depuis le début de la crise
et il y en a bien d'autres qui
pourraient discuter merci
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
ce président il est exact que la
dénaturation du conseil de défense et
très agaçante
moi même je suis étonné qu'une
institution qui est dédié à la défense
nationale à laquelle participe le chef
d'état-major désormais les chefs
d'état-major de chacune de nos armes le
chef d'état major particulier du
président de la république le secrétaire
général de la défense nationale le
ministre de la défense bien évidemment
le premier ministre le ministre des
finances et qui est là pour prendre des
décisions qui relèvent de la stratégie
de défense de la france puissent être
réunies pour un objet pour lesquelles
ces personnalités que j'ai cités n'ont
que peu de valeur ajoutée par rapport au
ministre de la santé au
directeur général de la santé au
directeur général de l'offre de soin au
président de la haute autorité de santé
et j'en oublie certainement et si on
réunit ces personnes sans les militaires
c'est plus un conseil de défense mais
mes chers collègues c'est une
institution qui est placé sous
l'autorité du seul président de la
république
il en fait ce qu'il en veut je conteste
formellement
la pertinence de l'utilisation du
conseil de défense pour gérer la crise
sanitaire mais je ne vois pas comment le
parlement pourrait se faire une sorte
d'intrusion dans un domaine qui relève
vraiment de la quintessence de la
responsabilité du président de la
république si vous le voulez bien cher
que les continuez monsieur le président
laurent a critiqué cette très mauvaise
pratique des institutions mais ne venons
pas voter une loi qui vient perturber la
répartition des compétences entre le
président de la république et le
parlement
merci l'avis du gouvernement
oui j'aurais une version un peu
différente bien sûr de monsieur le
rapporteur vous en conviendrez
juste pour rappeler que les conseils de
défense sanitaire
sont une formation spécifique du conseil
de défense et de sécurité nationale dont
l'existence est vu par l'article 15 de
la constitution
ils permettent de réunir les membres du
gouvernement
compétent en la matière c'est parler du
ministre de la santé mme y en a d'autres
aussi ainsi que les acteurs des grandes
institutions publiques du domaine de la
santé pour prendre les décisions les
plus pertinentes au milieu d'une crise
de l'emploi que nous connaissons qui est
une pandémie je rappelle ce n'est pas
une crise française la mobilisation du
conseil de défense dans le cadre de
cette crise sanitaire répond
parfaitement donc aux missions assignées
à cette instance et elle ne constitue en
aucun cas un contournement du conseil
des ministres ou du parlement qui ont
pleinement joué leur rôle je crois
depuis près de deux ans notre réunion de
ce soir en témoigne notamment dans le
cadre de l'examen des 12 projets de loi
relatifs à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire pour ces raisons le
gouvernement est défavorable à votre
amant alors explications de vote jean
benarroch
si d'ailleurs le groupe crc veut d'avoir
déposé cet amendement
au delà
de ce qui nous a été fournie comme
explication par la ministre et par le
rapporteur ou de là je dirais tu simple
état de fait de constater ce qui est
possible par la loi ce qui ne l'est pas
et donc ce qui est serait possible par
le président de la république nous
assistons à une véritable dérive de
l'utilisation aujourd'hui des
instruments de la démocratie qui est
fait pour gérer cette crise par le
gouvernement et par le président de la
république des décisions qui sont prises
par le gouvernement omnipotent qui se
repose sur un aréopage qui est
constituée par des gens qui sont choisis
par lui et qu'il choisit en fonction des
intérêts et des volontés de la
propagande qui est devenue la
communication autour de cette loi
sanitaire je le répète la loi qui nous
est proposé aujourd'hui c'est parti non
plus du doigt d'urgence destiné à lutter
contre le virus et contre sa propagation
mais fait partie d'une réelle d'une
réelle propagande qui est menée
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement et en
particulier par son président à des fins
essentiellement électorale et a défait
de constituer un modèle de société une
façon de gouverner et au conditionnement
vis-à-vis de notre population destiné à
justifier une certaine façon de
gouverner la france donc nous nous
opposons totalement à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui et nous partageons
absolument dans le cas de cet amendement
la position de nos amis de chez eux et
nous votre dock cet amendement sur le
président le rond
je voudrais dire à madame la ministre
que nous soyons concrets nous sommes par
exemple en ce moment face à la question
de la stratégie sanitaire concernant les
écoles le conseil de défense est il le
bon endroit pour discuter de cette
question
poser la question c'est y répondre nous
voyons bien que le problème de la
stratégie sanitaire à l'école est un
problème qui doit être débattues
démocratiquement et qui ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui avec tous les problèmes que
nous connaissons
mais pour répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur je suis très étonné de sa
réponse parce que j'entends bien qu'il
admet la dérive qui a été faite du
conseil de défense mais s'abriter
derrière le fait que nous n'aurions pas
à toucher cette question là parce
qu'elle relève des pouvoirs de la
présidence de la république ce sera en
quelque sorte entériné la
marginalisation du parlement parce que
cette manière de gérer a été utilisé
pour marginaliser entre autres choses
pas seulement mais entre autres choses
le parlement et nous le savons tous ce
dont nous devons nous ne pouvons pas
nous ne pouvons pas nous même excusez
moi
entériner cette marginalisation et je
crois qu'il est très important de dire
que nous devons revenir au plus vite à
d'autres modes de gestion de ce type de
crise parce que il est malheureusement
probable que ce n'est peut-être pas la
dernière et donc nous devons le
parlement c'est le moment où le
parlement doit dire qu'il faudra changer
le mode de gestion de ce type de crise
et n'ont pas accepté comme une fatalité
comme nous l'a dit le rapporteur cette
chose qui devrait rester cette dérive
qui devrait en quelque sorte est
désormais bas alizée
monsieur le comte
il merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
soutenir cet amendement parce que il est
très important il est très important
pour le fonctionnement de l'état
parce que un conseil de défense et le
secrétariat général de la défense
nationale qui ont assuré le le le suivi
lorsqu'il s'agit de décisions sanitaire
qui concerne le ministère de la santé
c'est en général le secrétaire général
du gouvernement qui sait faire les
choses derrière lorsque par exemple il
faut prendre un décret
au droit à un compte et de défense ça ne
fait pas et par conséquent vous avez des
annonces en conseil de défense qui un
mois après sont toujours pas mis en
oeuvre dans les décrets et comme par
hasard nous le savons en tant que
français de l'étranger parce que des
annonces qui sont faites au mois d'août
le secrétaire général du gouvernement
n'est pas présent et par conséquent sa
attend plus d'un mois avant d'être passé
en décret voilà et pendant ce temps là
le ministère de la santé n'est pas
informé de ce qui a été n'est pas
correctement informé de ce qui a été
décidé a annoncé en conseil de défense
on le sait on l'a vu à la télé mais
comme le secrétaire adjoint du
gouvernement n'était pas là pour prendre
les styles et les prendre les actions
derrière sas a attendu cinq semaines
c'est des dysfonctionnements des pas qui
ne sont pas acceptables
je vais soumettre au vote ce qui sauve
favorable à cet amendement
qui a reçu un double avis défavorable de
la commission demande manifestants
devant la marque
avis contraire
abstention
il n'est pas adoptée nous allons passer
à l'examen l amendement qui porte le
numéro 112 monsieur dessus merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement
concerne les personnes placées en centre
de rétention administrative si on vit un
certain nombre de leurs droits
fondamentaux retiré depuis le début de
cette pandémie
en effet un certain nombre de pays ont
fermé leurs frontières pour autant
continue d'envoyer des personnes
originaires de ces pays en rétention
sans pouvoir leur donner de date
d'exécution de leur éloignement depuis
la loi asile immigration la rétention
est censée être limitée à 90 jours
maximum pour autant depuis le début de
l'épidémie s'est promis cette limite est
devenu extensible d'abord de façon
totalement illégale puisque un refus de
tests pcr a suffi pour envoyer en garde
à vue un certain nombre d'étrangers pour
les replacer ensuite en rétention ces
actes illégaux ont été contestés et la
cour de cassation a confirmé leur
illégalité mais en août dernier à
l'occasion de l'examen du projet de loi
de gestion de la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement à légaliser cette pratique
en faisant voter un amendement pour
inclure dans le délit de soustraction à
l'éloignement le refus par un étranger
de se soumettre aux obligations
sanitaires nécessaires à l'exécution
d'office de la mesure dont il fait
l'objet concrètement un étranger qui
refuse de se soumettre à un test pcr sur
la renvoyer en garde à vue en détention
c'est indigne cette mesure n'est en
aucun cas une mesure sanitaire ces
mesures qui détournent nos voeux nos
mesures de gestion de crise on au
service d'une politique migratoire
inhumaines s'opposer à un acte médical
est une liberté fondamentale que l'on
refuse à ces personnes et cette
situation kafkaïenne a été pointé du
doigt à de nombreuses reprises par des
médecins des universitaires mais aussi
par des associations engagées au
quotidien auprès des retenues de ces
centres ces associations nous font
remonter qu'en réalité au quotidien à
personne ne vérifie la réalité du refus
opposé par l'étranger et son intention
véritable se soustraire à l'exécution
d'office de mesure d'éloignement
cette vérification est pourtant une
demande du conseil constitutionnel dans
sa décision concernant cet article la
politique sanitaire doit rester son seul
et unique objectif lutter contre la
pandémie elle ne serait en aucun cas
être utilisé comme un prétexte pour
renier droits fondamentaux tel est le
but de cet amendement
avis de la commission a vivement
remercié le président c'est délibérément
et en pleine conscience que nous avions
approuvé cette disposition au mois de
juillet dernier qui permet quand
est exigé un test de dépistage négatif
pour l'entrée dans le pays d'origine
d'une personne expulsée et que cette
personne refuse le test de lui infliger
une sanction pénale et c'est très bien
ainsi nous sommes non défavorable à cet
amendement
ma
vie l'explication de vote je n'en vois
pas ce qui change favorable à
l'amendement 112 le manifeste en levant
la main
avis contraire
abstention il n'est pas adoptée sous
pression l'examen avant le mans 64 il
est présenté par monsieur bonnecarrère
merci monsieur le président je vous
précise mes chers collègues que je
défendrai l'article 64 mais que après
les explications
l'amendement 64 n'est qu'après les
explications de monsieur le rapporteur
je serai amené à accepter le retrait de
cet amendement compte tenu de son
caractère organique et je vous
présenterai ensuite les deux amendements
suivant et j'accepterai le même régime
vous comprenez que la présentation des
amendements
la présentation de ces amendements en
caractères d'appel et je voudrais
prolonger la question posée cet
après-midi sur les élections
présidentielles qui n'a reçu aucune
réponse du gouvernement et je voudrais
donc alerté à nouveau le gouvernement
mais peut-être et surtout mobiliser les
différents groupes du sénat je dis bien
les différents groupes de notre
assemblée sur cette question de
l'élection présidentielle je ne suis pas
du tout sur les sujets de parrainage
mais uniquement sur les conséquences de
la pandémie premièrement nous allons
tout droit à une pandémie démocratique
où une pandémie présidentielle les
candidats ne pourront pas faire
normalement
campagne les nos concitoyens sont
réticents à se rendre dans les meetings
la distribution des tracts me paraît
légèrement le complexe
quant à l'accès aux bureaux de nous
prouve de bureaux de vote nous pouvons
imaginer que certains de nos concitoyens
soient gênés à ce titre cheveux dans
simplement observer qu'il n'ya port a
pas de vraie campagne possible et qu'il
n'y aurait donc pas d'égalité entre les
candidats sortants ou candidats qui se
présenteraient deuxième observation ceci
vous et nous est parfaitement connue
vous avez pris des dispositions pour
tenir compte du coc u19 pour les
élections municipales
vous en avez pris pour les élections
départementales et régionales et nous ne
prendrions pas pour les présidentielles
c'est la première explication de
l'amendement que je retirerais après
avoir écouté les observations de
monsieur le rapporteur et du
gouvernement
monsieur reporter
cette présidence je suis très heureux
que monsieur bonnecarrère n'est pas
retirer trop vite son amendement parce
qu'il mord et privés l'occasion de lui
dire combien je trouve cette démarche et
combien toute la commission des lois
approuve sa démarche notre seule chance
pour aboutir notamment sur les
procurations pour que le même régime
soit appliquée à l'élection
présidentielle qu'aux élections qui se
sont tenues depuis le début de la
pandémie c'est de pouvoir mettre en
débat est adoptée dans les délais les
plus rapides une proposition de loi
organique c'est possible nous avons
examiné de manière approfondie la
procédure mais ça suppose que le
gouvernement y apporte un plein concours
car sans le gouvernement nous n'y
parviendrons pas et ce serait fort
dommage pour toutes les personnes qui
sautent en difficulté par le risque
qu'il pense courir en se rendant au
bureau de vote en pleine pandémie et les
chiffres d'hier et d'aujourd'hui des
contaminations 368 mille personnes hier
3 161 milles aujourd'hui sans doute
beaucoup plus parce qu'il s'agit
seulement des personnes qui se sont fait
dépister montre que et il est impératif
de s'assurer que la règle du jeu pourra
permettre à tous les français de voter
est donc vraiment je trouve que votre
initiative est excellente je regrette
simplement que ça relève de la loi
organique ce qui nous empêche de
l'adopter dès maintenant
gouvernement veut s'exprimer
défavorable
alors monsieur bonnecarrère
et
pardon allez-y oui et je vous demande la
possibilité de continuer sur
l'amendement migaud miro 65 ans
signalant au gouvernement par une légère
ironie que un peu plus tard dans le
texte nous aurons une disposition à
l'article 1er septembre où vous nous a
démêlé nous demander l'autorisation de
prendre des mesures concernant
l'organisation des assemblées générales
de copropriété je m'excuse de la
comparaison entre les deux qui peut être
légèrement choquant alors qu'il n'ya pas
dispositions prévues pour les
présidentielles vous dire chaque clé
qu'il y a urgence
parce que avec le régime de la loi
organique de 2016 25 mars 2016 le compte
tours en termes de communication a
démarré le 1er janvier avec une période
dite
d'équité entre les candidats déclarés ou
présumés au 8 mars nous sommes dans la
période préliminaire et nous avons les
règles purement égalitaire qui
s'applique quinze jours avant l'élection
vous dire aussi que comme vous l'a
sous-entendu
monsieur le rapporteur il ya quelques
secondes non seulement il nous faut une
disposition organique pour l'élection
présidentielle mais il faut aussi
envisager une procédure accélérée sinon
nous tombons sous la règle de l'examen à
expiration d'un délai de six semaines
vous avez une question complémentaire
qui est la question de l'élection
législative
puisque si malheureusement la situation
de pandémie poursuivez vous aurez le
même suivait pour les législatives et là
vous aurez même pire puisque vous
n'auriez même plus la possibilité de
prendre de disposer de dispositions
imaginez par exemple qu'après l'élection
présidentielle
il y est une dissolution vous n'avez
plus de cession à ce moment-là possible
il faut donc à la fois prendre des
dispositions pour l'élection
présidentielle et pour l'élection
d'où l'importance de pouvoir envisager
ensemble des groupes du sénat si vous
l'acceptez à la fois un projet de loi
organique pour l'élection présidentielle
et un projet de loi sur l'élection
législative je vous donnerai une
dernière précision en soutenant
l'amendement numéro 66 6 en indiquant
bien entendu à monsieur le rapporteur
que j'accepte le même sort pour le de 65
pour le précédent
monsieur kerrouche avant qu'on le retire
pour permettre de
ménager le président alors ça va être
difficile d'être plus lapidaire que la
représentante du gouvernement mais sur
ce sur ce point sur ce point quand même
si gouverner c'est prévoir
ce gouvernement a des difficultés c'est
le cas en ce qui concerne par exemple
l'obligation vaccinale on est ici dans
le cas d'une obligation vaccinale des 10
et qui ne veut pas dire son nom parce
qu'on ne veut pas prendre la décision
c'est la même chose en ce qui concerne
les élections depuis plus de deux ans
avec le groupe socialistes écologistes
et républicains nous faisons des
propositions pour améliorer la situation
démocratique en temps de pandémie
j'entends les efforts de notre collègue
bonnecarrère qui sont louables mais on
voit bien en fait qu'on ne peut agir
qu'à la marge parce que il est en fait
trop tard il est trop tard parce que le
gouvernement malgré des propositions de
loi organique qui lui ont été faites
notamment en matière de vote par
correspondance ou de vote sur trois
jours justement s'agissant de l'élection
du président de la république un traité
ses propositions comme d'autres avec le
mépris arguant du fait que peut-être
attendant meilleure fortune nous serions
débarrasser de la pandémie or encore une
fois si gouverner c'est prévoir c'est
prendre au sérieux le fait que la
démocratie doit être une démocratie tout
terrain ce qu'elle n'est pas parce que
ce gouvernement n'a pas souhaité prendre
les mesures adaptées et nous pouvons
collectivement le regretter
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe quand
d'avril ni un peu plus tard pour les
législatives ce que je sais c'est qu'il
aurait fallu prendre
mesure qu'il est désormais trop tard et
que nous pouvons peut constater le
risque d'abstention générés par la
pandémie que ce gouvernement n'a jamais
voulu anticiper
jeu folio voulez
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues je crois que le sujet
que porte notre collègue philippe
bonnecarrère est un sujet éminemment
important essentiel
l'abstention est un véritable cancer
pour la démocratie et je crois que
chacune et chacun d'entre nous devons
être conscients des effets pervers que
ceci peut avoir par rapport au jeu dira
identification que peuvent avoir nos
concitoyens dans ce qui nous rassemble
donc là la république et la démocratie
et je me permets de vous dire maintenant
la ministre avec tout le respect qu'ils
peuvent être le nôtre par rapport à ces
éléments mais que votre nom réponse est
le fait que vous m'ayez même pas pris la
peine de répondre à notre collègue
philippe bonnecarrère pour essayé
d'argumenter de donner quelques éléments
de donner quelques perspectives et
quelque chose d'affligeant ou le dis de
manière très très directe mais je crois
que somme toute la situation est
suffisamment grave par rapport à cela et
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
notre collègue il n'est pas trop tard il
n'est jamais trop tard de bien faire
quand il s'agit de sauver je veux dire
l'élection présidentielle qui est le clé
de voûte de la clé de voûte de nos
institutions et nous avions une
spécificité par rapport à l'élection
présidentielle ça a été le cas notamment
la dernière fois et la fois d'avant avec
un sursaut de participation qui était
quand même quelque chose de tout à fait
positif et ce coup-ci nous n'allons pas
quand même rester les bras croisés et
attendre que nous ayons une catastrophe
démocratique comme nous l'avons eu pour
les élections
régionales les élections départementales
où les élections municipales et donc
madame la ministre il est important que
vous puissiez répondre et nous dire
quelle est votre position et quelle est
la position du gouvernement sur ce sujet
éminemment important essentiel
sur votre carrière si j'ai bien compris
après ces échanges pour retirer le
absolument et je vous demande quelques
secondes pour présenter pour m'expliquer
sur 2 66e mais je constate que 105
absolument monsieur le président
et grâce effectivement au 66 de dire à
monsieur kerrouche qu'il n'est pas trop
tard chers collègues je ne suis pas du
tout sûr des camps modifications sur les
parrainages ou sur le modification du
mode électoral qu'on connaît bien votre
préoccupation est votre mobilisation sur
le terrain du vote par correspondance
je suis sur un seul sujet qui est la
conséquence de la pandémie sur les
élections présidentielles aux notes et
législatives on en a tenu compte pour
toutes les autres élections
comment expliquer démocratiquement comme
le ferait pas pour les élections
présidentielles et tout à l'heure le
gouvernement madame la ministre a
répondu en disant mais il ya déjà eu ce
débat dans la loi organique de 2002
début 2000 21 c'est inexact
la loi organique de mars 2021 consiste
comme chaque fois avant une
présidentielle de prendre de tirer les
conséquences de toute une série de
modifications législatives
donc ça concerne et l'envoi des comptes
de campagne de manière dématérialisée
les parrainages idem de manière
dématérialisée ça concernait le vote par
correspondance des détenus la
modification de mars 2021 n'a pas porté
sur notre sujet qui est la conséquence
de la pandémie sur la tenue des
élections présidentielle et des
élections législatives
et là notre pays est un problème majeur
et là on a une possibilité de réponse à
travers une proposition de loi organique
sous réserve qu'on examine en procédure
accélérée
et à travers une proposition de loi pour
la partie législative c'est une question
que nous soumettons avec mon groupe à
l'ensemble sans en faire une question
mais sur personnaliser parce que c'est
un sujet collectif c'est un sujet pour
tous les candidats et nous vous
proposons de vous enseigner merci de
votre attention
mais si
la commission
sur ce commandement 66
même si son destin même marque
aimantation que tout à l'heure monsieur
le président l'avis du gouvernement vit
alors mal au cul karman voulait
s'exprimer
merci monsieur le président nos
ministres très rapidement parce que
c'est effectivement une réelle question
d'ailleurs rien le ministre qu'en est il
de la mise en place du comité
combrexelle 2 j'oserais dire ainsi qui
est censé aussi nous aider à prendre en
compte les différentes difficultés vous
dire parce que je pense que l'argument
de dire que nous avons déjà eu un projet
de loi organique de mars 2021 ne peut
être le seul argument est en tout cas ne
peut pas être à mes yeux un argument
retenu en mars 2021 personne n'avait
envisagé
que nous en serions là aujourd'hui et
que les élections présidentielles allait
se dérouler dans la situation sanitaire
qui est celle qui est la nôtre sauf à
nous dire que tout le monde savait que
nous serons cette situation là et dans
ce cas là nous pourrions tirer les
enseignements de tout ce qui n'a pas été
fait et que nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui je crois que la vérité c'est
que effectivement le variant la bombe
rêve ce dont nous parlons depuis
maintenant plusieurs heures est ici et
qu' il y aurait réellement
nécessité à réinterroger
les modalités les opérations
électorales
pour faciliter
les la participation pour faciliter la
prise en compte de l'expression de
celles aidées ceux de celles et de ceux
qui pourraient pour dit raison est la
première étant la peur de la
contamination ne pas venir au bureau de
vote au mois d'avril prochain
bien
les retirer
et nous passons l'examen de l'amendement
ce sont 5 qui est présentée par monsieur
benarroch
particularité d'avoir été adopté par le
sénat par la totalité d'entre vous chers
collègues fin octobre après avoir obtenu
le soutien du groupe socialiste par
l'intervention de madame de la gontrie
qui avait su rappeler combien notre
assemblée nous tous en fait avoir à
coeur d'appliquer les élus locaux et
leurs représentants dans les décisions
qui les concernent
comme vous savez bien tous combien ces
élus et leurs représentants doivent être
réellement et concrètement associé à
toutes les réflexions comment leur
connaissance du terrain est nécessaire
pour des fois guidé notre chemin et
comment a minima ne pas vouloir
s'assurer de leur rôle pour une
meilleure acceptation des mesures se
sont toutes les raisons qui vous ont
fait voter cet amendement au mois
d'octobre je sais que notre rapporteur
considère que cela il satisfait que
notre amendement est satisfait mais pas
vraiment
les consultations qui sont faites par le
préfet auprès des parlementaires et des
élus locaux n'ont pas pris encore tôt
fait jusqu'à présent la rédaction même
de ce que notre assemblée a voté il
n'est nullement fait état dans la loi
que le préfet fait parvenir les mesures
envisagées pour faire face à l'épidémie
afin que les élus et les parlementaires
locaux les élus locaux les
parlementaires puissent exprimer un avis
sur ces derniers et puis sert des
propositions c'est ça le coeur du
problème puisque vous le savez
actuellement les consultations qui sont
faites prennent des formes plus ou moins
précises dans chacun de nos départements
et ne laisse pas de marge de réflexion
pour les marques pour les parlementaires
et pour les exécutifs locaux
nous vous demandons donc en gravant dans
le texte de cette loi
l'année ces cités pour le préfet
pour le représentant de l'état donc de
consulter les parlementaires et les
exécutifs locaux avant de prendre toute
mesure et de leur faire parvenir les
mesures envisagées afin qu'ils puissent
exprimer un avis sur ces dernières et
faire des propositions c'est ce que nous
demandons vous l'avez voté en octobre
nous vous demandons de le voter
aujourd'hui aussi l'avis de la
commission monsieur remporté heures
monsieur benarroch a déjà donné l'avis
de la commission cet amendement est
satisfait par les dispositions de la loi
de mai
2021 prise à l'initiative du sénat et
dont le texte est suffisamment précis
pour imposer la communication des
documents sur lesquels la vie est
sollicitée car elle ne peut pas y avoir
de consultation sur un texte si le texte
n'est pas communiqué cela va de soi donc
l'avis est défavorable
le gouvernement
oui même avis satisfait donc roger
double avis défavorable demandes
d'explications de vote monsieur
benachenhou
on est plusieurs fois et c'est normal je
n'en disconviens pas j'interviens pour
mon groupe depuis le début vous ne
pouvez pas à chaque fois que
j'interviens faire preuve de réprobation
comme si ça vous embête et je suis
désolé vous êtes intervenu souvent je
n'ai jamais fait preuve d' aucune
réprobation c'est tout à fait logique
monsieur le président retailleau donc je
vous remercie de biens non pas avoir
lieu exprimez-vous très bien monsieur le
président c'est le droit aussi de dire
ce que je pense je souméras alors j'ai
une minute 33 secondes je vais donc
faire mon explication de vote
monsieur le président bas monsieur le
président de la commission je vais
excuses de vous dire vous ne répondez
pas à ma demande ce qui est marqué dans
le texte aujourd'hui que nous avons voté
en octobre c'est à dire après la loi du
mois de mai et que vous avez accepté de
voter à l'époque et que nous avons votée
précise et bien que les consultations et
les avis devaient être données de telle
façon à ce que les mesures soient
étudiées après consultation à vis des
élus locaux et des parlementaires c'est
exactement la même chose que nous
demandons aujourd'hui qui n'est pas fini
merci je soumets qui est favorable c'est
qu'au moment son seul
avis contraire
on suit n'est pas adopté
nous allons examiner l amendement 50 peu
rectifié terre madame noël nous présente
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre le pass vaccinale est une
mesure hautement coercitives et
restrictive de liberté pour la
population il convient que le parlement
dans son rôle de contrôle de l'action
gouvernementale
évalue la proportionnalité l'utilité les
conséquences de cette mesure dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire conformément
au 6 de l'article 1er de la loi du 31
mai 2021 qui prévoit que l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat peuvent requérir
toute information complémentaire dans le
cadre du contrôle et de l'évaluation de
ces mesures
monsieur le rapporteur
cet amendement est satisfait par
l'article 11 de la loi du 5 août 2000 21
qui prévoit déjà un rapport mensuel au
parlement et le gouvernement s'en
acquitte je l'en remercie
vis du gouvernement mais ma vie une
surprise mais ma vie je soumets
il est retiré et nous passons
à l'article 1er bis 1
avec deux amendements ils font l'objet
d'une discussion domaine l amendement du
gouvernement qui porte le numéro 194
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
beaucoup de choses ont été dites sur cet
article et malgré tout beaucoup de
malentendus persiste je souhaite donc
clarifier nos objectifs et les raisons
pour lesquelles nous souhaitons le
rétablir
d'abord contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu dire il ne s'agit pas de
s'immiscer dans l'organisation des
entreprises mais de sanctionner les
comportements de celles qui refusent
délibérément de prendre les mesures de
prévention nécessaires pour protéger la
santé de leurs salariés
face à la copie 19
ans 8 j'entends parler de rupture de
confiance voire de suspicion généralisée
dire que certaines entreprises ne jouent
pas le jeu ça n'est pas une rupture de
confiance c'est un constat c'est dire
que la confiance que nous avons tous
dans nos entreprises ne doit plus être
entachée par des comportements dangereux
de certaines est comment dire que nous
n'aurions pas confiance dans les
entreprises alors que nous avons
mobilisé des moyens sans précédent pour
les protéger et les accompagner face à
la crise nous avons soutenu nos
entreprises coûte que coûte depuis deux
ans
d'ailleurs ce que me disent bon nombre
de chefs d'entreprise c'est qu'ils
comprennent très bien voir qu'ils
appellent de leurs voeux que des
sanctions soient prévues lorsque les
obligations qui s'applique à tous ne
sont pas respectés par certains
par ailleurs il faut redire qu une
procédure de sanction existe déjà nous
cherchons à la rendre plus efficace plus
opérantes sans pour autant en changer
l'esprit je rappelle que la procédure de
sanctions actuelles tout comme celle qui
vous est proposée n'intervient qu'après
une mise en demeure les sens à
l'entreprise un délai pour se conformer
à ses obligations
nous proposons une alternative à la
procédure pénale actuelle qui aboutit
dans un délai moyen de deux ans ce qui
n'est pas compatible avec l'urgence de
la pandémie
par ailleurs nous faisons face à une
question essentielle d'équité pour se
conformer au protocole sanitaire les
entreprises doivent revoir leur
organisation et acheter du matériel de
protection
tout cela représente à la fois des
complications et des coûts pour
l'entreprise
comment pourrions-nous nous satisfaire
qu'alors que la majorité des entreprises
investissent autant de temps et d'argent
al'inverse celles qui ne le font pas
n'en soient pas inquiétés cela ne serait
ni compréhensible ni juste quand vous
supprimez tout simplement cet article
vous acceptez que certaines entreprises
peu scrupuleuses joue avec la santé des
salariés et de leurs proches le vote que
vous devez faire aujourd'hui renverra
chacun a sa responsabilité
souhaitez-vous véritablement protéger
l'ensemble des français face à la crise
ou seulement l'ensemble des français -
quelques-uns pour conclure je veux
rappeler que derrière ce débat l'enjeu
ce sont des vies il est de notre
responsabilité
de mettre en place des procédures
nécessaires pour protéger tous les
français je vous invite à choisir la
voie de la responsabilité en votant cet
amendement
mais si l'amendement qui porte
le numéro
[Musique]
oui je ne comprends pas tellement
pourquoi il est en discussion commune
avec le celui du gouvernement parce
qu'il n'y a pas de rapport mais je vais
quand même présenté cet amendement que
je trouve extrêmement important d'autant
plus important d'ailleurs que lors de la
de la discussion du dernier projet de
loi concernant la gestion de la crise
sanitaire le 28 octobre dernier cet
amendement avait fait l'unanimité au
sein de notre assemblée il était
présenté par notre collègue pierre
laurent adopté par le sénat c'était une
demande donc de rapport mais visiblement
ça n'a pas convaincu nos collègues
députés en commission mixte paritaire et
donc je leur présente aujourd'hui parce
que je pense que à nouveau nous allons
pouvoir le voter ensemble et convaincre
nos collègues députés alors pourquoi ce
rapport c'est parce que nous sommes
effectivement en pleine crise sanitaire
avec malgré la pandémie la fermeture de
cinq mille 700 lits d'hospitalisation en
2020 dans les établissements de santé
français et c'est une étude du ministère
de la santé qui leur apportait donc
d'ailleurs à ce propos je vous invite à
lire l'article très détaillée du
magazine de vérification de
l'information de libération chaque news
qui donne des éléments très précis sur
les fermetures de lits et qui indique
donc que la politique qui est menée par
le gouvernement qui poursuit les
politiques qui sont menées depuis plus
de 20 ans entraîne les situations
catastrophiques dans les hôpitaux et en
tant que parlementaire on a besoin de
savoir quelle est cette politique
quelles sont les logiques qui font
qu'aujourd'hui vous continuer à fermer
des lits et vous ne prenez aucune mesure
pour rendre les professions de 2 soit
attractive parce que vous prétexté que
on manque de personnel mais nous sommes
tous impacté dans nos territoires et
effectivement le personnel hospitalier
toutes catégories socioprofessionnelles
confondues quitte l'hôpital parce qu'ils
sont épuisés épuisée par deux mois de de
pandémie épuisée parce qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de personnel épuisé parce
que ils n'ont pas des salaires
suffisants et le ségur de la santé n'a
rien réglé tout ça donc un rapport
s'impose pour modifier la donne
bien leurs portes
c'est un avis défavorable monsieur le
président mais je vais expliquer
pourquoi
madame la ministre nous avons échangé
déjà sur cette question et vous savez
que les entreprises se sont très
largement engagé pour mettre en oeuvre
les recommandations que votre ministère
a établi la vous disiez tout à l'heure
l'objectif de cet amendement c'est aussi
de préserver des vies mais nous avons
débattu très largement depuis hier et
nous avons convenu tous que le meilleur
moyen pour préserver la vie de nos
concitoyens ça restait le vaccin vous
savez aussi que les entreprises ont déjà
des obligations pour assurer la sécurité
et la santé de leurs salariés au travail
et qu'ils sont pénalement responsable
est-ce qu'il est utile d'envoyer un
signal négatif aux entreprises qui ont
déployé des efforts considérables
pour
limiter la propagation de cette épidémie
alors le télétravail c'est un des outils
mais il y en a plein d'autres certaines
entreprises ont choisi
d'étaler les heures les plages d'entrée
et de sortie dans les entreprises pour
ne pas sur sa surcharge et les lieux de
travail mais aussi surchargé les
transports en commun ont mis à
disposition des dispositifs et des
protections pour protéger les salariés
donc je suis d'accord avec vous pour
dire que le trade télétravail est un
outil ce n'est pas le seul et puis
madame la ministre lors de nos échanges
nous avons échangé sur des chiffres et
vous m'avez dit que sur 30000 contrôle
qui avaient été effectuées jusqu'à fin
novembre 2000
21110 mise en demeure avaient été
réalisés ce qui est relativement faible
ça représente
0,37 % des contrôles exécutés dont en
plus nous considérons à la commission
des affaires sociales que tout ce qui
réglemente
l'organisation du temps de travail ça
relève du dialogue social donc pour
toutes ces raisons nous avons émis un
avis défavorable
[Applaudissements]
sur l'amendement 194
et sur le deuxième amendement madame le
reporter sur le deuxième amendement la
commission est constante dans ses avis
et un avis défavorable puisqu'il s'agit
d'une demande de rapport mais je
rappelle quand même qu'il y a une
mission sur l'hôpital et qui est
présidée par notre président de
commission catherine des roches
à la ministre votre avis sur
l'amendement 155 qui vous permettra de
vous exprimer gouvernement défavorable
son amendement 555
oui
c'est vous qui auriez oui madame la
présidente le président pardon madame la
rapportant on arrive effectivement
échangés l'amendement il n'est pas en
train de viser le télétravail il est en
train de viser des situations
dangereuses et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi le fait que la très grande
majorité des entreprises respectent
leurs obligations doit nous empêcher de
prévoir des sanctions voyez quand on
sanctionne les excès de vitesse on n'est
pas en train de dire que la majorité des
automobilistes fait des excès de vitesse
on est en train de dire que
effectivement alors même que une très
grande majorité de gens respectent les
limitations de vitesse mais certains ne
le font pas et donc ça justifie d'avoir
des sanctions précisément pour ceux qui
ne le font pas et je le redis ces
sanctions elles visent des situations
dangereuses et moi je peux vous dire que
depuis ces derniers mois nous en
constatons nous constatons qu'il existe
des entreprises je peux vous parler
d'une entreprise de transport et de
logistique de la zone de roissy
dans laquelle des contrôles sont
intervenus pendant huit mois d'affilée
sans que l'entreprise se met en
conformité avec les obligations la
situation ne s'est réglée que par un
cluster qui a enfin conduit l'entreprise
à se remettre en conformité je peux vous
citer aussi des cas d'une entreprise de
l'agroalimentaire 32 salariés dix-huit
cas positifs je peux vous citer des cas
d'entreprises qui ont des open space
dans lesquels elle refuse de télétravail
à leurs salariés avec un port du masque
aléatoire et compte et que et face à une
mise en demeure est faste à une mise en
demeure est face à une mise en demeure
le chef d'entreprise ne répond qu'il
n'en tiendra pas compte alors
aujourd'hui il existe déjà une sanction
sanctions pénales chacun connaît la
charge qui peut être celle des parcs et
y compris pour engager des poursuites
donc aujourd'hui ces sanctions pénales
elles sont beaucoup trop longue et on
propose une sanction administrative
quelque part c'est peut-être moins
stigmatisant - infamant qu'une sanction
pénale devant un tribunal correctionnel
avec le souci d'avoir une procédure plus
efficaces qu'ils rétablissent de
l'équité aussi par rapport à la très
grande majorité des entreprises qui en
effet se conforment à leurs obligations
moyennant comme je les dis du temps et
des coûts et jose allons passer le
président de l'apli de roche
merci monsieur le président simplement
pour vous dire madame la ministre que
lorsque nous avons auditionné deux
ministres verront hier notre collègue
victor cha soin de lui poser la question
de la situation des hôpitaux outre mer
et notamment en guadeloupe hélas le
ministre a dit en effet qu'on demandait
à des soignants qui étaient positifs
d'aller travailler de façon
exceptionnelle pour la surcharge de
travail donc c'est très intéressante le
gouvernement soit très exigeants viser
des entreprises mais pourquoi ne
s'applique-t-il pas lui-même comme
employeur public c'est qu'un rapport
tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
explications de vote madame prix bas in
his past vous êtes exigeants avec les
entreprises mais l'état est un employeur
public et s'il ya des situations
dangereuses c'est de l'envoyer des
soignants positif en fait partie
précision
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame
madame la ministre je dois dire je suis
très surprise par le ton de votre
intervention et le ton de défense de
votre amendement en fait vous
caricaturez notre position nous
renfermant d'un côté il ya les gentils
qui vont à les sanctionner les vilaines
entreprises et de l'autre côté est les
vilains sénateurs qui ne veulent pas
sanctionner les villes de l'entreprise
c'est un peu caricatural
c'est presqu'à la limite offensant
madame la ministre moi je voudrais vous
dire que nous ne sommes pas favorables à
ces amendes administratives j'ai bien
entendu lorsque vous avez pris la
délicate attention de m'appeler pour me
m'expliquer votre votre position je vous
ai écouté je nous ne sommes pas d'accord
sur le fait de cette nouvelle procédure
administrative dans ces procédures
administratives bien qu'il y ait des
lettres de relances et des lettres
notification précédent il n'y a pas de
procédure contradictoire comme il peut y
avoir de procédure contradictoire au
pénal il n'y en a pas non mais vous me
fait signe que non mais quand après un
inspecteur du travail a pris une
décision ensuite la décision va à la
direction départementale et ensuite
derrière s'est appliqué donc la décision
est prise d'amendé et le chef
d'entreprise on ne peut pas c'est une
nouvelle la disposition que vous prenez
là qui vient en fait d'un
dysfonctionnement de la justice commis
un dysfonctionnement de la justice qui
ne va pas assez vite alors on crée une
nouvelle disposition pour aller plus
vite pour sanctionner des entreprises là
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça nous
pensons qu'il y a aujourd'hui dans le
code du travail et dans le code pénal
des dispositions qui permettent de
sanctionner les entreprises qui ne font
pas face à leurs obligations et donc
nous ne sommes pas d'accord pour cette
nouvelle procédure qui à mon avis
perdura bien après la crise sanitaire
l'homme billon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président à mon tour
je voudrais dire que je bien entendu je
ne voterai pas l'amendement 194 qui vise
mettre en place des amendes
administratives les entreprises en
réalité ont tout intérêt à garder leur
personnel en bonne santé et les
préserver de l'aco vide en réalité on ne
voit pas pourquoi aujourd'hui on
imaginerait que des entreprises où m
sciemment en danger leurs salariés et
donc leur outil de travail donc moi je
pense qu'il serait préférable quand même
de mettre en place les outils
nécessaires pour qu'il puisse mettre des
protocoles en place les entreprises ont
démontré lors du premier confinement
quand même lorsque les métiers
essentiels étaient toujours autorisées à
travailler qu'ils étaient en capacité de
mettre en place des protocoles qui
n'existait pas à l'époque ils les ont
mis en place sans que personne ne leur
demande de rien donc véritablement je
crois que cette contrainte cdh amendes
administratives sont totalement
déconnectés de la réalité et des
préoccupations de ces entreprises donc
non je ne voterai pas cet amendement
madame la ministre monsieur claude kern
donc
non
monsieur richard
merci monsieur le président madame un
ministre vous nous disiez un instant que
cet amendement ne visait pas le
télétravail la non observation du
télétravail on y dit que cet amendement
vise des situations dangereuses et je
lis ce que vous préconisez dans votre
abonnement lorsque la situation
dangereuse dont vous parliez résulte
d'un risque d'exposition à lakovic 19 du
fait du non respect par l'employeur des
principes généraux de prévention prévus
et de cet état
simples questions très directes pouvez
vous nous dire quel type de situations
dangereuses
résultait d'un risque d'exposition à
l'accueil de 19 dans la mesure où vous
dites que ça n'a rien à voir avec les
jours de télétravail merci
tout pareil
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre j'avais déposé en commission
avec le soutien de plusieurs collègues
un amendement pour supprimer cet article
je veux donc remercier la rapporteure la
présidente et tous les membres de la
commission doivent bien voulu le prendre
en compte en effet même si vous indiquez
même le ministre que cet article ne vise
pas ou ne vise pas principalement le
télétravail il le concerne alors que le
télétravail repose sur le double
volontariat celui du salarié et de
l'employeur l'article l mist 200 m2 11
du code du travail permet déjà d'activer
le télétravail et ça a été fait depuis
le début de la pandémie
ainsi cet article permet en effet
d'encourager fortement en télétravail
sans qu'il y ait besoin de remettre en
cause et de l'imposer par l'amendement
que deux rétablissement pour proposer il
ne saurait davantage être soumis ce
télétravail aux aléas de l'appréciation
des inspecteurs du travail quant au
caractère télétravail à bhl ou non d'un
poste de travail en effet par delà le
contexte de la crise sanitaire nous
avons fait déjà des propositions en ce
sens pour développer le télétravail dans
le cadre des travaux de la délégation à
la prospective et la pérennisation du
télétravail peut passer par un dialogue
nouveau à instaurer au niveau du
parlement et avec les partenaires
sociaux mais il ne saurait se faire
autrement que par le dialogue proposé un
nouveau paradigme pour accompagner la
mise en place d'une nouvelle forme de
travail qui ne s'adressera pas à tous
mais qui concernera beaucoup et qui va
s'inscrire dans la durée est de notre
responsabilité par delà le texte qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui je remercie donc
la commission d'avoir pris en compte cet
amendement de retrait et je pense que
nous aurons à retravailler sur ce sujet
au delà du texte d'aujourd'hui par
ailleurs j'ajoute que par rapport à vos
réponses on ne saurait légiférer pour
quelques cas particuliers qui poserait
problème merci
alors
le président retailleau
et madame la ministre vous souhaitiez
répondre oui madame la ministre monsieur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
vous êtes ici au sénat et à peine arrivé
dans notre hémicycle
vous nous intimer pratiquement l'ordre
de voter de rétablir votre amendement
sur un ton croyez moi qui ne suppose
aucune opposition moi je n'accepte pas
ce dont vous nous fait le coup de sauver
des vies humaines croyez vous que nous
soyons aussi responsable ici alors que
nous venons de voter l'article 1 et
croyez moi ça n'est pas le président de
république qui nous a facilité les
choses mais nous l'avons voté cet
article 1 le principe du pass vaccinale
nous qui sommes dans l'opposition ici au
sénat et vous nous fait le coup de dire
attendez les entreprises elles peuvent
bien se conformer à ce que nous
souhaitons faire dans la législation
parce que elle nous doit beaucoup et
bien c'est de l'argent public qui a
sauvé les entreprises c'est pas l'argent
du gouvernement et moi je n'accepte pas
vos leçons de responsabilité parce que
ici nous avons montré pendant ces 2 que
nous avons une lisse et la
responsabilité et nous avons toujours
donner au gouvernement les moyens de
protéger les français pourquoi nous
sommes pas pour établir votre amendement
madame c'est tout simplement parce que
nous ne voulons pas rajouté un nouveau
régime au régime qui existent déjà
régime pénal pour la protection de la
santé la sécurité des salariés pourquoi
nous ne voulons pas rétablir cet
amendement madame tout simplement parce
que vous avez raison il ne parle pas
télétravail il est beaucoup plus large
il est très intrusive vis-à-vis de
l'organisation de l'entreprise et nous
nous voulons laisser cette organisation
aux faisons confiance bien sûr aux
employeurs mais aussi dans ce dialogue
social nécessaire aux employés parce que
c'est une question c'est le travail qui
concerne aussi les employés vous savez
très bien qu'un certain nombre
d'employés en du mal à télétravailler et
bien nous voulons faire confiance à nos
entreprises qui traverse un moment
difficile et ce n'est pas en les
pointant du doigt qu'on arrivera à
relever les défis que nous avons à
relever en france faisons confiance à
nos entreprises avant d'essayer de les
condamner
[Applaudissements]
avant le vote
merci monsieur le président je penses tu
avoir manqué de respect à votre haute
assemblée en vous disant avec beaucoup
de gravité avec beaucoup de gravité
qu'il y à des situations dans quelques
entreprises qui mettent en danger la
santé des salariés est alors si vous
m'interrogez monsieur le sénateur si
vous m'interrogez monsieur sénateurs sur
le type de non prise en compte de ces
risques c'est par exemple des
entreprises qui ont des masques qui ne
sont pas aux normes des entreprises qui
ne désinfecte pas les outils partagé
alors que d'autres entreprises
appliquent les règles des protocoles qui
ont été mis en place en concertation à
chaque fois avec les entreprises avec
les branches et je peux vous assuré
madame la sénatrice que effectivement
c'est plus coûteux pour une entreprise à
chaque changement des équipes de
désinfecter les outils de production que
de ne pas le faire et certaines
entreprises malheureusement font le
choix de ne pas le faire donc c'est ce
type de comportement qui met en danger
la situation des salariés que nous
souhaitons pouvoir plus efficacement
dissuader avec une sanction qui sera
plus rapide et donc plus dissuasive
et monsieur le président monsieur le
président cette sanction la loi est
claire le l'amendement en tout cas qui
vous est proposé est claire elle est
limitée aux risques qu'ovide limiter à
la période d'urgence sanitaire et même
dans ce cadre à des périodes dans
lesquelles l'épidémie serait
particulièrement
le niveau de co2 de l'épidémie serait
particulièrement élevé moi je suis un
peu surprise que de proposer une
sanction administrative soit considérée
comme une innovation il ya beaucoup de
dispositions du code du travail qui
repose sur des sanctions administratives
par exemple sur le respect de la durée
du travail par exemple sur les fraudes
au détachement sont des processus qui
sont évidemment contradictoire quand il
y à une mise en il ya la possibilité
pour l'entreprise de répondre à la mise
en demeure la mise la sanction je
rappelle qu'elle est prononcée par le
directeur régional du travail avec
naturellement des recours possible
devant les tribunaux administratifs ou
encore des recours hiérarchique devant
le ministre donc je pense que les
entreprises qui jouent le jeu dont
aucune inquiétude à avoir face à ce type
de sanction et celles qui ne le joue par
seront sans doute dissuadé de ne pas
appliquer les protocoles
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mesdames les ministres dont il
ya une argumentation qu'on a retrouvés
dans d'autres débats ici je me rappelle
sur la loi de finances à d'autres
moments c'est ce qu'a évoqué notamment
madame sophie primas en parlant de la
procédure contradictoire
vous savez ce que c'est avec la
procédure contradictoire chaque parti a
le droit de prendre connaissance des
arguments de fêtes
de droit épreuve et là moi je m'excuse
m'ont hélas gaïa divergences entre cette
partie de l'hémicycle et l'autre partie
c'est que là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
on vient coup sur coup d'exonérer les
charges des entreprises
rappelez vous un le cice exonérations de
charge des impôts productif vous avez
vous avez une procédure contradictoire
avec les salariés vous avez une
procédure contradictoire avec ceux qui
sont au chômage
est-ce que de l'autre côté les mici
qu'on propose un moratoire de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage
donc voilà non mais voilà ab non mais
faut avoir le débat avec eux avec la
sincérité et l'honnêteté qui nous
appartient tous ici mais faut mettre les
pieds dans le plat faut pas mentir sur
la sur la discussion qu'on a les
éléments qu'on a après madame la
ministre
évidemment que les entreprises qui sont
dans l'illégalité doivent être
sanctionnés après ce qu'on vous moi je
vous donne mon opinion
je pense que la question des 1000 euros
par salarié avec un plafond à 50 milles
d pad aptn au tissu économique
parce que là peut-être que nous avons
une convergence dans cet hémicycle mais
entre la petite tp ol grands groupes ce
n'aura pas les mêmes conséquences
donc il faut imaginer une
proportionnalité et nous avons ici du
point de vue de la fiscalité dans
d'autres domaines établi des règles de
proportionnalité de la sanction en
fonction d'un certain nombre de critères
donc nous nous sommes favorables à ce
que évidemment les entreprises qui
jouent pas le jeu soient sanctionnées
mais il faut trouver une
proportionnalité qui met pente est en
difficulté ce qu'elle est essentielle de
notre tissu économique
c'est les tpe et pme c'est ça qui nous
fait tenir donc il faut trouver une
autre modalité donc moi je pense que il
devrait y avoir un échange qui permet la
sanction est une proportionnalité
vis-à-vis des entreprises concernées
merci à temps voter
avis défavorable
de la commission
sur cet amendement
194 il en est de même sur le 155 ceux
qui sont favorables à l'amendement
présenté par le gouvernement le
manifestant devant la main
avis contraire
[Musique]
il n'est pas adopté et je vais voter sur
l'amendement 155 présenté par le groupe
communiste
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
et manifestants devant la ba
avis contraire ils ne sont pas adoptées
après l'article bliss à nous avons deux
amendements identiques à 38 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur guy laroche
et pour
le maintien quoi qu'il en coûte de
l'activité économique du pays au moment
où le virus connaît une très forte
circulation ne doit pas empêcher de
faire tout ce qui est en notre possible
pour protéger les français et les
françaises les multiples hésitations et
la frilosité de ce gouvernement a imposé
à protocoles sanitaires strictes pour
éviter les contaminations dans les
entreprises ont conduit à un flou dans
l'application des règles et des
recommandations
aujourd'hui encore certains salariés se
voient refuser la pratique du
télétravail alors qu'elle serait
possible certes un open space n'ont pas
été aménagées les salariés sortent assez
sans capteur de co2 sans ouverture
régulière des fenêtres sans vitre de
séparation des bureaux et risquent ils
sont maximaux et pourtant les
inspecteurs du travail se trouve
impuissant face à la nécessité de faire
appliquer la loi le gouvernement avait
proposé un dispositif d'amande
administrative dans un amendement
supprimée par la commission des lois on
vient d'en parler
la volonté de durcir le cadre légal
permettant d'imposer aux employeurs la
mise en place d'actions de prévention
efficace du risque de contamination sur
les lieux de travail part d'une bonne
intention mais le dispositif prévu passé
largement à côté de son objectif la
procédure d'instruction contradictoires
qui précède la sauque sur d'une amende
administrative est longue et peut aussi
durer plusieurs mois une temporalité qui
n'est évidemment pas compatible avec la
vitesse de diffusion du virus et la
nécessité de mise à l'abri des
travailleurs exposés l'inspecteur du
travail doit pouvoir soustraire
immédiatement un travailleur du risque
d'exposition par la prescription d'un
haricot vide en mettant fin
temporairement à la partie des travaux
ou de l'activité aux causes lorsqu'il
constate qu'il est exposé à la
circulation du virus est qu'il se trouve
dans une situation dangereuse a viré
comment expliquer que les restaurateurs
les patrons de bars ou de lieux
culturels ont été transformés au
douanier sanitaires ces derniers mois
mais que les inspecteurs du travail dont
le métier est de protéger celles et ceux
qui travaillent se trouve impuissant
pour endiguer la propagation du virus
dans l'entreprise
l'amendement 156 rectifier
oui c'est un mort un amendement qui est
identique je voudrais juste préciser qu
effectivement depuis deux ans maintenant
les organisations syndicales demandent
un encadrement du recours au télétravail
par la loi justement et demande qu'il y
ait une prise en charge par l'employeur
des dépenses qui sont supplémentaires
qui sont engendrées par ce télétravail
on vient d'avoir une discussion à un
échange que je trouvais extrêmement
intéressant sur les sanctions
qui doivent être infligée aux
entreprises contrevenantes on a vu que
le sénat avait rejeté cet amendement
mais comme nos collègues du groupe
europe ecologie les verts nous proposons
que en situation justement de risques de
contamination les inspectrices et les
inspecteurs du travail puisse prescrire
un arrêt temporaire ou toute une partie
de l'activité d'une entreprise ou d'un
service lorsqu'un ou plusieurs
travailleurs où travaillent eux se
trouve justement dans une situation
dangereuse avéré en raison de
l'insuffisance des mesures de prévention
qui ont été mises en oeuvre par
l'employeur face au virus et donc ça
c'est quelque chose d'important c'est
quelque chose que les organisations
syndicales défendent et aussi les
travailleurs et les travailleuses sont
mises en danger eh bien c'est la seule
façon à notre sens de réellement les
protéger
merci la vue de la commission à l'âme le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
même commentaire pour ces deux
amendements identiques la situation
visée par cet amendement semble beaucoup
trop large et plus difficile à maîtriser
pour les entreprises même de beaux
volonté dans la mesure où l'exposition
un virus peut être généralisée le
dispositif donne ainsi un pouvoir
d'appréciation
disproportionnée à l'inspection du
travail la commission a donc considéré
que les recommandations les contrôles et
les sanctions étaient déjà suffisant
pour assurer la lutte contre le coc vite
19 au sein des entreprises qui se sont
je le rappelle largement mobilisés
depuis le début de la crise enfin cet
amendement introduit dans l'urgence une
disposition pérenne dans le code du
travail ce qui n'est pas satisfaisant
c'est donc un avis défavorable pour ces
deux amendements identiques
madame le ministre
merci monsieur le président donc coup
l'aurez compris le gouvernement partage
pleinement l'objectif de protéger la
santé des salariés face aux risques de
kovy 19 ce qui peut supposer d'avoir
effectivement tout l'arsenal juridique
pour dissuader les entreprises qui ne
respecteraient pas les règles permettant
effectivement de protéger la santé de
des salariés je suis toutefois
défavorable à l'amendement que vous
proposez en effet des dispositions de
sanctions administratives telles que
celle qui a été proposée par le
gouvernement nous semble mieux adapté
qu'une suspension d'activité qui à terme
pourrait menacer l'emploi des salariés
que nous souhaitons protéger par
ailleurs comme l'a dit madame la
rapporteure votre amendement ne se
limite pas au contexte de lutte contre
la copie 19 contrairement au dispositif
de sanctions administratives proposé par
le gouvernement qui est limitée à la
période de la pandémie donc pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons je donnerai un
avis défavorable à cet amendement ces
amas mais si
je vais soumettre
ces deux amendements on vote qui sont
favorables aux 38 rectifié manifestants
en levant la main
habib contraire
n'est pas adoptée je pense que c'est le
même vote pour le 156e kevin
c'est ne sont pas adoptées
après alors mes chers collègues mesdames
les ministres il est quasiment minuit il
nous reste 45 amendements à examiner
nous allons donc ouvrir la nuit afin de
terminer l'examen de ce texte
notre enfant du jour du jeudi 13 prévoit
partir de 10h30 examen des conditions de
loin dans le cas de l'espace réservé au
groupe de l'union centriste
en conséquence nous parvenions pas à
finir l'examen ce projet doit cette nuit
à 1h30 ce que je souhaite nous devrions
d'accord avec le groupe de l'union
centriste décalé d'autant le début de
cet espace réservé par l'observation il
en est ainsi décidé et nous examinons le
140 rectifié
de monsieur fabien gay merci monsieur le
président mesdames la ministre madame la
ministre du travail
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
je suis content
que vous preniez le sujet du contrôle
des entreprises à coeur parce que quand
vous a interpellé lors du premier
confinement y compris de soutenir à
l'inspection du travail nous expliquer
que tout le monde et toutes les
entreprises joué le jeu et aujourd'hui
vous revenez vous nous dites que c'est
plus complexe que ça même si moi je
pense que beaucoup d'entreprises jouent
le jeu actuellement
sur une question là aussi nous le disons
depuis depuis le début de ce texte nous
pensons qu'il nous faut un vrai débat et
arrêter de subir et commence à imaginer
une société où on va vivre
malheureusement nous espérons sortir le
plus rapidement de cette crise sanitaire
mais s'il venait par malheur arrivait
une sixième ou une septième vague il
faut peut-être que quand nous commençons
à imaginer autre chose nous nous sommes
beaucoup penchés sur la question du
télétravail y compris si au sénat on a
fait une mission avec mon collègue
michel canet ma collègue martin berthe
et puis beaucoup de travaux on travaille
sur le travail il ya du positif il ya du
négatif et moi je crois qu'à long terme
quand même se pose la question de quel
de quel travail dans l'entreprise parce
que ça casse aussi les solidarités si
c'est sur le long terme et il faut un
système mixte
même si là pour le coup dans une pub
pleine épidémie une pleine vague il faut
aller vers 3 à 4 jours de télétravail
par contre nous pensons qu'il nous faut
imaginer la société du roulement
pourquoi parce que c'est notamment sur
le lieu de travail mais aussi et
notamment dans les transports publics
qu'un certain nombre de salariés se
contaminent et penser tout le contraire
par exemple quand on voit les rames du
rer b sur bondy le matin et le soir là
il ya une véritable question donc la
question de la société du roulement il
nous faut la mettre en débat entre nous
je vous remercie
alors l'avis de la commission
même le rapporteur
président
les concerts dont 7 cet amendement les
entreprises sont responsables déjà
d'évaluer les risques professionnels et
de prendre les mesures qui permettent de
prévenir ces risques en concertation
avec les salariés dans le cadre du
dialogue social est sous le contrôle de
l'inspection du travail
il convient de maintenir cet équilibre
et lee n'est pas souhaitable de confier
à un arrêté ministériel le soin de
réglementer les horaires de travail
merci messieurs président donc vous
souhaitez permettre aux mises de la
santé du travail d'imposer
l'organisation en roulement dans les
entreprises en cas d'épidémie graves
comme celle que nous traversons
comme vous le savez le gouvernement a
cherché depuis le début de la crise à
concilier le maintien d'activité des
entreprises et la protection de la santé
des salariés c'est tout l'objet du
protocole sanitaire en entreprise qui
vise précisément à définir les pratiques
à mettre en place au sein des
entreprises alors que ce soit le
télétravail mais je le disais aussi le
port du masque dans les espaces de
travail chloé partager la désinfection
des outils de travail par exemple
et pour autant et contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu entendre dire le gouvernement ne
n'a pas à s'immiscer dans l'organisation
des entreprises c'est bien à l'employeur
qu'il appartient au titre de sa
responsabilité en matière de santé et de
sécurité de fixer en associant les
acteurs du dialogue social les mesures
d'organisation permettant la continuité
d'activité et la préservation de la
sécurité des salariés donc pour ces
raisons j'ai émis un avis défavorable à
cet amendement
favorable je soulevais ceux qui sont
favorables son adoption le manifeste en
levant la main
avis contraire
abstention il n'est pas adoptée et nous
passons à un amendement près l'arctique
abrite un capteur richier il est
présenté par madame
luronne
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre donc je présente cet amendement
de madame catherine belrhiti qui vise à
exclure les femmes enceintes du pass
vaccinale et de l'incitation à la
vaccination
par cohérence avec l'amendement qui
propose d'exclure le post vaccinale pour
les jeunes de moins de 18 ans il est
nécessaire de prévoir que la grossesse
ne conduisent pas systématiquement à la
vaccination contre la copie de 19 ans
faisant explicitement un cas de
contre-indication médicale
en effet si le pass vaccinale comme
outil d'incitation à la vaccination ne
peut être exigée en dessous d'un certain
âge 16 ou 18 ans en fonction des
dispositifs retenus il est logique que
les enfants à naître soit aussi exclu de
cette vaccination d'autant plus qu'il
n'existe encore aucune étude de long
terme concernant les effets
potentiellement indésirables sur le
foetus merci
l'avis de la commission
oui sur cet amendement je voudrais
d'abord rappeler qu'il n'appartient pas
au législateur de définir les contre
indications médicales mais qu'il
appartient aux autorités de santé
indépendante de faire les
recommandations en matière de
vaccination et sur le fond cet
amendement laisse entendre que le vaccin
pour être dangereux pour les femmes
enceintes et qu'elle constituerait un
public à risque ce qui est tout à fait
l' inverse puisque les les femmes
enceintes sont considérés comme
prioritaires pour la vaccination et en
particulier le conseil d'orientation de
la stratégie vaccinale considère que les
risques d'infection et de formes graves
pour une femme enceinte sont multipliées
par 10 par 18 avec que des des risques
d'admission en soin intensif
pour cette raison c'est un avis
défavorable
oui c'est un avis défavorable également
je crois que le ministre de la santé a
eu l'occasion de rappeler à plusieurs
reprises d'abord les effets positifs et
ensuite le fait que en aucun cas en
aucune manière au contraire le vaccin
était contre-indiqué j'ai récemment
demandé au professeur fisher de donner
quelques explications aussi du personnel
à domicile qui avaient besoin de ces
explications et qui a pleinement rassuré
les façons en présence sur le fait qu'au
contraire même sa empêcher le
développement parfois de de
contamination auxquelles elle pourrait
être exposée donc voilà
alors expliqué sur les ondes que la
mercier
merci monsieur le président madame à
nice mes chers collègues je voudrais
juste rappeler que le coc vide est une
infection qui donne des complications
respiratoires
donc une femme enceinte a le risque
majeur d'être césarisé en urgence c'est
ce qui s'est produit dans plusieurs
hôpitaux en particulier à bichat sur des
mamans vraiment très mal je ne développe
très pas les futures mamans en
réanimation ou là le risque est de
perdre et la maman et le bébé donc il
faut vacciner les femmes enceintes tiens
j'oubliais
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président en
complément de ce qui vient a dit cet
amendement est vraiment scandaleux en
demandant de ne pas inciter les femmes
enceintes à la vaccination parce que
toute la littérature internationale
démontre que non seulement chez la femme
enceinte le vaccin n'a pas d'effets
secondaires
mais il démontre aussi que les femmes
enceintes sont un groupe et je reprend
les termes du haut conseil de santé
publique et du collège national des
gynécologues et obstétriciens français
un groupe à haut risque de formes graves
alors si vous vous souciez des femmes et
si vous vous souciez de la santé de
l'enfant à naître vous devez promouvoir
la vaccination des femmes enceintes
parce que sans cesse vous invoqué des
arguments toujours les mêmes vous dites
y'a pas de données de long terme et
comment y aurait des données de long
terme sur des vaccins qui sont apparus
il ya un an enfin c'est quoi cet
argument vous êtes une anti vaccins
madame chers collègues parce que sans
cesse vucci parce que sans cesse vous
sortez des arguments qui sont fallacieux
pour dissuader à la vaccination vous
nous demandez dans cet amendement de ne
pas inciter à la vaccination des femmes
qui sont à haut risque de complication
pour elles mêmes et pour leur bébé 6
explications
oui excusez moi mais je ne peux pas
supporter que vous vous vos propos moi
j'ai juste pris cet amendement j'ai une
collègue qui m'a demandé de le présenter
gelé juste présentés et vous n'avez pas
à mettre à m'accuser voilà je les
présenter en tout à fait normalement
c'est tout voilà c'est tout et chacun
penser ce qu'ils veulent
s'il vous plaît par l'interpellation
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
dans la nuit y ont
[Musique]
émerveillé merci monsieur le président
bien entendu je ne vais pas voter cet
amendement voté cet amendement c'est
remettre en cause les bienfaits du
vaccin je suis pour le vaccin je suis
pour que les français se vaccine est
bien entendu que les femmes et les
enfants à naître soit protégé
aujourd'hui j'ai eu un témoignage en
début de semaine de personnes qui
bossent dans les services de maternité
il ya de plus en plus de femmes non
vaccinés qui sont aujourd'hui en
difficulté parce qu'elles ont été non
vaccinés donc nous on peut pas dire ça
aujourd'hui au sénat les femmes
enceintes doivent se vacciner pour elle
même et pour les enfants je vous
remercie
bonhomme
oh oui merci monsieur le président mais
je dirai rien de neuf mais sauf que je
pense que la répétition c'est aussi de
la pédagogie est absolument nécessaire
de vacciner les femmes enceintes elles
sont à très haut risque pour elle pour
le bébé il ya des mort in utero il ya d
accouchement précoce il ya des voiles ad
abord tome des pardons des fausses
couches provoquer ou non mais en tout
cas je pense que c'est absolument
primordiale et c'est ce type
d'amendements en fait qui laisse
percevoir dans la population des espèces
de doute sur le vaccin ça son risque pas
son jeu des suspicions d'effets aux
suspicions injustifiée infondées donc je
voterai cet amendement et je pense que
ce type pardon je ne voterai contre cet
amendement qui ne devrait qu'il n'aurait
même pas dû être d'ailleurs dans cette
dans cette assemblée
[Applaudissements]
peut-on su ceux qui sont favorables à
cet amendement qui a reçu à double avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement
donc je le retire at il
retiré après
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 22 rectifié adam cohen
oui merci le monsieur le président le
droit au travail est guidé par un
certain nombre de principes fondamentaux
qui font office de garantie pour les
salariés lorsque ces derniers sont
confrontés au risque de perte de leur
emploi ou de leur rémunération
toute rupture de contrat de travail
intervenue à l'initiative de l'employeur
donne ainsi droit sous réserve d'une
durée de cotisation suffisante à la
prise en charge par l'assurance chômage
ou dans le cas contraire au revenu de
solidarité active rsa aucun salarié ne
peut être ainsi privés de revenus que ce
soit sous forme d'un salaire durant
l'exécution du contrat de travail d'un
revenu de remplacement ou d'allocations
sociales à la rupture dudit contrat
cette politique constitue l'un des
piliers de l'état providence
garantissant à chaque individu un
minimum de ressources pour subsister et
conserver une certaine dignité tous ses
droits et garanties ont été renversés
par la loi du 5 août 2000 21 qui est
venu institué l'obligation vaccinale des
personnels soignants imposant en effet
aux employeurs de suspendre
automatiquement le contrat de travail
des salariés non vaccinés pour une durée
indéterminée et sans maintien de leur
rémunération
si sanction il doit y avoir elle ne peut
pas être aussi disproportionnée
conduisant au placement brutale d'un
certain nombre de ses salariés dans une
situation de précarité sans précédent
pour toutes ces raisons nous souhaitons
revenir sur cette disposition qui
d'autant plus qu'elle touche des
personnels soignants souvent aux revenus
faibles fournissant un travail
indispensable on a toutes et tous dit
dans l'hémicycle est essentiel pour le
bon fonctionnement de notre pays je vous
remercie
si
le monde et 14,8 ibis l'amuseur brawn
merci monsieur le président dans le
contexte de la crise spital hier et de
manque de soignants qui aggrave
fortement la situation sanitaire
cet amendement vise donc à permettre aux
soignants et à d'autres personnels
suspendu de venir travailler en se
faisant tester pour pouvoir réintégrer
leur poste par ailleurs nous savons que
certaines directions hospitalières
demande aux soignants vacciner est
positif à la cocaïne mais
asymptomatiques de venir travailler cet
amendement vise donc à permettre leur
retour en revenant la situation
antérieure au 15 octobre 2021 qui
permettait aux non vaccinés de
travailler sur présentation d'un test de
dépistage il s'applique aux personnes
soumises à l'obligation de vaccination
par l'article 10 de la loi du 5 août
2021 incluant les soignants mais
également les pompiers et les transports
sanitaires notamment
l'amendement s'en va du très qualifiés
il est défendu
deux autres aussi sont 45
c'est parfait mais
amendement 176 présenté par madame
jasmin merci monsieur le président là je
tente de trouver une solution pour la
boîte je sais que ce n'est pas évident
alors j'assume seul cet amendement qui
tient compte d'une décision
d'un avis d'ailleurs du haut conseil de
santé publique qui vient d'être cité par
vos collègues les minots jonnier donc
c'est le même conseil la santé publique
et avait le 23 mai 2020 il y avait pour
le bac c'est évidemment mais qui avait
proposé en tout cas une solution pour
remplacer dans les établissements
publics de santé les établissements
médico-sociaux et sociaux et bien d'un
faire en sorte que les remplacements des
personnes non remplaçable par des
personnels qui pourrait être positif ou
alors
il ya tant que le vaccin dont on ne fait
pas même est asymptomatique
aujourd'hui il ya évidemment les vaccins
mais en guadeloupe hier le ministre
olivier viron on nous disait que les
soignantes se sont beaucoup vacciner et
c'est vrai mais il ya aussi beaucoup de
la personne vaccinée des soignants
vaccinés qui sont en congé de maladie
parce qu'ils ont co vide donc il ya un
problème de plus il ya des personnes qui
sont pas vaccinés mais qui sont négatifs
et qui sont privés d'emploi pour le
moment parce qu'ils sont suspendus alors
aujourd'hui ce que je propose c'est
qu'on donne la possibilité
aux raisins publiée comme bien des prix
par la collègue en face de permettre à
ses personnels dans un plan bien précis
pour une durée précise de pouvoir
travailler pour assurer en tout cas la
suppléance aujourd'hui on voit doublé à
l'épuisement des professionnels jacques
trop longtemps mais leur épuisement il
ya le stress la dépression et tentatives
de suicide et je veux vraiment qu'on
puisse trouver une solution provisoire
pour une courte durée mais trouver la
meilleure solution possible pour nos
territoires merci merci alors l'avis de
la commission madame reporter merci
monsieur le président en ce qui concerne
la
part dont la le dispositif relatif à la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
des sanctions qui vont avec la
commission a été constante et a toujours
soutenu ce dispositif
nous avons pas choisi
l'exclusion mais la suspension et il me
semble quand et en particulier pour les
départements outre-mer et je fais
référence à l'amendement défendu par
madame jasmin où le taux de vaccination
est particulièrement bas le vaccin des
soignants est particulièrement bienvenu
pour les protéger eux mêmes mais pour
protéger aussi les patients dont ils ont
la charge
donc ça c'est l amendement
122 pardon pour l'amendement
numéro 14 de madame muller brawn en fait
cet amendement permettrait aux
professionnels soumis à l'obligation
vaccinale de continuer à exercer leur
activité sous réserve d'un tests
virologiques négatif et l'obligation
vaccinale n'a pas vocation à devenir un
pass sanitaires c'est donc un avis
défavorable à
l'amendement
numéro
128,7 également un avis défavorable
c'est la réintégration des personnels
non vaccinés suspendu pour les besoins
de prise en charge des patients même si
effectivement ça se pratique le ministre
nous l'a rappelé olivier ferrand pour
les personnels contaminés mais non
symptomatiques sous réserve de respecter
un certain nombre de consignes peuvent
continuer à exercer
le de l'amendement numéro 145 de madame
assassi est similaire à celui de madame
jasmin dont j'ai donné le commentaire
tout à l'heure il s'agit de ne pas
appliquer les sanctions outre-mer c'est
tout à fait contre productif quand on
est convaincus de l'utilité du vaccin
gouvernement
avoir absente ces amendes sur l'ensemble
d'un moment je consulte
article veut que deux des six chine
oui ça vaut une défense pour un peu tous
les tous les amendements il s'agit pas
de ne pas favoriser la vaccination vous
avez bien vu qu'au niveau de notre
groupe le groupe communistes
républicains citoyens écologistes nous
sommes fondamentalement favorable à la
vaccination et nous avons donné un
certain nombre d'éléments pour dire qu'
il faut au contraire développer beaucoup
de pédagogie à l'est r continuer
notamment au niveau des personnes âgées
qui sont isolés à domicile etc
mais là on est sur une sanction qui est
disproportionné par rapport à à la non
mise en conformité des personnels c'est
à dire que finalement on les suspend
tout on les suspend de leur travail et
ils n'ont du jour où l'on m'aime plus de
revenus on en est là donc c'est une
situation qui est quand même paradoxal
avec une scène s'est jamais produit à ce
niveau là c'est la première fois qu'on
fait une telle entorse au code du
travail et notamment pour ce qui est des
des territoires ultramarins
quand on voit la difficulté qu'il y a à
convaincre la population de vaccination
quand on voit le manque des personnels
hospitaliers
on se dit qu marche sur la tête parce
que le paradoxe est quand même important
de notre présidente catherine de roche
l'a souligné dans le même temps eh bien
on envoie des personnels qui sont co
vide plus travailler parce qu'on manque
de personnel donc voyez c'est quand même
deux poids deux mesures
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mais chers collègues donc c'est
la troisième fois que je vais m'exprimer
sur le fait que les soignants doivent
être vaccinés est un test ne suffit pas
donc je compléterai en disant seulement
que pour nous les soignants digne de ce
nom nous avons un adage primum no quéré
en premier je ne nuit pas et nous avons
juré en prêtant le serment d'hippocrate
ce n'est tout de même pas rien
je suis
[Applaudissements]
je suis vraiment très heureuse
d'entendre tout ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui il ya pas si longtemps j'ai
été commissaire au sein de la commission
denquête pour l'évaluation des
politiques publiques ici même au sénat
et je crois que j'ai participé à la
quasi totalité des auditions et j'ai
entendu j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
et aujourd'hui c'est vrai il ya un
vaccin mais quand on écoute les éléments
de langage qui sont maintenant utilisés
par tout le monde et je ne sais pourquoi
le vaccin empêche les formes graves
mais il n'empêche pas la transmission il
n'empêche pas de l'avoir même quand on
est vaccinés alors beaucoup
d'incohérences depuis le début de cette
montée unis je veux bien entendre tout
ce que j'entends aujourd'hui moi je suis
lobbies de personnes je suis lobbies des
guadeloupéens des malades va louper
c'est vrai moi je ne suis pas anti pacs
comme certains ont voulu faire croire je
suis vacciné ici et j'ai un schéma
vaccinal complet ici donc vous avez la
preuve et la traçabilité mais à un
moment donné papa est très cohérent il
ya pas si longtemps dans cette
commission denquête vous m'avez entendue
et vous avez prêté du droit à mes côtés
je n'étais pas la porte je n'étais pas
président mais j'étais régulièrement là
et j'ai entendu alors aujourd'hui je
veux bien qu'on prenne soin mais prendre
soin ce de façon holistique
c'est à tous les niveaux on ne peut
passer à prendre soin parce qu'on est
médecin parce qu'on est peut-être lobby
si on ne sait rien mais moi je ne suis
l'aubisque de la population et les élus
merci bien je vais soumettre maintenant
vote l'amendement 22 rectifier le double
avis défavorable ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption manifestants
devant nam un
avis contraire ne pas adopter
14 actifs ibis ceux qui sont favorables
son adoption de manifestants levant la
main
avis contraire
n'est pas adopté un amendement 128
rectifié bis
présenté par le membre du groupe
communiste double avis défavorable ceux
qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
manifestants devant la malle avis
contraire n'est pas adopté un amendement
à un présentait aussi par le groupe
communiste tout l'avis défavorable porte
le numéro 145 ceux qui sont favorables
sur l'adoption manifestants devant la
main
ali contraire n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 76 étaient présentés vers
malabo jasmin donc l'avis défavorable
ceux qui sont favorables son adoption
manifestants devant la main
avis contraire il n'est pas adapté
nous allons examiner un amendement qui
porte le numéro 15 rectifiez bis il est
présenté par madame mula bronn il est
retiré retirer
je vais mettre aux voix l'article 1 bis
[Musique]
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
de manifestants devant ammann
avis contraire
abstention
adopté l'article inter
même vote je pense
et je passe à des amendements qui porte
le numéro 148 lacunes premier couac
terre il est présenté par le groupe
comme une icône
l'article
1er quater prévoit la prolongation d'un
dispositif d'accompagnement des médecins
du secteur privé victimes de
déprogrammation répétées de soins non
urgents jusqu'au 30 juin 2022 on sait
effectivement que c'est la
déprogrammation de ses soins est tout à
fait négative pour les patients d'abord
est effectivement aussi pour les
établissements de santé mais que ce soit
d'ailleurs des établissements de santé à
but lucratif ou non lucratif et donc
c'est valable aussi pour
les les hôpitaux publics donc comme on
est restreint avec l'article 40 nous
n'avons pas pu faire un amendement qui
étend dès ce dispositif prévu par le
gouvernement
également aux
établissements publics d'où notre
proposition de suppression de cet
article pour ne pas faire effectivement
deux poids deux mesures c'est à dire
favoriser les établissements privés à
but lucratif au détriment des
établissements publics
alors l'avis de la commission le
rapporteur oui monsieur le président en
fait cet amendement vise à supprimer un
dispositif qui tend réalité est un filet
de sécurité visant à garantir les
honoraires des médecins libéraux en
établissement de santé sous conditions
et ses médecins qui sont
particulièrement touchés par les
déprogrammations il ne s'agit en aucun
cas de faire un cadeau aux médecins
c'est très encadré
et pour cette raison nous avons donné un
avis défavorable
du gouvernement
oui c'est un avis défavorable pour les
mêmes raisons que madame les rapporteurs
je pense que ça n'aurait pas de sens
détendre au médecin qui exerce à
l'hôpital public ce dispositif même si
bien sûr ils sont salariés déjà de la
structure alors que les médecins dont on
parle qui sont victimes parfois d'une
déprogrammation qu'ils n'ont pas
choisies ont une perte de revenu qu'il
fallait compenser ce pas le moment de
fragiliser ces professionnels de santé
l'avis défavorable
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
ceux qui sont favorables cette aide à
son adoption magnifique panorama
avis contraire
n'est pas adoptée et nous allons passer
à l'examen de l'article 1er tiens quiès
ah et je vais donner la parole à
monsieur michel calvet merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre chers
collègues cet article traite du cumul de
pension de retraite avec une activité
pour les professionnels de santé j'avais
déposé un amendement qui était considéré
comme irrecevables par la commission des
lois appelant l'attention sur la
situation catastrophique dans le secteur
des transports qui assure pour beaucoup
des missions de service public je pense
notamment aux questions de transport
scolaire d'une part mais aussi aux
questions de transports urbains qui sont
essentiels pour la vie collective dans
nos communes et sur les territoires et
donc en bretagne par exemple les
entreprises de transports recherche 540
chauffeur et donc qu'il est
indispensable à mon sens que l'on puisse
prendre des dispositions notamment
permettant le cumul des personnes en
situation de retraite ou de congé de fin
d'activité avec une activité de
chauffeur permettant aux entreprises de
pouvoir faire fonctionner la ligne parce
que bien entendu ces
dispositifs de transport nécessite des
compétences que dont 10 et des
qualifications d'ailleurs l'on dispose à
72 personne mais en nombre limité et
donc il est important que le
gouvernement puisse prendre cela en
compte c'est le sens de cette parole
si monsieur
poireau bien sûr merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre est cher
collègue quelques mots concernant cet
article
cet article 1er quinquis hors
prolongation de la dérogation règles de
cumul emploi retraite pour les soignants
les soignants qui ont repris une
activité durant la crise sanitaire
et en rappelant malheureusement que
depuis le début de la pandémie
il faut réellement souligné je crois que
tout le monde le fait unanimement dans
cet hémicycle mobilisation de l'ensemble
des soignants avaient comme objectif
sauver des vies
mobilisation également des soignants
retraités durant l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
avec un des principes des dérogations
qui ont été mis en place durant lors des
différents projets lois d'urgence en
2020 et 2021 et validation lors de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour
2022 avec le rapport de madame doisneau
et ses collègues rapporteur et je
soulignerai bien entendu le travail des
deux commissions commission les lois et
commission des affaires sociales
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé profession
médical pharmacie paramédical ou
auxiliaires médicaux en soulignant aussi
le les collègues de et madame le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales qui indique que ces il s'agit
d'une mesure de justice en faveur des
retraités qui participent à l'effort
collectif pour soutenir l'ensemble des
soignants et qui sont aussi
particulièrement épuisé depuis ses
nombreux mois auquel aussi on s'associe
étroitement jour merci elle soutiendrait
cet article
merci bien que
je vais mettre aux voix
l'arctique qu'un piège à il n'est pas
modifié
ceux qui sont favorables son adoption de
manifestants devant la main
avic ont près
d'un point il est adopté
à kiel premier tient qu'à elle même
situation non modifiée
même vote
et un article un premier sexistes
messieurs la mini vous l'aimez et merci
monsieur le président madame richard
collègues dont la continuité dans
l'intervention précédente référence
aussi à la première loi d'urgence du 23
mars 2020 pour faire face à l'épidémie
du colis de 19 dispositif de garantie de
financement des établissements de santé
période mars 2020 à décembre 2021 avec
trois objectifs éviter toute rupture de
trésorerie sécuriser les financements
des établissements leur donner une
crédibilité
budgétaire assurer pleinement la prise
en charge des patients et avec une
nouvelle possibilité de reconduction
pour le premier semestre
2011 22 c'est aussi la position de la
commission des affaires sociales et en
soulignant aussi bien entendu le
problème des réformes qui sont en cours
et qui concerne les établissements de
santé ces sont des sujets aussi qui sont
particulièrement un souvent très souvent
évoquée par bon nombre de collègues
j'irai dans cet hémicycle et en
soutenant bien entendu cet article je
vous remercie mais si je mets aux voix
larqué que premier sexuelle ceux qui
sont favorables son adoption de
manifestants devant la main avis
contraire
attention aux nombreux points
et je vais passer maintenant à
l'examen d'un amendement à l'article 1er
cette pièce a
qui porte le numéro
163 adam kane
il est défendu l'avis de la commission
sur l'amendement
163 rectifier les fonds dits oui c'est
un avis défavorable parce qu'en fait la
commission des affaires sociales est
très intéressée au coût du traitement de
cette pandémie je rappelle quand même
que les tests 7,1 milliards d'euros par
mois et dont il nous importe de
connaître la courbe des dépenses de
santé liées à cette crise sanitaire
avait lui même
sommes favorable à cet amendement mais
pour des raisons différentes que quand
même important d'abord cette disposition
apparaît satisfaites dans la mesure où
le rôle de comité d' alerte qui est
prévue à l'article 114 4 1 du code de la
sécurité sociale prévoit précisément une
information du parlement sur le niveau
d'exécution de l'ondam le comité
dallaire transmet ses avis pour le 15
avril le 1er juin le 15 octobre et peut
rendre plus d'avis à d'autres échéances
s'ils l'estiment nécessaire dans un
contexte d'incertitude sur le niveau de
l'ondam la loi de financement de
sécurité sociale pour 2022 a d'ailleurs
prévu le maintien de ce dispositif et
donc le niveau d'information du
parlement en prévoyant uniquement que ne
soit pas proposé des mesures de
redressement de compte pour engager les
dépenses d'assurance maladie liée à la
crise sanitaire pour ces raisons le
gouvernement est favorable à votre
amendement de suppression
alors madame la présidente
dire simplement madame la ministre parce
que c'est souvent ce qu'on aurait tort
qu'on nous parle du comité d' alerte de
la commission des comptes de la sécurité
sociale mais rappelé que ce n'est pas le
parlement et nous nous demandons c'est
une information du parlement donc j'ai
bloqué mes vidéos favorable de la
commission est favorable du gouvernement
c'est bien ça je vais soumettre au vote
ceux qui sont favorables à cet
amendement du conte communiste du
vietnam un
avis contraire n'est pas allé
sur l'article 1er septembre
ceux qui sont favorables manifestants
devant la main
avis contraire
attention il est
adopté un amendement qui porte le numéro
199 2 présenté par le gouvernement
madame la ministre
merci monsieur président donc cet
amendement vise à rétablir
l'habilitation du gouvernement à prendre
par ordonnance les mesures nécessaires
au bon fonctionnement des copropriétés
le sénat a supprimé cette habilitation
aujourd'hui même en l'absence de
confinement plusieurs facteurs peuvent
rendre difficile voire impossible la
tenue d âge et en présentiel cela
peut-être des couvre feux locaux des
jauges ça peut très une annulation par
l'exploitant de la salle réservée pour
l'ag cela peut être un gestionnaire de
copropriété atteint par locaux vides
voir la réticence de certains
copropriétaires à se déplacer tous ces
cas concret nous sont remontées du
terrain il faut mettre en oeuvre les
dispositions adaptées c'est bien
l'objectif de l'ordonance que le
gouvernement souhaite prendre que de
répondre au plus juste à ces enjeux sur
la base des échanges que nous tenons
avec les représentants des syndicats et
des propriétaires c'est pourquoi nous
rétablissement d'habilitation est
nécessaire l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président la commission des
lois
madame la ministre nous sommes
parfaitement d'accord avec vous sur le
fond en revanche nous sommes en
désaccord sur l'idée d'avoir un texte de
loi d'habilitation sa raison pour
laquelle la commission des lois
directement inscrits disposition dans le
texte c'est donc un avis défavorable
défavorable parce que proposait inscrits
et explications de vote ce soir
ferait rapidement monsieur le président
nous partageons totalement la position
de la commission monsieur le président
de la commission pour mettre fin à ce
débordement de ordonnance et j'ajoute en
doute que nous avons ici une parfaite
illustration
du caractère parfaitement aléatoire de
l'invocation de l'article 45 de la
constitution
parce que très franchement je sais pas
comment on pourra expliquer que les
copropriétés font partie du périmètre
comme il est d'usagé de dire de ce texte
pad aux demandes d'explications de vote
donc avis défavorable de la commission
sur l'amendement 199 gouvernement ce
qu'ils sont on l'adopté de manifestants
devant la main
d'enthousiasmé mesurer avis contraire
je canalise l'enthousiasmé et n'ont pas
noté
sur l'article 1er septembre je pense que
le vote est identique inné et nous
passons l'amendement 108
monsieur benarroch
l'ajout du gouvernement qui permettait
de reporter qui permet de reporter les
rendez-vous des services de médecine du
travail
si l'objectif de mobiliser les services
de médecine du travail de santé au
travail maintenant dans la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vie 19 permet
effectivement d'avancé dans cette
campagne celui ci ne doit pas obérer la
réussite de la prévention santé au
travail et se faire au détriment du
suivi de l'état de santé des
travailleurs qui demeure
particulièrement nécessaire et ce alors
que du par l'accumulation des reports de
rendez-vous s'avère préjudiciable pour
l'organisation des entreprises et pour
les travailleuses et les travailleurs et
que d'autre part les ssd peuvent
participer à caen avec lors des dix
rendez-vous les salariés non encore
vaccinés la médecine du travail est
investi d'une mission d'ordre public
social elle doit préserver ses
prérogatives il est indispensable nous
semble utile de lui laisser effectuer
ses missions quotidiennes qui tous des
enjeux divers en lien avec la pénibilité
du travail la prévention du harcèlement
moral et sexuel au travail le maintien
dans l'emploi des travailleurs ou encore
de l'ergonomie de tous les postes de
travail et des visites médicales
nécessaires et de natures diverses sont
également nécessaires par les services
de santé au travail les visites
médicales régulières ne sont pas sans
importance au contraire elles permettent
de veiller au maintien d'une bonne
condition physique qui permet également
de limiter les formes graves de maladies
et de détecter un tas de maladies auprès
de salariés dans le seul médecin et le
médecin du travail rappelons que le
droit à la santé des travailleurs est
inscrit à la neil et à 11 du préambule
de la constitution de 46 et qu'il
accorde aux employeurs de s'assurer de
la santé de leurs employés selon les
dispositions de l'article l 41 21 1 du
code du travail il est très mal vécue
par les services de santé au travail
aujourd'hui de voir toutes leurs
missions traditionnelles reporté sous
prétexte uniquement qu'il devrait
participer à la campagne de vaccination
ce qu'il faut pour la grippe depuis des
années sans suspendre leurs activités
bien l'avis de la commission
oui monsieur le président cet amendement
qui vise à supprimer l'article 1er oct
yeahs qui prévoit que les visites
médicales prévues dans le cadre du suivi
de l'état de santé des travailleurs
peuvent être reportés lors qu'elles ne
sont pas prioritaires afin de permettre
la mobilisation des services de santé au
travail dans la campagne de vaccination
contre la grippe 19 alors c'est vrai que
la santé des salariés au travail c'est
une réalité et une préoccupation les
médecins du travail sont habilités à
décider s'il doit y avoir visite ou non
nous au niveau de la commission nous
avons jugé
utile de limiter la possibilité de
report
parce que on ne peut pas reporter
indéfiniment ces visites de santé au
travail et nous proposons également que
la visite qu'il doit s'effectuer dans la
45e année de l'agent soit reportée d'une
année pour les mêmes raisons pour
libérer les médecins du travail pour
qu'ils puissent se consacrer à la lutte
contre l'épidémie et la mise en place de
la vaccination
donc un avis défavorable
défavorable je soumets
au vote ceux qui sont favorables sur
l'adoption manifestants devant la map
avis contraire
l'abstention n'est pas adoptée et nous
passons un article au nôtre article 1er
au thiès
non modifiés parce que c'est le même
vote
il est adopté
deux amendements vont faire l'objet
d'une discussion commune un amendement
160 rectifié beast que fabien est
présente merci monsieur le président si
vous acceptez je présente les deux en
même temps
madame la unis c'est dommage que la
ministre du travail soient partis c'est
sur une
question
un certain nombre d'entreprises et de
grandes entreprises ont été dû aider
beaucoup dans cette crise
prêts garantis par l'état chômage
partiel aide directe exonérations de
cotisations est pourtant un certain
nombre ont continué à licencier on pense
particulièrement à la filière automobile
et les fonderies
un exemple en plein dans l'actualité les
salles ce qu'on nous rabâche tous les
jours les oreilles comme industrialise
le pays sauf que quand on regarde par
exemple on perde la souveraineté
industrielle sur les fonderies demain
toutes nos pièces seront fabriquées en
espagne ou en roumanie c'est ça la
réalité notamment véronneau dont l'état
est actionnaire il faut le rappeler
l'esam ses 350 salariés sur le carreau
ces 250 qui depuis le 26 novembre sont
en lutte et nous pensons pourquoi dont
nous pensons et une véritable question
en pleine épidémie lors qu'on aide sans
précédent les entreprises et qu'en même
temps vous avez dû aux rssi très dur en
menant le contrôle pour les chômeurs un
million de personnes ont perdu des
indemnités chômage qui rappelons le est
un droit donc nous pensons au minimum
qu'il faut interdire les licenciements
et si vous voulez pas adopter celui là
nous allons faire un amendement de repli
pour que les entreprises qui ont
bénéficié les aident et qui en plus
versent des dividendes au minimum quand
quand même ne ne licencie pas et je
rappelle une dernière chose comme ça
j'aurai présenter les deux dans les deux
minutes que sur cette idée là nous
sommes majoritaires y compris en période
hors prise jour après jour merci je
considérais deux amendements présentés
et jeunes ont de l'avis de la commission
sur ces deux amendements madame le
rapporteur ainsi monsieur le président
chers collègues je pense que cette
mesure est quand même un caractère un
petit peu excessif qui ne prévoit même
pas de pouvoir licencier un salarié pour
faute et vous savez tout aussi bien que
moi que les salariés certains ou
certaines catégories de salariés sont
protégés pour éviter les licenciements
abusifs donc on ne peut pas mettre ça
sur le dos de la crise pour cette raison
ce sont deux avis défavorables pour ces
deux amendements ou vers l'humour au
modem le même avis
je vais consulter
sur un amendement centriste dit fier
miss ceux qui sont favorables sur
l'adoption le manifeste en levant la
main
avis contraire
et pas adopter et sur le 161 actifs
risqués donc amendement de repli
même vote
ne sont pas adoptés
une ovation à l'amendement sauf 96 est
ici présentée par le gouvernement madame
la ministre monsieur le président ce cet
amendement et visa permettent de
prolonger les dispositifs d'exonération
et des lots paiement des cotisations et
des contributions sociales au bénéfice
des employeurs et travailleurs
indépendants les plus touchés par la
crise économique et sanitaire plusieurs
mesures en ce sens ont permis de
soutenir ses employeurs dans le cadre de
la loi de financement de sécurité
sociale pour 2021 la loi de juillet 2021
de finances rectificative et dans le
contexte actuel compte tenu des
conséquences les mesures de lutte contre
l'épidémie pour être emporté pour
certains secteurs
d'activité le présente amendement donne
la possibilité de prolonger ou de
reconduire par décret certaines mesures
d' aide au plus tard jusqu'à la fin des
dispositions de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prévue par la loi
soit en l'état actuel du droit jusqu'au
31 juillet 2022
habitat commission
chez président nous allons donner un
avis favorable sur cet amendement parce
qu'il nous semble indispensable de
soutenir les très petites entreprises
mais quand même je me permettrai de
faire une remarque madame la ministre
nous regrettons que sur cette mesure que
cette mesure n'ait pas été prévu par la
loi de finances de sécurisé de par la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2022 puisqu'on était déjà
dans la crise sanitaire et on le savait
on savait bien qu'elle était qu'elle
était loin d'être terminée malgré ces
remarques et un avis favorable
à il favorable
je vais soumettre
aux voeux ceux qui sont favorables
manifestants devant la main
à vie contre l abstention
adopté deux amendements identiques
11 rectifié lui donne
alors le déploiement d'autres tests de
détection antigénique du virus ascough 2
sur prélèvement nasal ne nécessite pas
de présence de professionnels de santé
et permet ainsi la réalisation de tests
plus fréquent au sein de la population
c'est un outil essentiel dans la lutte
contre les virus il est donc
indispensable d'augmenter les
disponibilités et d'en permettre l'accès
au plus grand nombre cet amendement
propose de pérenniser les mesures mises
en place par l'arrêté du 27 décembre
2021 au delà du 31 janvier 2022 afin que
les entreprises de la grande
distribution puisse vendre des autotests
à moindre coût notre ministre de la
santé a précisé que c'était un acte
médical pourtant alors nous moi je suis
dans le bas-rhin je peux vous dire que
depuis des mois on peut acheter des
tests à l'unité dans tous les
supermarchés en allemagne l'allemagne
serve d'exemple pour beaucoup de
facteurs et qu'on vend le test à 1 euros
65 alors que si nous allons dans les
lieux en france c'est à 25 euros les
cinq tests oraux c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
on veut ouvrir au plus grand nombre le
test et que les gens puissent se soigner
et ne pas contagieux compte
contaminer les autres il vaudrait mieux
qu'ils puissent tester donc qu'on puisse
ouvrir cette vente au plus grand nombre
merci
suivent publié
aujourd'hui
l'avis de la commission
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
rappeler sur cet amendement que les
pharmaciens ont été particulièrement
engagée dans la lutte contre cette
épidémie en vaccinant en faisant des
tests et que nous avons cette chance en
france d'avoir un maillage de pharmacie
sur les territoires et que très souvent
les pharmaciens en particulier en milieu
rural sont le premier recours quand on
manque cruellement de médecins
les pharmaciens sont quand même des
professionnels de santé ce ne sont pas
des épiciers qui se contentent de
délivrer des médicaments ou des
dispositifs médicaux il apporte un
conseil il rassure éventuellement et il
informe sur les conduites à tenir dans
le cadre des autotests si jamais on a un
test positif et puis si on ne veut pas
voir disparaître nous pharmacie et un
jour voir la distribution des
médicaments en supermarché eh bien il me
semble qu'il faut réserver aux
pharmaciens la vente de ces autos thèse
de ces dispositifs médicaux quant aux
prix puisque vous faisait une
comparaison entre les prix pratiqués en
allemagne et en france le gouvernement a
tout loisir dont cadres et les prix de
ces auto test comme il a pu le faire
durant la crise sur les gels
hydro-alcooliques par conséquent c'est
un avis défavorable sur ces deux
amendements
au leader en europe je vais consulter
merci monsieur le président moi je
voulais juste a ajouté que la vente des
autotests compte tenu de la situation
actuelle comme vous le savez est
autorisée mais d'une manière strictement
encadrée et nous souhaitons la limite
est aussi dans le temps pour réaffirmer
les principes que nous venons d'évoquer
qu'il s'agit bien d'un acte médical et
que les pharmaciens ne sont pas des
boutiques et comme les autres donc nous
avons donc préciser les choses et ne
voulons pas inscrire dans la loi
aujourd'hui justement le fait qu'on
ouvrirait à ses commerces
bien je consulte
sur ces deux amendements identiques
il est retiré voyez président y est
retiré donc je consulte sur le onze
rectifie bis uniquement ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption le manifestant
devant la même
avis contraire n'est pas adoptée
et nous passons à la maman soit 92
rectifié messieurs ravier merci monsieur
le président cet amendement vise à
supprimer l'obligation du port du masque
dans la rue j'espère pour cela ne pas
avoir à subir la furie voir la fureur du
tribunal révolution révolutionnaire de
la république vaccinale parce que
permettez moi
de dénoncer ce qui s'est passé tout à
l'heure
jupiter avait une technique pour faire
de ses adversaires il les rendez-vous
est manifestement certains d'entre vous
mes chers collègues avec tout le respect
que je vous dois et que je vous accorde
même s'il n'est pas tout le temps
réciproque même s'il n'est pas tout le
temps réciproque certains y rejoue la
manière dont notre collègue a été traité
pour avoir commis le crime manifestement
de présenter un amendement qui voulait
exemptes et les femmes enceintes dans
l'obligation vaccinale
personne ici et anti vax mais il est des
sénateurs qui sont contre l'obligation
vaccinale contre l'obligation vaccinale
pour avoir présenté cet amendement
notre collègue a été montré du doigt les
menaces n'étaient pas loin elle a été
présentée manifestement commune la voilà
est ce que j'ai encore le droit de
parler comme une hérétique de la
religion de la religion vaccinale donc
j'en appelle
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues un peu de retenue soyez quand
même encore assez
assez intelligent pour savoir écouter
les avis des autres donc l'obligation du
port du masque dans la rue et
symboliquement honteuse c'est un peuple
entier que l'on bayonne socialement
inacceptable dans un pays qui avait
pourtant érigé la loi en loi pardon le
principe d'avoir le visage découvert en
public est surtout sanitaire au nom
stupide puisque aucune je dis bien
aucune étude n'a prouvé son utilité dans
la rue le ministre vers ont demandé hier
de croire la science je suis pour une
fois totalement d'accord avec lui donc
ce masque dans la rue et inutile il ne
fait qu'accentuer la séparation des
français et alimenter la psychose il est
temps de s'en débarrasser
mais si la ville de la commission
merci monsieur le président le port du
masque en extérieur n'est pas une
obligation mais peut-être justifiée soit
du fait de la très forte contagiosité de
certains variants soit du fait de
certaines configurations en particulier
les rassemblements où les zones très
fréquentées
il ne convient pas d'empêcher une telle
mesure par ailleurs cette obligation est
très encadré et le conseil d'état l'a
rappelé par une ordonnance du 11 janvier
dans laquelle il a précisé que les
préfets ne peuvent imposer le port du
masque en extérieur car c'est qu'à
certaines conditions il doit être
limitée aux lieux et aux heures de forte
circulation de population quand la
distanciation physique n'est pas
possible pour ces raisons c'est un avis
défavorable
madame lamy
[Musique]
bien joué
monsieur le président millions
merci messieurs président je n'étais pas
beaucoup intervenu jusqu'à présent mais
là quand même d'abord aussi haut sur la
les conséquences de la non vaccination
chacun dans cette large et au mit et
madame marie mercier on en parlait mais
je voudrais ajouter très clairement que
s'il a déjà extrêmement compliqué de
soigner un patient qui a un coût vide un
coït grave il est encore plus compliquée
le choix d une femme enceinte qui a un
col ingram et la plupart du temps quand
une femme enceinte alcoolique grave on
perd au minimum l'enfance il ravit donc
c'est absolument incroyable d'entendre
ce que vous venez de dire il n'y a pas
eu de bronca contre celle qui a présenté
cet amendement mais je voulais juste
vous dire puisque vous avez dit que
personne était candidate dans cette
enceinte je pense que quand même
certains sont irresponsables
alors je
consulte avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
de manifestants le monde à mon
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté
et j'ai maintenant
soumettre et ben deux amendements en
discussion commune 124 identifié terme
sur benarroch
107 donc je vais défendre en même temps
si vous le voulez bien
dès début décembre alors que le virus au
micro arriver que le valeurs delta neu
reculait toujours pas le conseil
scientifique déclaré freiner la
circulation du virus avec des mesures de
contrainte dans l'espace plus vite qui
relève de décisions gouvernementales est
préconisé nous voyons bien que le
gouvernement n'a pas fait ce choix
légitimement ou pas mine de la passe et
nous pensons que la lutte contre
l'épidémie ne peut pas se résumer à une
campagne vaccinale certes importantes
nécessaires indispensables mais pas
suffisante la limitation de la
circulation du virus via le rappel et le
contrôle de gestes barrière doit
s'appuyer au vu de la flambée épidémique
aussi sur une politique d'un masque plus
protecteurs aussi le groupe propose
d'imposer une protection plus grotte
pour la population dans les transports
publics collectifs ou les gestes
barrière de distanciation et d'aération
sont parfois totalement impossible
cependant les ffp2 plus protecteurs sont
plus chers que les masques chirurgicaux
dans le cou pèse déjà beaucoup sur le
budget des ménages aussi nous vous
proposons dans le premier amendement que
l'état assume son rôle et contribuer
sincèrement à la protection des
personnes en prenant les mesures pour
fixer un prix maximum pour ses
équipements comme il l'avait d'ailleurs
fait au début de la pandémie sur le gel
hydroalcoolique et sur les masques
chirurgicaux cet amendement évident que
le gouvernement a fixé le prix du masque
ffp2 par décret comme cela avait été
fait pour les masques classique
l'amendement de repli
qui est un amendement qui ne parle plus
de l'obligation du port du masque ffp2
et dans l'ensemble des transports en
commun est un amendement qui précise
juste que le gouvernement doit par
décret fixer la limite du prix du masque
ffp2
avis de la commission le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
imposé par la loi le port du masque dans
les transports sans discernement des
situations et sans condition de durée de
la main dur n'est pas souhaitable par
ailleurs le haut conseil de la santé
publique a récemment rendu un avis sur
le port du masque ffp2 et il ne semble
pas en recommandé lusage en population
générale
à ce stade et madame la ministre j'en
profite pour vous dire que nous serions
intéressés à avoir ses amis quand il
tombe puis c'est ce qui est prévu dans
la loi pour l'instant nous ne disposons
ne disposons pas de ces avis concernant
l'encadrement des prix bon je l'avais
rappelé en commission le code du
commerce permet déjà au gouvernement
d'arrêter par décret en conseil d'état
les hausses ou les baisses de ces
équipements
invités savent orale
et jusqu'à ce jour de monsieur jo me
merci monsieur le président je remercie
notre collègue benarroch de poser la
question des masques ffp2 qui est
effectivement une vraie question suivrez
la vie de la rapporteure mais il n'en
reste pas moins que il ya un certain
nombre de situations en tout cas où le
port de ces masques apparaît nécessaire
et j'ai interrogé le ministre de la
santé sur les patients qui sont
immunodéprimés qui sont la catégorie
importante de patients vaccinés qui se
retrouvent en réanimation voilà et c'est
une population de ce sont trois cent
mille personnes à peu près dans notre
pays et pas plus et les sociétés
savantes publie à tour de rôle d études
et de recommandations demandant qu'on
les protège rapidement avec des masques
ffp2 le ministre de la santé pour le
moment n'a pas fait prendre de décision
de prise en charge de ces masses pour
ces patients les patients qui sont en l2
ou une prise en charge des masques
chirurgicaux
quel que soit l'affection de longue
durée mais cette catégorie de patients
nécessitent qu'on les protège au mieux
ils sont vaccinés sont tout de même
victime de formes graves du vie russe il
faut absolument rapidement madame la
ministre s'il vous plaît que vous nous
indiquiez quand vous allez prendre et
comment des dispositions pour que les
masques ffp2 puisse être prise en charge
pour ces patients je remercie
[Applaudissements]
et je vais consulter valablement
l'oublier non non
donc si en avant 2024 rectifié bis ceux
qui sont favorables à son adoption de
manifestants devant la même
avis contraire n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 107
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
mais restant devant l'amas avis
contraire mais pas à l'autre
et nous passons à l'examen de
l'amendement avec deux amendements en
discussion commune l'amendement 150
rectifier à l'homme la présidente et
celle ci est
ensuite un amendement 115 ratifié même
la présidente merci monsieur le
président nous sommes contraints comme
chacun le sait par l'article 40
donc cet amendement vise enfin un site à
l'installation généralisée de
purificateurs d'air dans sans filtre
dans les établissements
recevant du public et dans les
transports en commun qui sont quand même
et chacun le cic ici pardon des lieux à
haute contamination
avançant qu'il est ici une roche
et être expliquée contraire par le même
article 40 nous avons pris la forme dans
cet amendement d'une demande de rapport
au gouvernement et de telle façon a
lancé un appel en quelque sorte à
déployer les capteurs de cod dans les
établissements scolaires et sur les
lieux de travail
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer a annoncé une aide
financière aux collectivités pour
financer les capteurs de co2 aide
financière est notoirement insuffisantes
quand on sait que seulement 20 pour dans
des établissements scolaires sont
aujourd'hui dotées l'état en fait
renvoient la responsabilité
comme souvent aux collectivités alors
que cette mesure de bon sens devrait
normalement figurer au coeur de la
stratégie de lutte contre l'épidémie du
gouvernement l'installation de
détecteurs de co2 pourtant la mesure la
plus simple et la moins coûteuse pour
contrôler la qualité de l'air ces
capteurs contribuer à lutter contre la
propagation du virus la concentration de
co2 est un moyen de s'assurer que les
salles sont suffisamment aéré ils
peuvent également devenir un outil
pédagogique qui permet de sensibiliser
les enseignants les enfants mais aussi
les parents aux réflexes de l'aération
des pièces en france certaines régions
et certaines villes sur leur propre
budget commencent à se doter de cet
équipement mais la mesure est loin
d'être encore généralisée nous devons
donc que le gouvernement se saisisse
pleinement de ce sujet et la fois que
nous avons adoptées dans cet abonnement
est celle de rapport à remettre dans le
mois qui suit la promulgation de la loi
sur ces capteurs là et sur les
intentions du gouvernement pour répondre
à ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure le
rapporteur sur l'encadrement des prix
j'aurais bien aimé que la ministre
plutôt que de se contenter d'une réponse
défavorable favorable d'où 10 d'auxi le
gouvernement al'intention
effectivement d'encadrer le prix des
masques ffp2 et s'il a l'intention comme
l'a demandé monsieur daumier d'en mettre
à disposition des plus vulnérables pour
lesquelles il s'avère que c'est fort
utile alors on l'a vu de la commission
concernant l'amendement numéro 150 de
madame à ça si il s'agit d'une
incitation donc ça n'a pas vraiment de
porter c'est plutôt un amendement
d'appel leur après on peut disserter
très longtemps sur l'intérêt des
capteurs de co2 des purificateurs etc il
ya quand même des moyens simples qui
sont rappelées très clairement c'est
d'aérer très régulièrement aussi on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir un capteur de co2 qui
va clignoter dans tous les sens pour
réaliser qu'il faut ouvrir les fenêtres
c'est donc un avis défavorable
et puis sur l'amendement
[Musique]
numéro 115 c'est une demande de rapport
justement sur les capteurs de co2 et la
commission des affaires sociales vous
connaissez sa position concernant les
rapports c'est un avis défavorable
c'est un avis défavorable au pardon et
pour répondre à monsieur larouche qui me
demandait sur le contrôle des prix
pour ça je disserter à côté de moi et
c'était pour vous répondre c'est qu'on a
les instruments juridiques pour le faire
sous l'encadrement que vous parliez mais
à ce stade il n'y en a pas encore de il
n'y a pas encore le besoin exprimé voilà
mais si mais si ça vole du gaz
au vote oui merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues la mélisse même la
rapporteure ce qu'a dit manama ça si
il faut le regarder avec esprit de
responsabilité puisque c'est à la mode
anna massassi a fait une incitation sur
ce qui est demandé
partout où vous consultez dans le
domaine médical donc on peut pas
répondre seulement ouvrir ou fermer les
fêtes quand des experts nous disent que
les capteurs co2 sont une incitation
justement ouvrir et fermer les fenêtres
et que ça permette est en alerte et que
les purificateurs on sont des éléments
de réponses fiables
donc voilà il faut c'est pas une
invention du groupe et du groupe
communiste et moi je vous demanderai à
madame la ministre bref voilà j'ai
demandé à ma préfète jeudi dernier je
suis dans le val de marne 47 communes
j'ai demandé quelle est la nature du
dispositif du fonds mis en place par le
gouvernement et les dispositifs
donner aux maires aux présidents du
département et à la présidente de région
on est demain matin mais sur le
président il est 1h 5 j'ai toujours pas
la réponse que comme parlementaire je
n'ai pas c'est peut-être pas
catastrophique
non peut pas renvoyer la patate chaude
aux collectivités territoriales aux
maires aux présidents de département et
au président de région et quand un
parlementaire quelle que soit son
étiquette politique questionne sur un
dispositif mis en place par le
gouvernement sur un fond on est
incapable d'avoir la répartition et les
critères et on nous parle de l'urgence
de cette loi de 7-2-2 se
passe de se laisser passer vaccinale et
quand on discute concrètement capteurs
co2 purificateur dans les écoles on un
mouvement demain et on nous répond quoi
donc c'est pas une question d'
incitation moi je vous demande demandé
aux préfets dès demain qu'ils informent
tous les maires oui dans mais je crie
pas j'ai la voix forte depuis des mois
voilà ça veut pas dire que vous
m'entendez ça veut pas dire que vous
m'entendez mais bb oui mais le droit
d'être passionné en politique
voilà c'est même mieux donc je vous le
dit madame je vais essayer de me compte
mais bon c'est pas grave hein faut
entendre quand même hein allez un peu de
sourire
appelé les maires demain voilà appelé
les maires ap les présidents de
départements appelé président de région
expliquez-leur le dispositif
d'accompagnement du gouvernement pour
équiper les écoles de la maternelle à
l'université avec des capteurs et des
purificateurs merci monsieur le
président au caillou
c'est peut-être parce qu il se fait tard
mais je voudrais apporter à la fois le
mon soutien à ce qu'a demandé bernard
jomier tout à l'heure il ya quelques
jours l'ap-hp à signaler que parmi les
patients qui était triplement vacciner
70 % sont immunodéprimés
70% donc sa demande elle justifié la
demande de monsieur benarroch soyez
monsieur benarroch j'ai pas un esprit
partisan
j'étais ici un de ceux qui depuis un an
demande à l'état de prendre en charge
les capteurs des co2 parce qu'on sait la
science nous a montré que ça n'est pas
par les gouttelettes et par les aérosols
que tout cela se propage et que si au
printemps aussi à l'été on ouvre les
fenêtres spontanément on ne le fait pas
en hiver qu'un capteur un capteur co2
c'est 100 euros et j'estime que ce n'est
pas aux collectivités
mais ce serait une mesure de santé
publique voilà et c'est à l'état quand
je vois le quoi qu'il en coûte et les
dizaines de milliards est-ce qu'on peut
pas équiper nos classes dans les écoles
élémentaires dans toutes les écoles
primaires dans les collèges et les
lycées avec des capteurs de co2 mes
chers collègues et vous savez qu'il ya
eu deux études j'en rajoute par surcroît
une première étude ya quatre ans 2016 je
crois qu'elle est de du danemark et une
étude récente de harvard qui montre que
l'aération des classes vous écarter la
problématique au vide mais renforce les
compétences cognitives les performances
cognitives des élèves c'est à dire que
on a une meilleure aptitude à apprendre
à apprendre lorsqu'il ya voilà des
fenêtres qui sont régulièrement ouvertes
donc c'est tout bénéfice donc voilà je
veux dire je comprends je comprends la
commission mais très franchement
on dépense des milliards et des
milliards alors que et on veut laisser
l'école ouverte donc prenons-en les
moyens
alors
où il ajouté
je n'ai pas moi non plus l'esprit
partisan j'approuve totalement ce qu'il
vient de dire et je me lie à sa démarche
et je demande donc au gouvernement à
l'état de prendre charge effectivement
nous ne pouvons pas le faire dans le
cadre d'un amendement dans le cadre de
cette loi il aurait était recevable mais
nous le demandons tous ici donc sur tous
les bords d'une manière transparente
isad madame la ministre fait quelque
chose si vous voulez lutter contre
l'épidémie il ya urgence effectivement à
lutter contre la propagation du virus et
qui pour les gens qui en ont besoin et
les lieux qui en ont besoin de marquer
de masques ffp2 équipant les écoles de
deux capteurs de co2 nous aurons
beaucoup progresser ensemble et l'état
aura contribué à cette progression sans
faire reposer la totalité de l'effort
sur les collectivités je rajouterais
pour la rapporteure que quand vous dites
basse et naturel n'y a pas besoin de
capteurs pour ouvrir les fenêtres certes
mais il ya besoin aussi de capteurs
effectivement pour éduquer les gens pour
les former pour les habituer à ouvrir
les fenêtres c'est comme si vous nous
disiez il n'y a pas besoin de compteurs
kilométriques sur les voitures pour
réguler la vitesse au delà d'une vitesse
qui est pas tolérée bassi il faut à
capteurs de vitesse pour savoir à quelle
vitesse on roule c'est bien de savoir la
saturation au co2 de l'air et donc c'est
bien d'avoir des capteurs au co2 ça
aidera à aérer les classes mais s'ils
devaient soumettre le moment 150 ratifié
au vote
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
manifestants devant la main
ceux qui sont favorables
avis contraire
il est adopté
et fait tomber sur
un amendement 39 rectifiée présentée par
mona muller brawn
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à demander que le
gouvernement rende au parlement un
rapport pour les 30 juin 2022 sur les
effets indésirables liés à la
vaccination
en effet le 1er décembre dernier lors de
l'audition devant la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat
différents agents de l'agencé nationale
de sécurité du médicament et des
produits de la santé oms puisse
s'exprimer sur le souci des effets
indésirables
faisant suite à l'injection des vaccins
arn antique au lead des médecins de la
santé publique parle de 20% d'effets
indésirables en plus comparativement à
des vaccins dits classiques nous
souhaitons donc toute la transparence
sur cette vaccination et demandons que
le gouvernement rende au parlement un
rapport pour les 30 juin 2022 merci
madame le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président oui
effectivement il peut y avoir certains
effet un des riverains
indésirables pardon qui sont référencés
mais qui sont très rares pour l'immense
majorité des cas c'est le bilan qui est
fait des dizaines de millions
d'injections réalisés dans notre pays
mais ce n'est pas au gouvernement de
produire ce rapport vous l'avez dit
c'est aux autorités sanitaires
indépendante et la nsm produit tous les
quinze jours un rapport actualisé de
pharmacovigilance sur les vaccins et les
traitements et notre commission des
affaires sociales a auditionné en
décembre dernier la sm sur ce sujet et
donc nous sommes très attentifs à ses
conclusions pour toutes ces raisons
indépendamment que c'est une demande de
rapport c'est un avis défavorable
du gouvernement
mais ma vie
je consulte ceux qui sont favorables à
des manifestants devant la barre
avis contraire n'est pas adopté
un amendement qui porte le numéro 113
monsieur b laroche
permanence des rapports mais nous sommes
bien obligés pour au pointé un certain
nombre de sujets de demander des
rapports sur des sujets où nous ne
pouvons pas demander pour des causes
d'irrecevabilité un certain nombre de
décisions il ne vous a pas échappé tout
le monde les a vus
que aujourd'hui il y à une inégalité
géographique et sociale importante dans
les politiques publiques sanitaires
les derniers chiffres et soeurs de
l'assurance maladie montre que pour
toutes les tranches d'âge la totalité
des tranches d'âge le taux de
vaccination dans les communes et les
quartiers les plus défavorisés reste
significativement inférieur à celui
qu'on observe dans les communes plus
favorisés donc cette partie là de
l'anneau vaccination ne doit pas être
obéré par une sorte de lutte manichéenne
entre les vacciner les non vaccinés donc
nous pensons primordial est utile en
tout cas de demander au gouvernement un
rapport qui étudie les raisons
justifiant les différences du rythme de
vaccination c'est de la population entre
ces différentes zones géographiques et
entre les différents niveaux soucier
sociaux et économiques des différents
quartiers des grandes villes ses
conclusions doivent permettre
d'accélérer la vaccination ce qui est
quand même le but recherché mais
semble-t-il par le gouvernement et par
la plupart d'entre nous auprès des
populations les plus fragiles et les
plus isolés et de présenter un bilan des
actions prises afin qu'elles ne viennent
pas s'ajouter à des fractures
préexistantes
le vide de la commission
merci monsieur le président
je voudrais rappeler aux auteurs de cet
amendement que notre commission des
affaires sociales exerce pleinement ses
compétences de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement
nous entendons bien sûr régulièrement le
gouvernement mais aussi les autorités
sanitaires l'assurance maladie ou le
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale nous avons toujours une
mission d'information en cours sur la
pandémie donc au delà du fait que c'est
une demande de rapport vous voyez bien
que le contrôle est exercé et que ce
n'est pas forcément au gouvernement à
produire ce rapport mais plutôt à nous
commission des affaires sociales à
travailler et à auditionner ces
organisations
le ministre a
donc ceux qui sont favorables
manifestants devant la mer
avis contraire on pas à l'autre et nous
allons examiner les amendements 151 et
rectifier il est présenté par le
président laurent
merci monsieur le président non il
s'agit d'une demande de rapport mais là
aussi vous savez très bien pour qu'on en
a rapporté avoir soulevé le débat ici
puisqu'on peut pas le faire de deux
manières différentes
mons a assuré punir tout à l'heure quand
ça a été évoqué dans d'étudier la
nécessité d' extension
de l'obligation du masque ffp2 alors on
énonce un certain nombre de catégories
de population qui pourraient être
concernés mais justement demandé un
rapport au gouvernement pour préciser la
nécessité la possibilité de cette
extension et la prise en charge
évidemment pour les populations
concernées du coup de ces masques ffp2
par l'état donc c'est l'objet de ce
rapport
l'avis de la commission
défavorables ces présidents
l'avis du gouvernement mais ma vie n'est
pas favorable
je consulte ceux qui sont favorables
manifestants pour la main
avis contraire n'est pas adoptée et nous
allons passer un amendement 117 rectifié
monsieur benachenhou
que
madame la ministre pourra dire même avis
pas de problème
à compter du 15 au 17 octobre 2021 sens
pour raisons médicales
les tests de dépistage du coc u19 sont
tous devenus payants pour les adultes
non vaccinés les personnes majeures nos
vacciner sans ordonnance doivent donc
débourser la somme de 44 euros pour un
test pcr normalement à peu près vrai 2
euros pour un test antigénique en
laboratoire
25 à 30 euros en pharmacie et 5 euros 20
pour un autotest 12 euros 90 il est
supervisé par un professionnel de
chanter le budget qui peut être
conséquents pour les personnes en
situation de précarité
plusieurs conséquences prévisibles ont
été constatées sur cette catégorie de
population en particulier une baisse du
taux de dépistage pour les adultes non
vaccinés et une belle de dépistage pour
les adultes asymptomatiques le conseil
scientifique s'était inquiété de la fin
de l'année dernière d'une certaine forme
de difficultés d'interprétation des
données épidémiologiques
du fait de la flambée des contaminations
et la cinquième vague de ce qu'on
appelle la septième vague ducobu 19 il
apparaît nécessaire de revenir sur cette
mesure afin que l'ensemble des citoyens
français puissent avoir recours à un
dépistage ducobu 19 non conditionnés à
leurs moyens financiers
en vue de la commission
merci monsieur le président au delà du
fait qu'il s'agit d'une demande de
rapport je voudrais quand même revenir
sur un point de votre amendement vous
parler de gratuité
la gratuité n'existe pas vous savez bien
que c'est pris en charge par l'assurance
maladie
c'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
chose que de dire que c'est gratuit et
les tests de dépistage ont quand même
coûté sur l'année 2021 plus de plus de
6,2 milliards d'euros et puis je vous
rappelle qu'actuellement les tests sont
encore très largement prise en charge
puisque ils sont gratuits pour les
mineurs et que pour toutes les personnes
vaccinées ils sont également gratuits
donc c'est un avis défavorable
donc je ceux qui sont favorables le
manifestant devant la main
avis contraire peut pas adopter un
moment 150 de rectifier ses vols depuis
mai mais remercie monsieur le président
mes chers collègues la mamie nice - et
dit que fallait que je parle moins fort
ce qui était le cas du collège
retailleau ce qu'était le cas du
collègue benarroch ils ont au parler
moins fort votre avis est et silence
complet l'avis défavorable pas
d'argumentation sur les capteurs co2 si
si c'est vérifiable pas d'avis de votre
part sur les capteurs co2 vis-à-vis des
collectivités territoriales et des
purificateurs voilà donc je vais essayer
vraiment de contrôler ma voix et voir là
ce que vous allez dire messine scolaire
pareil article 40
mais voyez c'est aussi ça qui fait que
notre groupe il va pas voter ce pass
vaccinale parce qu'il sait pas au niveau
la réponse depuis le temps qu'on connaît
la question du virus on aurait dû
réorganiser la médecine scolaire
regardons les chiffres la visite
médicale est obligatoire avec un bilan
sixième et douzième année en 2018 yak 18
% des élèves en 6e année qui ont été
contrôlés par un médecin scolaire
on a moins de 1000 médecins scolaires
pour millions trois cent cinquante cinq
mille élèves ça fait un médecin pour
treize mille élèves et voyez quand
demain on à la wii on à la colère de
beaucoup de parents et d'enseignants par
rapport au dispositif au protocole
scolaire c'est parce qu'un médecin
scolaire il fait tout ce travail de
prévention vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de la
population et le aller vers moi je vais
vous dire quand on dit qu'on va aller
vers les gens les plus défavorisés les
plus éloignées du droit commun et ben
moi j'ai connu la médecine scolaire ou
les plus pauvres les que il avait le
droit à la médecine scolaire ils étaient
à égalité
et sa compagne l éducation nationale
parce que le but de la médecine scolaire
c'est aussi d'accompagner tout le
personnel de l'école donc c'est un
travail de prévention extrêmement
important c'est pour ça que le groupe
pense qu'il faut revoir la question de
la place et le rôle de la médecine
scolaire pas par nostalgie mais
réellement parce qu'il ya des risques
sanitaires dans ce passage de vie et que
la médecine scolaire peut être vraiment
un accompagnement à l'école et un
accompagnement la citoyenneté quand on
veut convaincre quand on veut aller vers
on parle terrain légalité et on met des
moyens où on est à égalité devant le
droit à la santé madame la ministre
j'espère pas avoir parlé trop fort et
vous avoir provisionné un problème
folique merci oui mais vous pouvez faire
comme ça mais moi vous ne faites pas
comme ça vous répondez vous argumentez
madame la ministre vous argumentez très
bien
l'avis de la commission
c'est un avis défavorable monsieur le
président
alors c'est un avis défavorable
s'agissant d'un rapport je vous
rappellerai monsieur que dans l'article
41 à du projet de loi de la loi 3ds que
vous avez eu l'occasion d'examiner avant
l'assemblée nationale prévoit d'ores et
déjà la remise d'un rapport sur la
médecine scolaire donc voilà je pense
que vous l'avez déjà voté s'est
satisfait donc roger pour celui ci et
puis vous savez monsieur depuis tout à
l'heure je répond j'aurais point ce que
je peux dire j'aurais po ce que je peux
répondre et je n'extrapole ray jamais
sachez-le je suis pas de ce genre là à
dire des choses dont je n'ai pas encore
la possession complètement de
l'information vous m'interrogez sur bien
sûr à 1h23 je vais vous dire que nous
allons financer les masques nous allons
financer les purificateurs enfin
franchement soyons sérieux donc moi je
vous respecte et j'aimerais bien aussi
que vous respectiez le fait que je fais
mon travail que j'essaie de répondre à
chaque fois est vraiment ce ton là je
trouve qu'il n'est pas approprié à mon
comportement merci
[Musique]
sur cet amendement merci monsieur le
président madame namyst vous venez de
rappeler à bon escient l'heure tardive
donc je ne vais pas être long je
voudrais juste profiter de l'observation
très juste qui était faite par notre
collègue sur la médecine scolaire et de
l'allusion que vous avez fait très juste
aussi à ce que le texte 3ds contient ça
contient un rapport on va dire non pas
par dépit mais notre conviction c'est
que la médecine scolaire est
effectivement d'une grande utilité
sociale parce qu'elle permet d'éviter
que des enfants et des familles passent
sous les radars des médecins et que nous
nous voulions dans 3ds que le
gouvernement accepte que la médecine
scolaire est à titre expérimental soit
prise en charge par les départements
dans les conditions qui qui leur
donnerait vraiment les moyens de le
faire et madame la mini je pense que la
crise sanitaire montre l'enjeu de la
médecine scolaire on ne réglera pas ce
soir mais je crois que ce rapport est
juste un fil que nous accrochons très
aimablement mais avec ferveur et
conviction votre pâte pour que nous
puissions continuer à avancer sur ce
sujet majeur
pour myron
oui merci monsieur le président je
voulais à mon tour soutenir la demande
faite par notre collègue communiste
parce qu'effectivement le problème de la
médecine scolaire est un problème
extrêmement important je ne vais pas
reprendre les chiffres qu'il a pu qu'il
a pu donner sur les inégalités
territoriales qui peut y avoir en
matière de médecine scolaire où on ne
peut passer de certains départements ou
alors que le chiffre idéal et d'un
médecin
scolaire pour 5000 certaines département
n'ont même pas un médecin d'autres l'ont
1 pour 90 mille enfants je crois que
c'est un problème extrêmement important
la soulevait déjà plusieurs reprises et
donc le groupe socialiste votera la
demande de membres du groupe communiste
en religion
oui merci monsieur le président moi je
vais juste dire à notre collègue pascal
savoldelli que je vais pas voter son
amendement que je vais suivre l'avis de
la rapporteure mais je partage
entièrement ce qui a été dit sur la
médecine scolaire nous allons avoir à
débattre prochainement d'un texte sur le
harcèlement scolaire et là encore la
médecine scolaire c'est forcément un
outil qui peut être essentielle pour
leur repérage et l'accompagnement du
harcèlement scolaire donc bien entendu
je suis l'avis du rapporteur mais je
partage à 100% parce que c'est une
demande de rapport les remarques qui ont
été faites et je souhaite qu'on met tout
en oeuvre désormais dans les mois et
dans les mois qui viennent et qui
renvoie vont voir des échéances arrivée
importante pour que la médecine scolaire
soit enfin un sujet qu'on prenne à bras
le corps je vous remercie
je mets la roche
152 et hischier ceux qui sont favorables
à son adoption manifestants devant la
main
avis contraire
l'abstention n'est pas adoptée
après l'article
1er août yes un amendement
147 il est bon
il est retiré
un amendement qui porte le numéro 34
l'impôt mirror le présente
oui mais si président s'est fait
présenter
il s'agit de problèmes des brevets à
l'initiative de l'afrique du sud plus de
120 pays il y ait vu syndicats et
organisations de la société civile on
demande une dérogation temporaire des
obligations qui sont liées à l'accord at
pic de l'om c'est sur les droits de
propriété intellectuelle liée au
commerce
cette dérogation facilitera le partage
la propriété intellectuelle du savoir
faire nécessaire pour accroître et
accélérer la disponibilité
l'accessibilité et le caractère
abordable des accents tests et
traitements contre la copie de 19 dans
le monde je rappelle qu'en 2001 sous la
pression de l'opinion publique mondiale
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques avait
dû finalement se résoudre à laisser
l'afrique du sud qui était ravagé à ce
moment là par l'épidémie du sida fait
reproduire en inde des génériques
d'antiviraux et ça a été un véritable
tournant dans l'histoire donc de l'om
c'est à l'époque il s'agissait donc de
permettre la fabrication de génériques
de synthèse aujourd'hui accéder au
brevet de ces vaccins de nouvelle
génération reste pourtant insuffisant et
la déclaration commune lancia
l'initiative de msf qui sera rendu
public dans quelques jours insiste
également sur l'accès au savoir faire
aux données et aux ressources liées à la
recherche et au développement
l'enjeu est tel qu'ils hésitent
d'engagement majeur des états auprès
d'institutions internationales pour que
les laboratoires accepte de transférer
ces technologies développées
signature de cette déclaration commune
les membres du groupe est saine
socialistes écologistes et républicains
souhaitent que la france soutienne
activement cette proposition au niveau
international en complément et au delà
des mécanismes kovacs egalgi de
distribution simple des vaccins il faut
que les pays en développement puissent
eux mêmes être des acteurs du but contre
la pandémie je rappelle que l'émergence
division récente ne va rien au micro à
partir de l'afrique du sud démontre s'il
est encore besoin l'urgence d'un accès
plus égalitaire au niveau 2 du monde
entier contre le co lead merci alors
l'avis de la commission le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
cette cet amendement ou en tout cas
l'objet de cet amendement a été abordé à
plusieurs reprises en particulier lors
de l'examen de l'article 1 les partages
des droits pour la recherche l'accès et
la production du vaccin ça va bien au
delà du cadre national y compris du
cadre européen et les différentes firmes
les différents laboratoires ont déjà
laissé entendre qu'ils étaient prêts à
une coopération
pour la recherche dans ces domaines
c'est à une demande de rapport danse et
un avis défavorable
du gouvernement même avis
explications
le consul ceux qui sont favorables à cet
amendement le manifestant devant la mort
avis contraire
je n'ai pas adopté je vais mettre revoir
l'article 1er nonies qui n'est pas
modifié lui
ceux qui sont favorables manifestants
dans la meuse
[Musique]
avis contraire
abstention
il était doté
après l'article 1er nonies un amendement
soit 95 rectifiée présentée par le
gouvernement madame la ministre parce
qu'il monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui vise à rétablir les
possibilités offertes par l' ordonnance
du 25 mars 2020 aux assemblées aux
organes dirigeants des personnes morales
aux autres entités de droit privé en
matière de réunion et délibérations à
distance dont les dispositions sont
arrivés à échéance en septembre 2021
dans le contexte actuel de reprise de
l'épidémie il s'agit d'une part de
permettre au gouvernement de prendre par
ordonnance les mesures nécessaires au
bon fonctionnement de leurs
délibérations et leurs réunions et
d'autre part autorisé immédiatement les
organes collégiaux d'administration de
surveillance de direction des personnes
morales de droit privé comme par exemple
les conseils d'administration de
surveillance des sociétés à se réunir et
à prendre des décisions à distance david
que
commission monsieur reporter merci
monsieur le président et la commission a
eu un regard bienveillant pour cet
amendement est un certain nombre de ceux
qui vont suivre
et alors qu'elle aurait pu émettre un
avis défavorable parce que ils ne sont
pas compris dans l'objet du texte et par
conséquent si le conseil constitutionnel
devait être saisie de la loi si elle est
votée il prendrait l'initiative de dire
que
c'est non conformes à aux exigences
constitutionnelles de la procédure
législative à cause de l'article 45 de
la constitution
et il le fait
coups sûrs
alors nous nous sommes dit néanmoins que
plutôt que d'émettre un avis défavorable
pour une raison juridique nous pouvions
nous en remettre à la sagesse de notre
assemblée car si notre assemblée a
adopté ces amendements très technique ça
permettrait peut-être de leur donner une
chance car ils ont un intérêt pratique
indéniable c'est le cas avec cet
amendement donc si le gouvernement avait
un petit peu mieux anticiper les
exigences
législatives
il aurait pu intégrer ça à son projet de
loi et à ce moment là il n'aurait eu
aucun embarras et nous n'avons pas le
pouvoir de le sortir de cet embarras
croyait bien madame la ministre que je
le regrette profondément
mais je m'en remets à la sagesse du
sénat
l' explication de vote je n'en vois
poids le sujet a été abordé
début de soirée
ceux qui sont favorables
il ya une sagesse le manifestant devant
la main
avis contraire
attention il est adopté
197 présenté par le gouvernement
c'est un amendement qui vise à réactiver
le dispositif prévu par l' ordonnance du
7 mai 2020 prolongé ensuite en juin en
ce qui concerne les modalités de
résolution financière de certains
contrats en cas de force majeur dans le
secteur de la culture et du sport ce
dispositif a permis aux organisateurs
des manifestations culturelles et
sportives contraint d'annuler leur
contrat de vente de billets d'abonnement
du fait de la crise de proposer à leurs
clients un avoir en lieu et place de
remboursement des sommes versées
naviguait
commission même chose que le précédant
sa mort et j'ai
même vote
après
un amendement est un seul sous
amendement qui va faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune un amendement
présenté par le gouvernement sous amendé
par mr a fait
le job le ministre
présente amendement a pour objet de
rétablir la possibilité que les
prestations de serment réaliser au cours
d'une audience juridictionnelle soit
faite par écrit la possibilité de
prestation de serment par écrit évite
les rassemblements de nombreuses
personnes qui viennent ensemble prêté
serment nouveau aux auditeurs reçu à
l'école nationale de la magistrature
élèves-avocats nouveaux avocats et
cetera elle est donc un outil nécessaire
à la lutte contre la propagation
d'épidémies
monsieur françois
merci monsieur le président lorsque j'ai
vu cet amendement je me suis dit que il
y avait quand même plusieurs façons de
lutter contre la pandémie et que ont
choisi c'est peut-être le d'associer la
solution de facilité
avec cet amendement c'est pour ça que je
propose ce sous-amendement qui dont
l'objet est assez simple c'est à dire de
limiter le recours aux prestations de
serment par écrit aux situations les
plus à risque parce que pour être
sérieux un petit peu madame la ministre
vous ne me dirais pas que pour ses
prestations de serment surtout lorsqu'on
va être avocat ce qui est un moment très
important dans la vie d'un avocat on ne
peut pas surtout avec le gigantesque
tribunal que l'on a à paris faire là les
sessions en plusieurs parties et non pas
regrouper tout le monde dans des salles
qui au demeurant sont gigantesques au
tribunal de paris dans les juridictions
de pro grâce ça peut aussi s'organiser
différemment donc je trouve qu'avec cet
amendement madame la ministre on a été
un peu vite en besogne et que par mon
sous-amendement on permet de ré hab lire
les choses dans leur juste milieu
immédiat c'est à dire tous comme on dit
en breton
l'avis de la commission
mais si le président heureusement que
nous avons un texte relatif au
renforcement des outils de gestion de la
crise sanitaire pour pouvoir enfin
parler de la prestation de serment des
magistrats et des avocats
et il fallait vraiment que le
gouvernement
mobilise toutes les ressources de son
intelligence pour en arriver là
est vraiment je l'en félicite
le sous-amendement monsieur fera ça me
paraît très bien mais je n'ai pas pu
enfin j'ai demandé à vérité au président
de la commission des lois de bien
vouloir demander une suspension de
séance pour que la commission se
réunisse mais n'a pas voulu le faire
alors j'y ai renoncé et je me permets à
titre personnel de donner un avis
favorable sur monsieur fera ça à votre
amendement en revanche pour l'amendement
du gouvernement je m'en remets à votre
sagesse
l'avis du gouvernement
si on le sous-amendement bien évidemment
alors je vais commencer par consulter
par les conventions parce que nous avons
de bons qui a soulevé l'enthousiasmé du
rapporteur
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
manifeste en levant la main
avis contraire
et ça donnerait à l'amendement ainsi
sous-amendé
et je vais faire voter mentaux ainsi se
demander ce qu'ils sont favorables son
adoption manifestants devant l'amas
avis contraire
abstention
il est adopté
ensuite l'article 2
qui est supprimée mais auparavant l
amendement et deux sous amendement est
présenté par le gouvernement
comme le milicien l'article 2 qui a
supprimé
c'est le 204 6 1 alors le présente
amendement vise à rétablir les
dispositions qui t'avait qui avait été
adoptée à l'assemblée nationale la
nécessité des systèmes d'information
dans le cadre de la lutte contre
l'épidémie n'est plus à établir les
dispositions supprimées par la
commission des lois ont vocation à
permettre un nouvel usage essentiel des
données qui figurent en ajustant aux
finalités de ses systèmes d'information
le contrôle du respect de l'obligation
d'étiquetage par les personnes mises en
quarantaine ou en isolement et en
permettant aux services préfectoraux de
recevoir les données nécessaires à cette
nouvelle finalité dans le cadre des
mesures de placement en quarantaine ou
en isolement une obligation de dépistage
est imposée aux personnes concernées
notamment pour permettre la levée des
mesures de manière anticipée la mise en
oeuvre du contrôle de ce dépistage
implique nécessairement pour les
services préfectoraux de pouvoir accéder
au test réalisé par les personnes
concernées ainsi qu'à leurs résultats
l'autorisation des services préfectoraux
à recevoir les données dsi qu'ovide 19
sera donc très circonscrites dans son
objet les dispositions proposées ont été
jugés conformes aux règles de protection
des données par le conseil d'état dans
son avis sur le projet de loi elles
seront précisées par décret en conseil
d'état après avis de la cnil donc le
gouvernement estime nécessaire que ces
dispositions essentielles à la lutte
contre l'épidémie entourée de garanties
suffisantes au plan de la protection des
données soit adopté
mais ci dessous d'amendements ou jules
compte
oui merci monsieur le président d'abord
je commenterai part salué
l'attention du rapporteur sur la
nécessité de veiller à ce que les
données du fichier si dell qui contient
des données médicales ne soit pas
communiqué aux services préfectoraux
c'est une position constante du
rapporteur et de la commission toutefois
il me semble que dans un cas précis
il pourrait être raisonnable de faire
une exception et c'est ce qui a été
évoqué par madame la ministre toutefois
dans l'amendement du gouvernement
les choses ne sont pas suffisamment
précises
dans l'objet c'est clair dans le
dispositif ça pour ça permet des choses
plus large donc les deux sous-amendement
permet d'une part de d'indiquer que ça a
vocation à être
un accès pour des personnes spécialement
habilités ce que le gouvernement précise
dans l'objet d'amendements mais pas dans
l'amendement et deuxièmement nous
proposons de limiter enfin je propose de
limiter
les informations qui seraient transmis
aux préfectures
lorsque les résultats des tests des
dépistages serait négatif de manière à
permettre d'élever des quarantaines et
c'est un réel sujet parce que
aujourd'hui nous voyons un certain
nombre de quarantaine qui sont
surveillés par les préfectures
les personnes ont leur quarantaine levée
parce qu'elles ont des tests négatifs
les préfectures ne sont pas au courant
les services de police continuent à
surveiller les quarantaines alors
qu'elles n'ont plus lieu d'être mais
parce qu'ils ne sont pas au courant et
donc ça ça conduit les forces de police
à venir vérifier si les personnes sont
là elles sont là elles sont partis parce
qu'elles ont eu leurs quarante élevé
mais les préfectures ne sais pas donc
pour cette raison il me semble
préférable de préciser les choses mais
d'adopter effectivement
une exception au principe que le
rapporteur
à 1 me de ne pas de ne pas donner
l'accès aux fichiers cidep uo préfecture
justement pour éviter ces problèmes je
crois de toute façon que ça a vocation à
continuer de manière à ce que en cmp on
tombe sur un bon équilibre et et ma
contribution ce sont ces deux
amendements de manière à avancer sur ce
texte la visite de monsieur reporter
c'est le président c'est un sujet
complet complexe et est assez
particulier il ya des mises à
l'isolément de personnes qui viennent de
l'étranger et qui sont malades et il ya
des mises en quarantaine de personnes
qui viennent de l'étranger et qui sont
simplement qu'à contacter
isolement quarantaine c'est pas tout à
fait le même régime il n'est pas prévu
dans les textes de tests de dépistage
pour sortir de l'isolément ou de la
quarantaine
et l'obligation qui serait fait de
communiquer aux services du préfet le
résultat d'un test de dépistage nous est
apparu comme étant un peu surprenante et
par conséquent nous avions supprimée du
texte qui nous est venue de l'assemblée
nationale cette disposition et nous
l'avions déjà fait à l'occasion d'un
précédent vote sur l'un des textes
relatifs à l'urgence sanitaire
nous avons donc une position cohérente
et constante et nous n'avons pas
souhaité en changer sur ce point et par
conséquent la vie sur l'amendement du
gouvernement est défavorable
et il est aussi dans un même ensemble
pour les abonnements de notre collègue
j'arrive le compte
l'avis du gouvernement sur les bijoux
amendements
sur le sous-amendement 205 qui les
satisfait
rejet pour le deuxième il était
favorable
je vais consulter d'abord
sur le sous-amendement 206 ceux qui sont
favorables son adoption manifestants
levant la main
avis contraire
pas adopter même voix pour les 205
j'avais consulté si on a un rendement
204 du gouvernement avis défavorable de
la commission
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
de manifestants devant la main
avec contraire
n'est pas adopté
la petite est temps de supprimer et nous
passons à -62 mais il a été retiré avant
le début de la séance vous l'avez dans
votre liasses fed a été retiré avant le
début de la sienne
pas son article 3 de demandes de parole
madame de seine
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre nous allons aborder l'article 3
sur l'isolément et la contention dans le
cadre de soins psychiatriques sans
consentement
je ne serai pas langue étant donné que
l'heure tardive où nous examinons ces
dispositions je me bornerai à une
remarque est une question une remarque
d'abord cet article vise à combler une
double censure du conseil
constitutionnel
triple censure même puisque le
gouvernement malgré les avertissements
du sénat avait inscrit un bel fss un
cavalier social manifeste de fait nous
retrouvons à devoir adopter en urgence
une disposition qui requiert une
particulière vigilance dans un véhicule
législatif
disons le peut a pour prier une question
ensuite lié c'est urgent justement
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 les
dispositions relatives au renouvellement
des mesures d'isolement et de contention
sont abrogés même si légifrance ne
l'indiquent pas c'est bien juridiquement
le cas du fait de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel rendue en juin 2021 ma
question est donc simple quelle est la
situation concrète dans les services de
soins sans consentement depuis 13 jours
comment de telles mesures d'isolement ou
de contention sont elles prises et
renouvelé comment les médecins et
hôpitaux sont ils en capacité de veiller
à la sécurité des patients mais aussi de
leur environnement et des soignants
comment le juge et il en capacité d'être
saisie et de faire respecter les droits
fondamentaux des patients je vous
remercie
de deuxième demande de parole
madame répond c'est mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président
effectivement c'est la deuxième fois que
cet article nous est proposé il répond
vous venez de le dire à la décision de
la double décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui ordonnait une
révision de la loi avant le 31 décembre
la date passée nous trouvons devant un
vide juridique et en conséquence les
mesures d'isolement et de contention
ordonné depuis le 1er janvier non plus
de cadre légal mais on ne peut contester
que cet article ne présente aucun lien
direct ou indirect avec le texte de loi
que nous examinons il demeure à notre
avis un cavalier législatif comme il
hier dans le plfss
il s'avérait un cavalier social au
risque d'être de nouveau déclaré
d'ailleurs contraire à la constitution
certes il faut combler le vide juridique
et nous sommes bien obligés de fermer
les yeux cette fois ci ce cavalier
législatif
mais nous ne pouvons admettre que ces
dispositions ne soit pas proposée par le
gouvernement dans un projet de loi de
santé mentale afin de permettre le la
parlementaire le peu de place dans les
débats et amendement de l'assemblée
nationale sur cet article prouve s'il
était nécessaire que le débat
fondamental sur ces dispositions n'a pas
eu lieu et qu'il risque dès lors d'être
forclos pour très longtemps ce faisant
la psychiatrie reste le point aveugle de
nous des bases sur la santé comme
l'ondam psychiatrie on est le parent
pauvre pourtant l'audition du contrôleur
général des lieux de privation et de
liberté 1 a montré l'urgence d'un débat
sur l' usage voir le mésusage des
pratiques de contention et d'isolement
et l'exigence de questionner de
possibles alternatives aussi le
parlement ne peut être privé de ses
questionnements par le recours à ce
cavalier législatif
nous proposons donc de l'adopter pour le
présent tout en le limitant dans le
temps afin que l'urgence ne nous fasse
pas oublier l'essentiel je vous remercie
tout les re va me rapporter à vous avez
questionner où il y répondre et madame
pensée mange bien d'aborder aussi
madame les rapporteurs vous m'interrogez
sur la situation applicable aux mesures
d'isolement et de contention en
psychiatrie et depuis le 1er janvier
compte tenu des effets à compter de
cette date de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel que vous avez rappelé du
4 juin 2021 et de la censure de la
réforme que nous avions proposée en
pelles fss 2022 pour tirer les
conséquences de cette décision le
ministère de la justice et le mystère
n'a santé oms communiqué le 28 décembre
à leur service respectives les
dispositions s'appliquant à compter du
1er janvier 2022 à compter de cette date
au cur aucune mesure d'isolement et de
contentieux ne peuvent être de
contention par donc ne peuvent être
légalement être maintenu au delà des
durées respectives de 48 heures est de
24 heures en conséquence aucune
disposition législative ne permet au
juge des libertés et de la détention d'
autoriser le maintien de ces mesures au
delà de cette durée cette limitation
dans le temps des mesures d'isolement et
de contention n'a pas pour effet de
priver le juge des libertés
et de la détention de sa compétence à
contrôler les mesures d'isolement qui
reconnaissent les dispositions demeurant
en vigueur en complément je dois dire
que dans le contexte déjà difficile de
la psychiatrie que vous évoquez pénurie
de psychiatres infirmiers donc de
malades plus important cette censure
complexifie le quotidien des équipes
soignantes alors même qu'un texte d'
équilibre avait été trouvé entre les
représentants des patients et des
professionnels
les dispositions prévues par l'article 3
permettront de remédier à cette
situation transitoire et j'espère à ce
titre que le projet de loi pourrait être
promulguée dans les meilleurs délais
alors nous avons deux amendements
identiques
de de suppression
premier amendement de suppression
qui le défend il porte le numéro 53 quoi
avec qui philippe rayter
il n'est pas déformé et donc un
amendement
identique le réseau programme cots m oui
merci monsieur le président très
rapidement parce que finalement pourquoi
nous proposons niveau de notre groupe un
amendement de suppression c'est pour ce
qui a été exposé par les différentes
prises de parole et en fait j'ai bien
entendu écouter la réponse de madame la
ministre mais on peut pas se contenter
finalement sur une telle question d'en
faire une parenthèse dans une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale parce
que je je précise que ça avait déjà été
ce qu'avait fait le gouvernement
dean une parenthèse en fait dans ce
projet de loi de gestion de la crise
sanitaire il ya un vrai problème
effectivement au niveau de la
psychiatrie un manque de psychiatres
mais pas que c'est à dire ça fait des
années que ces petits gâterie à les
dépouiller et elle mérite vraiment une
véritable loi cadre et pas de mettre
dans un certain nombre de lois qui sont
destinés à autre chose quelques
mesurettes qui ne font pas du tout la
satisfaction ni des professionnels
de santé mentale ni dé patience c'est
donc la raison de la nôtre amendement de
suppression
alors le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le président d'abord
je veux rassurer tout le monde un
article initiale du texte ne peut pas
constituer un cavalier législatif
par contre sur le fond oui vous avez
tout à fait raison cet article n'a
strictement rien à voir avec la crise
sanitaire et le véhicule législatif
retenue n'est pas forcément est loin de
là le plus pertinent pour autant son
adoption est sans doute tout aussi
urgente que celles de l'article 1er dont
l'effet est attendu dès l'annoncé du
pass vaccinale en effet l'article 3 vise
à combler le vide juridique prévaut
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 puisque les
dispositions qu'il a pour objet de
modifier son réputé abrogé par une
décision du conseil constitutionnel du 4
juin
2021 c'est donc un avis pour ces raisons
défavorable sur cet amendement
le ministre lessard abl
donc je vais consulter ceux qui
le soutenir l'amendement 146 le
manifeste en levant la main
avis contraire
non ce n'est pas très adapté
et nous passons
à deux amendements identiques
je suis jolie
oui merci monsieur le président donc
très brièvement d'abord les amendements
que nous présentons sur cet article sont
essentiellement issu des préconisations
d'un contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté est là dans cet
amendement il s'agit d'ajouter à la
liste des personnes qui sont mentionnés
comme devant être prévenus en cas de
renouvellement de la mesure d'isolement
ou de contrainte la personne de
confiance qui est définie légalement et
7 ça nous paraît effectivement tout à
fait opportun de la mentionner
explicitement comme étant une des
personnes de pouvant être retenues dans
les personnes à prévenir
un possible amendement que prodige ne
rectifie d'un amendement identique
oui merci monsieur président l'article 3
donc un a déjà été utilement modifiée
lors du passage en commission sociale en
précisant la référence directe quant aux
personnes devant être informé du
renouvellement d'une mesure d'isolement
une contention à celle mentionnée à
l'article l 3213 tiré 12 là combien la
commission a complété la linea concernés
par l'ajout que le médecin fait part à
ces personnes de leur droit de saisir le
juge des libertés la détention aux fins
de main levée de la mesure nous l'avions
également souhaité et nous nous en
réjouissons notre amendement constate
cependant que cette référence ne
mentionne pas explicitement la personne
de confiance or la personne de confiance
institué par la loi de 2002 et dont les
missions ont été précisées par la loi de
2016 s'avère particulièrement utile en
ces situations un article du code de la
santé publique précise que lors de tout
spitz alisation dans un établissement de
santé il est proposé aux patients de
désigner une personne de confiance dont
le rôle est d'accompagner effectivement
le patient dans ses démarches de l'aider
à prendre des décisions et cette
personne doit être associée à la
recherche de consentement du patient
cette personne s'est elle a été demandée
et conséquence être informés lors d'une
mesure d'isolement ou de contention et
dès lors en cohérence avec le code de la
santé publique et dans un souci de
respect de l'intérêt et des droits des
patients il est pertinent d'ajouter nous
sommes pertinente ajouter à la liste des
personnes informées à l'article 3
explicitement nommément la personne de
confiance que le patient aurait désigné
dans le cadre de ces directives
anticipées ou de plan de soins conjoint
je vous remercie
de la commission d'amm le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président
en examen en commission la commission
avait donné un avis favorable sous
réserve de modifications que je vous
avais proposé vous avez apporté les
modifications nécessaires donc l'avis
est favorable et on a on fait référence
à la personne de confiance avis
favorable au gouvernement
il est notre avis c'est que cet
amendement il satisfait que son rejet
je vais soumettre
au vote ceux qui sont favorables à cet
amendement qui a reçu l'avis favorable
de la commission
[Musique]
manifestants devant l'amas avis
contraire
abstention on va pas vite adopté est
limité
il en est à six les deux amendements
à l'amendement 27 rectifié t présenté
par alain pomérols un merci monsieur le
président comme l'a dit mon collègue
bernard jomier
nos amendements ont été suggérées par le
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté qu'est ce qu'on
soit ont constaté des conditions
matérielles d'isolement qui mettait
méconnu par le l'office du juge des
lieux undine absurde une absence d'accès
à l'eau à des sanitaires absence de
boutons d'appel nématodes directement me
poser sur le sol des intérieurs de
chambre qui sont visibles par les autres
patients extra extra du patient qui sont
même à nu le juge ne doit donc pas
seulement vérifier la réalité de
l'existence des conditions qui
justifient la mesure c'est à dire le
danger pour lui même ou pour autrui mais
également vérifier que la mesure ne
porte pas une atteinte à la dignité et à
l'intimité de la personne on note en
pareil cas d'autres vérités sont mises
en place pour remédier au danger pour le
patient merci
un amendement
98 n'impose dumange
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
rappeler que les mesures de contention
et d'isolement reste des pratiques de
dernier recours et doivent respecter des
droits fondamentaux des patients dans
son rapport sur cette question en 2017
la haute autorité de santé soulignait
que les mesures d'isolement hypotension
doit toujours je cite respecter les
droits des patients à la dignité et au
respect de leur intégrité corporelle
rappel bienvenu au delà de son apparente
évidence cette recommandation fait écho
au code de la santé publique qui dans
son article l 3 1 3200 11-3 souligner
l'importance du respect de la dignité
principe par ailleurs largement est
régulièrement invoqué sur le par le
conseil constitutionnel dans un certain
nombre d'avis dont celui en 2010 sur la
contention et d'isolement il s'agit donc
d'un amendement aux cohérent avec les
textes juridiques dont dispose mais
c'est un rappel nécessaire
si l'on en juge par les nombreux
signalements pour traitements dégradants
dont ma collègue vient de parler relevés
par les autorités depuis de nombreuses
années en 2016 en 2020 le contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté rendait à 6,2 rapport accablant
sur les conditions de prise en charge
des patients en psychiatrie selon le
contrôleur dans certaines institutions
le respect des droits de l'individu est
devenu secondaire et je le cite encore
les considérations autour des patients
et du respect de leurs droits ne trouve
pas une place suffisante jusqu'à porter
atteinte manifestement à la dignité du
patient s'agissant donc de mesures très
privative de liberté avec des
contraintes fortes sur le patient
celle-ci se prennent suite un
questionnement médicale mais aussi
éthique pour respecter les droits
fondamentaux du patient il nous semble
nécessaire d'inscrire ses droits dont
celui du respect de sa dignité au coeur
de ces pratiques et des questions
qu'elle pose
bien l'avis de la commission le reporter
merci monsieur le président l'amendement
nous semble satisfait en effet l'article
l 11 10-2 du code de la santé publique
prévoit déjà que la personne malade quel
que soit son état a droit au respect de
sa dignité c'est donc une demande de
retrait ou à défaut un avis défavorable
pour ces deux amendements 27 et 98 à vis
du gouvernement même avis
il ya donc un souhait de retrait
il est retiré non il est maintenu et 2
sont maintenus je soumets au vote
donc avec un avis défavorable
à ce moment-là 27 rectifier pour
qui est contre il s'obtient merci même
vote je pense tout le monde ment 98
il est
vu comme amendement 28 rectifier une
erreur merci monsieur le président les
mesures d'isolement peu avec les pumas
ont concerné également des personnes qui
sont admises en soins libre mais qui
sont agitées ou en crise pour ces délais
pour ces personnes le délai de six ans
teaser pardon tu peux être cliniquement
justifié et a précisé qu on peut avoir
deux types de situations et art pour un
premier type de patients la situation va
mettre environ une heure et va permettre
donc un retour à une poursuite des
négociations après nelly de trois à
quatre heures le placement en soins sans
consentement d'un patient ne
correspondent pas aux conditions prévues
par la loi de 2011 or le changement de
statut démission entraîne des
conséquences juridiques particulièrement
graves qui ne sont pas justifiées par
leur état clinique pour les autres types
de patients dont l'agitation persiste il
s'agit de l'état que l'on peut rattacher
un trouble psychiatrique qui va
nécessiter du temps et pour eux donc
selon les critères de la loi ils
répondent bien aux critères de la loi et
les changements de statuts vers celui de
soins sans consentement est justifié il
faut rappeler que le diviseur prend
également en compte les temps de
changement d'équipé parce que ça peut
influer sur sur l'évolution du patient
enfin il faut rajouter que si dans une
situation de crise il nécessaire de
pratiquer une contre une contention
concomitante à l' isolement le délai le
même délai de six heures reste cohérent
avec le délai de six heures de la
convention prévue dans le texte en
discussion
alors l'avis de la commission
[Musique]
si je partage l'objectif de cet
amendement il ne peut pas être adopté à
lait dans l'état il conviendrait bien au
contraire de réécrire de façon plus
rigoureuse et dans des conditions plus
favorables que celles qui entourent
l'examen de ce texte l'ensemble de
l'article l32 22-5-1 pour prévoir ces
cas avis défavorable du gouvernement
même avis
demande explications de vote jean
lapointe ceux qui sont favorables le
manifestant devant la main
avis contraire
attention il n'est pas adopté un
amendement 31 rectifier un pomerol
oui monsieur brillant c'est juste à
l'amendement de conséquence donc il dit
qu
il retirait
il retiré
un amendement numéro 6 ans
merci monsieur le président je les dis
et je le répète c'est important le code
de la santé publique affirme le
caractère de dernier recours de
l'isolément et de la contention
toutefois et ça a été signalée par
laurence cohen le manque de personnel
conjugués aux insuffisances chroniques
de financement des soins en psychiatrie
et d'autres conditions
organisationnelles
dégradé conduit le personnel de certains
établissements à recourir trop souvent
aux mesures d'isolement et de contention
au risque de porter atteinte donc en
droits fondamentaux des patients dans
son commentaire sur sa visite au centre
hospitalier du forez en 2020 donc ces
récents le contrôle jean le contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté indique le recours à la
contention aux urgences se pratique
quatre à cinq fois par semaine et ne
fait l'objet d'aucune traçabilité comme
nous l'avons dit le contrôleur des
pleurs que le respect des droits humains
soient devenus secondaires dans beaucoup
à pas dans certains établissements table
à ce constat alarmant se conjuguent de
vives interrogations quant à l'intérêt
thérapeutique des mesures d'isolement ou
de contention dans beaucoup de cas c'est
le conseil de l'europe ceci il convient
de reconnaître que le recours à des
mesures de contention semble être
influencé de manière non négligeable par
des facteurs non clinique depuis lors de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour proposer
des alternatives à des mesures qui
connaissent effectivement presque
intrinsèquement le risque de dérives
certes il faut combler le vide et le
présent amendement acte d'urgence mais
nous ne pouvons pas accepter l'absence
d'un débat sur les mesures d'isolement
et de contention nous proposons donc de
limiter l'application de cet article à
trois ans c'est un délai que nous
trouvons très raisonnable pour qu'enfin
ce type d'amendements trouvent leur
place dans un texte ultérieur relatifs à
la santé mentale qui est le texte qui
doit voir le enfin le jour et ouvrir le
débat nécessaire avec l'ensemble des
parties concernées
voilà
l'avis de la commission
mais c'est monsieur le président je
partage le constat nos collègues sur une
prise en compte insuffisante de la santé
mentale mais par contre je considère
qu'elle prend un énorme risque en
mettant une une période de trois ans
parce que si à l'issue de ces trois ans
aucune disposition n'est prise eh bien
on se retrouve à nouveau dans la
situation actuelle avec un vide
juridique
donc c'est un avis défavorable
explications de vote mais je le prix
or madame le maire s'était même avis
même avis
oui merci monsieur le président
il n'est pas inutile finalement d'avoir
un délai
puisque si on regarde bien l'évolution
de la psychiatrie depuis quelques années
maintenant le premier rapport que j'ai
fait sur sur la psychiatrie date quand
même de 2009
depuis en 2009 on m'avait promis qu on
fait une loi sur la santé mentale qu'on
ferait une loi sur le financement des
hôpitaux psychiatriques
marisol touraine l'avait promis agnès
buzyn l'a promis olivier vers on est en
train d'essayer de mettre en place un
plan de financement des hôpitaux
psychiatriques
je pense que si on ne met pas un délai
pour nous obliger à faire une véritable
ovation à santé mentale on n'y arrivera
pas donc personnellement purement un
titre personnel je voterai l'amendement
d'impôts c'est manger
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
je la vois pas ce qu'ils sont favorables
à cet amendement le manifeste en levant
la main
avis contraire
nous rencontrons
ceux qui sont favorables de manifestants
devant la map regardez la main assez
longtemps levée
avis contraire
n'est pas adopté
mes chers collègues
je vais maintenant mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi
ah oui l'article 3 j'ai oublié de faire
voter
ceux qui sont favorables manifestants
devant la main
avis contraire s'en suit alors donnez
moi je suis donc maintenant adopter je
vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi j'ai reçu une demande de
scrutin public
sur le projet de loi émanant du groupe
duras mais républicain
demandes d'explications de vote
à monsieur bonnecarrère monsieur ravier
monsieur benarroch je suis bon tard déjà
inscrit
très brièvement nash carrière
très brièvement monsieur le président
notre groupe approuvera très
majoritairement le texte en la rédaction
à laquelle on vient d'aboutir après un
débat apaisé et nourris nous
l'approuverons par esprit de
responsabilité puisqu'il n'y a pas
actuellement de meilleures solutions
proposées au regard du passé ni terre ou
vaccinale mais avec les quatre
adjonction modifications essentielles
qui ont été apportées dans nos débats
avec la clause de caducité ou la clause
de sortie à laquelle nous tenons tout
particulièrement les modifications pour
les entreprises les modifications pour
pour les jeunes pour les l'essentiel
voilà l'explication de notre approbation
favorable merci monsieur le président
monsieur belleroche
[Applaudissements]
monsieur vers ans le 16 décembre vous
félicitiez de freiner ce variant avec
succès oui je sais qu'il n'est pas la
boire
comme quoi notre il faut pas le faire
remarquer quand même
comme quoi notre stratégie d'isolement
de ce traçage de séquençage de criblage
et fonctionnel et le 22 vous nous
annoncez sur une matinale je vous ai dit
que l'objectif n'était pas de réduire
les contaminations parce que le variant
est trop contagieux l'objectif est de
limiter les risque de formes graves de
saturation des hôpitaux et puis vous
publier ce texte pour montrer tout le
sérieux de votre stratégie sanitaire le
même temps ça doit être ça à la fois
supprimé dans la justification légale de
la prise de mesures le terme de
propagation ce qui nous permet de
déduire que cette lutte contre la
propagation n'est plus celle de
gouvernement et en même temps nous
assurer aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle je
n'ai jamais dit que nous ne serons plus
de lutter contre la diffusion du virus
j'ai dit que les armes étaient
différentes bon j'aimerais bien savoir
de quelles armes différentes vous parlez
monsieur verrons je suis d'accord avec
vous enfin avec le vous de ce milieu
d'après-midi pour lutter contre la
circulation
mais dans ce cas pourquoi monsieur
verront les masques à l'extérieur est
toujours pas de ffp 2 pour les
enseignants elle intérieur des écoles ou
dans les transports au combat pourquoi
si peu de détecteurs de co2 mais si
j'écoute votre position de ce matin
assumant que les mesures traditionnelles
les gens j'ai un tiers par exemple n'ont
pas véritablement d'impact sur var your
aussi contagieux que celui ci je ne
comprends pas pourquoi dans ce cas la
notion des gens j'apparais dans cette
loi pour les rassemblements pourquoi
vous maintenez fermer les discothèques
au fait pourquoi vous choisissez les
lieux où il est plus ou moins bien
d'aller se contaminer je pense que même
si vous en défendez votre politique et
de laisser circuler ce virus il est trop
contagieux et tout ceci en espérant que
l'hôpital et les soignants tienne mais
notre groupe qui est pour la vaccination
c'est une chose pour nous pas pour tous
les pays du monde et nous vous
encourageons à aller chercher les gens
qui sont les plus éloignés avec leur
parcours de vie du mode du soin nous
refusons malgré tout cette société de
contrôle nous refusons cette volonté
punitive de contraintes nous refusons
cette latitude trop grande accordée au
pouvoir exécutif dans la détermination
l'application de temps de mesures
restrictives et liberticide et nous ne
voterons donc pas ce texte besoins des
rangs
monsieur ravier
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues un monsieur le rapporteur
philippe bas issus de la majorité à
l'ère du sénat a évoqué un débat
philosophique pour commencer l'examen de
ce texte en disant que les libertés
étaient sacrés mais qu'elle n'était pas
absolue ce faisant ainsi et ce faisant
encore le rapporteur de l'elysée quand
les moyens choisis sont adaptés
nécessaire et proportionnée en vue du
bien commun chacun peut accepter de
restreindre sa liberté ce fut le cas au
premier confinement mais dix huit mois
se sont écoulés dix-huit mois d'
analyses scientifiques qui démontrent
les mêmes incidences contagieuse chez
les non vaccinés comme chez les vaccinés
et vous vous obstinez ensuite que ce ne
remportera ajouté que la liberté
consiste à pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne
nuit pas à autrui si je traduis les non
vaccinés sont nuisibles vous reprenez
ainsi les éléments de langage de
monsieur macro vous chercher des boucs
émissaires alors permettez moi de vous
dire mes chers collègues en particulier
aux vaccinaux lattre que les
irresponsables ce ne sont pas ceux qui
refusent l'obligation vaccinale ce sont
ceux qui ont plongé l'hôpital dans la
détresse en cause des suppressions de
postes des 15000 suspension de personnel
soignant non vaccinés et des fermetures
de lits par dizaines de milliers votre
rigueur budgétaire a tué la rigueur
sanitaires et c'est cette folie que vous
voulez masquer tout ce qui est à
martyriser les libertés les français
comme le chef de l'état candidat vous
voudriez que l'arbre du coc vie depuis
se cacher votre funeste bilan adopté ce
vaste se passe vaccinale c'est accepter
la logique du pass pour tous les sujets
de la vie passe sanitaire vaccinale
passe électoral passe écologique nos
libertés très basse à la fin de ce texte
et malgré toutes vos gesticulations vous
fermez les yeux devant la disparition
durable de nos droits et des libertés
fondamentales en votant sous le coup de
la peur et non sous la conduite de la
raison impasse vaccinale qui n'aura
aucun impact sur l'épidémie de kobe 19
alors j'en appelle directement aux
français que l'évidence et la providence
les guides pour s'administrer le moment
venu le vaccin électorale qui les
soulagera de ceux qui auront insulté et
divisé le pays de la liberté de
l'égalité et de la fraternité quant à
moi je vote toutes mes forces contre ce
texte et les intentions de ses auteurs
monsieur le président gothard
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre voilà deux jours que nous
débattons et je constate qu'on on a bien
fait de débattre sereinement et de
prendre ce temps du débat et de ne pas
avoir cédé à l'urgence on est dans un
pays aujourd'hui particulièrement
divisée on a besoin il ya une vraie
nécessité à la fois de concorde de
cohésion je pense qu'on a besoin
d'humilité de beaucoup d'humilité d'un
discours de vérité ce qui on le voit
bien ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui ne le
sera pas forcément demain et on l'a vu
tout au long de cette de cette crise
sanitaire
en tout cas on n'a certainement pas
besoin de clivages et on aurait traité
très jamais assez que la vaccination est
indispensable la vaccination protège et
évitent la propagation la vaccination
sauve des vies on voit bien c'est pas
suffisant et je regrette qu'on soit
toujours dans une simple logique de
contraintes d'obligations et que l'on
ait oublié l'essentiel la santé et je me
demande toujours d'ailleurs dans ce
concept des riffs quelle est l'étape
d'après nous avons au contraire besoin
d'une stratégie durable face au virus et
c'est cette absence de stratégie qui est
aujourd'hui inquiétante je rappelle que
plus de 1200 scientifiques appellent à
une vision beaucoup plus bleue global
avec à la fois une action internationale
sur la levée des brevets je rappelle qu
y en a 4 millions de personnes encore
avec sin en france et 4 milliards dans
le monde on a besoin de protection avec
le fpp 2 avec les détecteurs de co2 ça a
été dit de renforcer la proximité là les
verts d'aller vers les publics les plus
éloignés de renforcer notre hôpital et
de lancer un véritable plan de soutien
de remettre le contrôle parlementaire au
coeur et sur chacun de ces domaines le
gouvernement est absent et vous l'avez
hélas encore confirmé madame la ministre
le virus mute sadate et il est urgent de
s'adapter également et de mettre en
oeuvre une véritable stratégie durable
et internationales de protection et là
ce soir nous sommes très loin du compte
donc nous ne voterons pas ce texte merci
l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
depuis le début de cette crise le groupe
rdse dans sa grande majorité a voté en
responsabilité et avec un seul objectif
éviter un maximum de décès de nos
concitoyens c'est pour cela que nous
avons accepté des fois avec quelques
aigreurs de brider nos libertés
publiques nous restons persuadés
aujourd'hui que la vaccination si elle
n'empêche pas la propagation du virus
elle diminue fortement les cas graves et
les décès et nul ne peut nier cela ici
face à cette cinquième vague il nous
semble que l'effort nécessite encore de
franchir ce cap du pass vaccinale je
tiens à saluer le travail réalisé par
les commissions
et l'ensemble des sénateurs et nous et
nous rapportera premier lieu et le
groupe r d se satisfait que nous ayons
obtenu quelques avancées
très proposé par ma collègue nathalie
delattre savoir les georges les sur les
erp et l'obligation pour les plus de 18
ans et l'amendement de notre président
sur l'autorisation d'un seul parent pour
la vaccination des mineurs on rajoute
aura aussi la satisfaction sur l'abandon
de la présentation d'obligations de
papiers d'identité
aussi pour toutes ces raisons comme je
l'avais dit en discussion générale la
grande majorité du groupe rdse votera
favorablement pour ce texte merci mais
ce soir
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je ne vais pas reprendre ce qui
a été dit sur l'article 1 nous avons
choisi de voter ce texte
la très grande majorité de notre groupe
après une grande réflexion et en faisant
le choix avec notre ami bernard jomier
avec tous les collègues du groupe de la
responsabilité nous sommes pour
l'obligation vaccinale
nous avons considéré que le texte
proposé par le gouvernement s'en
rapprocher d'ailleurs ça a été dit par
les membres dudit gouvernement et donc
il aurait été incompréhensible que nous
fassions un autre choix mais j'insiste
sur le fait que ce choix était assorti
des mesures qui ont été adoptées ici en
ce qui concerne tout particulièrement
les libertés
le contrôle d'identité le refus qui est
le nôtre de voir un mélange qui aurait
été désastreux le fait qu'il y ait eu un
vote
303 voix contre 37 hier soir est à cet
égard très important et je terminerai en
m'adressant à madame la ministre
madame la ministre le gouvernement
bien sûr la majorité elle rêve ici et à
l'assemblée sera soumise un choix lors
de la commission mixte paritaire et
ensuite
et il est possible de toujours de jouer
l'intransigeance
la volonté d'avoir raison y compris
contre notre assemblée je veux vous dire
ici du fond du coeur que ce serait une
profonde erreur
et que j'aspire vraiment à ce que demain
soit pris en compte les apports du sénat
parce que notre débat il a été de bonne
qualité et je crois qu'il mérite
vraiment d'être entendue au service de
notre population
je vous remercie merci
mon parent lui que notre collègue hervé
explications de vote merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre au mois
d'avril quand le pass sanitaire a été
inventé il ne devait durer que l'espace
d'un été c'était suffisamment beau et
romantique pour qu'un certain nombre de
nos collègues majoritairement croisée de
promesses et puis en juillet il a été
étendu puis il a été cet automne
généralisée et ce soir le sénat
s'apprête à accepter un tour de vis
supplémentaire
finalement les libertés publiques sont
le seul levier qui nous reste pour
croire qu'on puisse faire reculer cette
contamination
et ce virus je pense que c'est une
erreur je les dis a à plusieurs reprises
et dans cet escalier sans fin de la
contrainte des libertés publiques je me
pose une question ce soir c'est de
savoir quelle sera l'étape
supplémentaire l'étape suivante quelle
idée alors que nous allons entrer dans
la période la plus importante de la vie
démocratique de notre pays avec les
élections présidentielles puis
législatives
quelle sera l'étape supplémentaire
qu'est ce qu'on proposera encore de plus
pour essayer de contraindre sans qu'
aucun des résultats finalement deux
soient convaincants pour que l'on fasse
reculer sur et donc moi je voterai
évidemment
contre ce texte comme j'ai voté contre
l'article 1er comme j'ai toujours voté
contre se passe sanitaire puis vaccinale
et j'espère que notre pays sera retrouvé
le chemin de la raison et le chemin de
la protection des libertés publiques il
faut alors que en europe en ce moment
d'autres pays prennent d'autres
décisions qui vont dans d'autres
directions et que l'humilité
commande aussi de regarder ce qui se
passe ailleurs et et de regarder comment
on peut être et rester le pays de la
liberté
merci madame la présidente à celle ci
merci monsieur le président
à l'issue de notre débat qui s'est
déroulé dans un climat je pense qu'ils
honorent notre assemblée je confirme que
mon groupe ne votera pas pour pour ce
projet de loi alors il ne le votera pas
pour des raisons que j'ai déjà
longuement évoqué enfin longuement que
j'ai évoquées lors de dans la discussion
générale c'est à dire que ce texte qui
instaure le pass vaccinale n'apporte
rien de nouveau en termes de moyens
nouveaux dégagé pour notre système de
santé les personnels concernés et il ne
remet pas en cause une logique
autoritaire malgré la suppression des
contrôles d'identité adoptées par notre
assemblée grâce à des amendements dont
l'un déposé par déposée par mon groupe
alors au delà de la nécessité de se
faire vacciner
et puis des efforts qu'il reste à faire
pour convaincre les plus éloignés voire
les mêmes même les plus
recchi son ce projet de loi met de côté
des mesures pourtant simple à mettre en
oeuvre pour ralentir voire prévenir la
propagation de l'épidémie enfin mon
groupe regrette que la question de la
levée des brevets réitéré à plusieurs
reprises ici dans cet hémicycle mais
aussi dans d'autres lieux comme lors de
l'audition de monsieur verrons cette
semaine donc cette question soit
systématiquement balayé d'un revers de
la main pour éviter le débat sur la
nécessité de vacciner l'ensemble de la
planète et donc sur l'urgence d'exiger
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui se
sont bien enrichie ces derniers ces
derniers temps ce pur donc exigé de ses
laboratoires qui participent à garantir
le droit universel à la santé pour tous
et partout donc voilà je confirme notre
opposition à ce texte
[Applaudissements]
nous avons entendu la promesse de ne
jamais rendre la vaccination obligatoire
en passant par la promesse de ne jamais
généraliser le pass sanitaires aux actes
de la vie courante puis de n'est jamais
transformée en passe vaccinale que de
mensonges ont été proférées sans ciller
sans rougir pensez vous que les français
n'ont ni mémoire ni réflexion et pensez
vous qu'ils ont encore confiance j'ai
retrait donc contre se passe vaccinale
merci merci monsieur le pays de rocaille
où
monsieur le président madame la ministre
voilà nous sommes au terme de l'examen
d'un texte qui parfois déchaîné les
passions mais nous allons pour mon
groupe voté très majoritairement un
texte qui a été significativement
améliorée il a été amélioré d'abord
grâce au travail des deux commissions et
de deux rapporteurs que je remerciés il
était aussi amélioré beaucoup l'ont
souligné grâce au climat de sérénité le
sénat est encore un lieu où on peut
avoir un débat démocratique sera une
conversation civique en maintenant des
arguments quel que soit d'ailleurs nos
positionnements des uns et des autres
mais en débattant pour améliorer la loi
et pour faire en sorte qu'elle vise
l'intérêt commun
elle le doit aussi à vous monsieur le
président qui avait refusé la semaine
dernière que nous légiférerons dans
l'hystérie qui avaient été suscitées par
certains de propos et je pense que nous
y avions gagné et chacun a pris aussi sa
part quelles que soient les groupes dans
ce climat maintenant demain madame la
ministre et vous aussi vous avez je
pense contribué à cette sérénité débat
je veux aussi vous en remercier mais
demain
vous aurez avec votre majorité à faire
des choix c'est la commission mixte
bytes je reprends ce qu'a dit en
d'autres termes notre collègue jean
pierre sueur il ya de choix en fait il
ya un choix qui consisterait au
gouvernement de balayer d'un revers de
main les apports la contribution du
sénat peut-être avec cette volonté
derrière politique politicienne de nous
rejeter dans le camp des anti vax pour
que la majorité s'octroie s'arroge le
monopole de la protection vaccinale des
français ce sera mauvais choix quel
autre choix qui vous ferez considéré que
dans une crise sanitaire profonde il
faut rechercher un minimum de consensus
que quand on veut imposer un outil lien
instruments comme le pass vaccinale il
faut tenter de dépasser les limites de
sa propre majorité c'est le choix que
vous aurez à faire que nous aurons à
faire ensemble demain nous tendons la
main mais nous ne ferons pas n'importe
quel prix le choix du rétrécissement ou
le choix de l'élargissement pour le bien
commun des français
messieurs
[Musique]
je vais maintenant ouvrir le scrutin
dans les conditions fixées
par l'article 56 de notre règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà il est 2 heures 28 du matin vous
êtes en direct sur public sénat pour
suivre la dernière étape de l'examen de
ce projet de loi de passes vaccinale les
équipes de public sénat sont toutes
mobilisées pour vous faire vivre cet
événement jusqu'au bout et en direct
vous le voyez donc un scrutin public sur
l'ensemble de ce texte et on l'a bien
compris ce texte va être sans aucun
doute adopter dans quelques instants
puisque il n'y a que deux groupes un
deux groupes qui s'opposent frontalement
aux textes les écologistes et les
communistes les autres groupes ont tous
dit y compris à l'instant le patron des
sénateurs a l'air qu'ils allaient voter
la version du sénat de ce projet de loi
de passes vaccinale même chose pour le
deuxième groupe en importance les
socialistes et également pour les
centristes alors bien sûr dans chaque
groupe il ya une liberté de vote donc
certains sénateurs ont appelé à
s'opposer mais il devrait être
minoritaire on devrait avoir le même
rapport de force que sur le vote de
l'article 1 qui transforme le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale c'était
vers 22h et à ce moment-là bon on avait
largement vu une majorité se dessiner en
faveur du texte le scrutin est clos
vient de dire gérard larcher dans
l'hémicycle on retourne dans l'hémicycle
pour écouter et bien le résultat
sur l'ensemble du texte
kruth un numéro 74 contenu de l'ensemble
des dgac des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au groupe
politique et le tiff ya la présidence
nombre de votants 338 donc de suffrages
exprimés 312 pour l'adoption 249 contre
63 le sénat a adopté forêt remercier
vous même madame la ministre ministres
verront nos deux rapporteurs et nous
deux présidents de commissions pour les
travaux kid qui l'ont conduit et vous
tous mes chers collègues avaient été
nombreux à suivre l'ensemble de ces
séances je vais lever la science la
prochaine séance aura lieu le jeudi 13
janvier c'est à dire aujourd'hui même à
11h30 pour l'examen de la proposition de
loi relative au port du casque à vélo et
dans le cas d'autres moyens de transport
la séance est levée bonne nuit
voilà vous venez de le vivre en direct
sur l'antenne de public sénat le sénat
qui adoptent ce projet de loi de passes
vaccinale avec une large majorité un
puisque je vous redonne ses chiffres sur
312 voix exprimées
249 pour 63 contre alors attention à le
texte adopté par le sénat est très
différent de celui de l'assemblée
nationale qui avait déjà été adopté la
semaine dernière au moins sur quatre
points puisque on a vu des critères de
mise en place et de lever du soleil
vaccinale on a vu aussi que se passe ne
concernerait pas les mineurs dans la
version du sénat également ce texte
supprime les contrôles d'identité des
cafetiers des restaurateurs dépasser
vaccinaux et enfin quatrième principale
différence il change les georges dans
les stades et dans les salles et de
spectacles et donc prochaine étape 2
pour ce projet de loi était l'examen en
commission mixte paritaire ça aura lieu
à l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure à
14 heures sept députés sept sénateurs
qui vont essayer de se mettre d'accord
sur une même version du texte c'est la
fin de cette émission vous avez suivre
comme cela en direct depuis 21h30
l'examen de ce projet de loi de passes
vaccinale j'aimerais remercier toutes
les équipes techniques à la rédaction
est aussi et bien sûr plus ixina point
fr qui vous ont fait vivre ce débat très
bonne nuit sur public sénat
le domaine d expertise de notre invité
ses l'atome la physique quantique les
particules et à tout cela il donne un
sens une cohérence il en fait même de la
philosophie etienne klein va t'il nous
aider à mieux comprendre ce monde rendez
vous dans un monde un regard les
entretiens de public sénat un monde un
regard avec etienne klein vendredi à 19h
sur public sénat
[Musique]